...
I hope part TALENT FROM HIS
event will be to invite tout
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS AND
EXPLORATION.
MY
GROUP DIGITAL INITIATIVE IS
LED BY CARLA HAYDEN.
WE CONSIDER IT PART OF OUR JOB
TO DO THAT FOR THE DIGITAL
COLLECTION.
WITH THAT IN MIND, I'D LIKE TO
SHARE WITH YOU, A FEW OF THE
THINGS WE HAVE GOING ON.
THE FIRST IS CROWD
SOURCING
WHILE TOM WAS HERE AND AN INSO
VITALY NINAKOVOR, HE HAD A SHORT
TIME WITH US.
AND IT'S AN APPLICATION BUILT ON
THE SCRIBED PLATFORM.
CREATE BIDE YOUR PUBLIC LIBRARY,
THAT INVITES PEOPLE TO IDENTIFY
PHOTOS  AND CARTOONS  AND TO
UPDATE THE CAPTIONS.
YOU CAN SEE SOME REALLY AWFUL
OCR
HERE.
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE PEOPLE TO
PLAY WITH CONGRESSIONAL DATA AND
FIND WAYS TO MAKE OUR DEMOCRACY,
YOU KNOW, EVEN MORE ROBUST USING
THE INFORMATION WE'RE MAKING
AVAILABLE.
WE HOPE TO HAVE THE KE TAILS.I
AM THRILLD  TO GIVE YOU GUYS A
SNEAK PEAK INTO WHAT WE'RE
LAUNCHING IN A FEW MONTHS.
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A PLATFORM OF
PLAY AND DISCOVERY WITH THE
DIGITAL COLLECTION.
MY HOPE IS THAT THIS WILL REDUCE
THE RESTRICTION TO INNOVATION
AND BELLE WE'LL BE ABLE TO USE
IT AS
INNO WE'LL BE ABLE TO USE
IT FOR NDI AND HOST INNOVATORS
AND
RELEVANCE.
WHEN I WRITE CODE, AUTO MOSTLY
ME STARING AT A SCREEN, TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHY IT'S DOING
THAT.
SO WHILE I HAVE YOU TRAPPED
HERE.
I'D LIKE TO SELFISHLY GO THROUGH
A THROUGH THINGS.
THE FIRST IS JOBS.
THERE ARE SOME REALLY COOL JOBS
POSTED RIGHT NOW.
AND I HAVE A FEELING THERE WILL
BE MORE JOBS POSTED  IN THE
FUTURE WE WANT  NEED YOUR GOOD
BRAINS TO COME HERE F. YOU FIND
JOB LIKE YOUR FRIEND MIGHT BE
GOOD FOR.
PLEASE SEND IT AND CHECK BACK
VERY OFTEN.
THE SECOND, THE FELLOWSHIP IN
DIGITAL STUDIES.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO COME HERE
FOR A LIFETIME, WHICH YOU
SHOULD.
YOU CAN COME HERE FOR JUST A
VISIT WANT THESE ARE PAID
FELLOWSHIPS TO BRING PEOPLE INTO
THE LIBRARY TO STUDY THE
REVOLUTION ON SOCIETY USING
LIBRARY
COLLECTION.
DON'T NOT APPLY BECAUSE YOU'RE
WORRIED.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO CALL, YOU
DON'T HAVE TO.
IT'S REALLY FUN.
AND WE'LL HAVE TWO SCHOLARS
PRESENTING THE LIGHTNING ROUND.
IF YOU'RE INSPIRED BY THEIR
WORK, PLEASE COME AND APPLY.
THEY CAN AWARD ONE A YEAR.
SO SHARE IT WITH YOUR FRIENDS.
THE SECOND, THE THIRD IS
INNOVATORS AND RESIDENTS.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING HARD ON THE
INNOVATORS AND RESIDENTS PROJECT
HERE TO BRING PEOPLE INTO THE
LIBRARY FOR SHORT-TERM, HI
IMPACT TECHNICAL
PROJECTS.
AND THE IDEA BEHIND THIS IS TO
BRING SOME FRESH IDEAS.
NEW BLOOD, GREAT BRAIN TO,
CREATE ACCESS POINTS TO THE
COLLECTION.
INNOVATE ORS AND RESIDENTS
PROJECTS, INCLUDE THE CROWD
SOURCING
PROJECT, A MARKED TO
HELP INTERACT AND WE'LL HAVE
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THIS
YEAR,
TOO THANK YOU FOR COMING.
I'M SO GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
IN THE MEANTIME, PLEASE CHECK
THE BLOG.
YOU CAN SIGN UP FOR E-MAIL
ALERTS.
WE DON'T HAVE TIME FOR QUESTIONS
TODAY.
IT'S WALL-TO-WALL INFORMATION
INTO YOUR BRAIN.
BUT WE'RE ENCOURAGING YOU TO
PLEASE INTERACT WITH THE
SPEAKERS DIRECTLY ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
YOU CAN ALSO COMMENT ON THE BLOG
WITH ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU
MUCH.
>> THANK YOU, KATE.
EDWARD AIRS WILL KICKOFF
WITH "HISTORY BETWEEN THE
LINES.
THINKING ABOUT COLLECTIONS AS
DATA" ED IS THE PROFESSOR OF HOW
MUCHITIES  AND THE PRESIDENT
EMERATIS AT UNIVERSITY OF
RICHMOND.
PERIOD [AWARD HIM THE NATIONAL
MEDAL IN 2013 FOR HIS DEDICATION
TO PUBLIC HISTORY.
ED HAS TRIED TO FIND NEW WAYS TO
CONNECT PEOPLE WITH THE AMERICAN
PAST.
CURRENT PROJECTS INCLUDE THE
BACK STORY PODCAST, BUNK
HISTORY.ORG, THE AMERICAN CIVIL
WAR MUSEUM AND SERVING AS
PRESIDENT OF THE ORGANIZATION OF
AMERICAN HISTORIANS.
PLEASE WELCOME ED AYRES.
[APPLAUSE].
>> GOOD MORNING, EVERYBODY.
GOOD MORNING!
SO I'VE BEEN ASKED TO COVER
SEVERAL
DECADES OF DIGITAL
STUFF.
AND YOU MIGHT THINK I HAVE IT
FIGURED OUT BY NOW, BUT I DON'T
BECAUSE THE FRONTIER KEEPS
MOVING ON US, AND IT'S REALLY
EXCITED TO THINK ABOUT WHERE WE
ARE AND WHERE WE'VE BEEN.
I THINK THE REVOLUTION WE'RE
LIVING THROUGH NOW, BEGAN BEFORE
THE DIGITAL.
I THINK IT ACTUALLY BEGAN, AND
IT'S A DANGEROUS THING TO SAY,
IN FRONT OF PEOPLE NA ACTUALLY
KNOW THE TRUTH.
THERE'S NO Q & A RIGHT NOW.
I BELIEVE THAT THE REVOLUTION
ACTUALLY BEGAN WITH THE MICRO
FILM REVOLUTION, THE 1930'S,
40'S, AND 50'S, WHEN WE UNLOCKED
THIS REMARKABLE TECHNOLOGY, THAT
ALLOWED US TO HAVE ALL THE
NEWSPAPERS  IN AMERICAN HISTORY
THAT WOULD HAVE THE UNITED
STATES CENSUS.
ALL THESE BOUNTIFUL DOCUMENTS,
AVAILABLE TO RESEARCHERS,
ANYWHERE, FOR RELATIVELY SMALL
COSTS AND EVEN THOUGH MICRO FILM
SEEMS UNSEXY TODAY, IT WAS MY
INTRODUCTION NOT ONLY TO ALL
THINGS DIGITAL BUT THE HISTORY
ITSELF.
I WASN'T SURE WHAT WHAT I WANTED
TO DO, EVEN WHEN I WAS IN
GRADUATE SCHOOL.
BUT ONE DAY I WENT INTO THE MIKE
FORM ROOM AND START READING
THERE ARES ON ONE OF THE BIG
WORLD WAR II
ERAS, GRAY THINGS
WITH THE CRANKS ON IT.
AND THERE IN FRONT OF ME, I SAW
SOMETHING REMARKABLE.
THESE NEWSPAPERS DEMONSTRATED
SOMETHING I HAD NOT REALIZED.
PEOPLE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN THE NEXT DAY AND
AIL THIS STUFF WAS HAPPENING AT
THE SAME TIME THAT YOU WOULD SEE
ON ONE PAGE THE NEWS I
RECOGNIZED FROM THE TEXT BOOK
AND ON THE OTHER PAGES, THE
NEAT, ALL KINDS OF FASCINATING
THINGS OF EVOLUTION OF LIFE
BEFORE OUR VERY EYES AND I
REALIZED, THAT'S WHAT I'M
INTERESTED IN IS ALL THAT
RESIDENTS, AND INTERACTION, THAT
SPACE BETWEEN THE LINES, THAT
SENSE OF POSSIBILITY THAT WAS ON
EVERY SCREEN OF THAT OLD SCRATCH
MIKE FILM ON THAT ARCHAIC
DEVICE.
SO I WROTE MY DISSERTATION
PARTLY ON THAT.
WHEN I BECAME A TEACHER, I SAID,
YOU KNOW, IT WOULD BE FUN TO
INTRODUCE ALL THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
TO THE GLORY OF MICRO FILM.
SO I SENT THEM INTO THE MICRO
FORM'S ROOM, IF FRONT OF THESE
MACHINES, AND THEY WERE
COMPLETELY ADDLED.
THIS WAS IN THE 80'S, AND THE
ENTIRE ASSIGNMENT WAS READ A
YEAR OF THIS NEWSPAPER AND WRITE
ABOUT SOMETHING INTERESTING IN
IT AND ALL THE PREMED PEOPLE IN
THE CLASS WERE JUST FREAKING
OUT.
BUT WHAT'S THE ASSIGNMENT?
THAT IS THE ASSIGNMENT.
WHAT IS THE QUESTION?
THAT'S FOR YOU TO FIND OUT AND
TO ANSWER IT.
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THAT
EVALUATION, AT A COME BACK IN
AND SAID, WE DIDN'T LIKE AYRES
THAT MUCH, BUT SEEING HISTORY
RAW IS ONE OF THE MOST EXCITING
THINGS I'VE DONE IN MY COLLEGE
EDUCATION.
I ALREADY NEW THAT MAGIC, THAT
POWER LAY IN THAT
MEDIUM.
ONE DAY, I WAS IN THE LIBRARY,
AND I SAW A GLEAMING, BLACK
MACHINE.
I SAW THAT AMAZING AS IT SEEMED
AT THAT TIME,
THAT IMAGES OF
MICRO FILMS AND MAPS, CAN BE
SEEN ON A COMPUTER SCREEN IN
COLOR.
WEBS DIDN'T EXIST YET.
SO, FOR INSTANCE, MY LIBRARY
TOLD ME ABOUT A MAGICAL THING
CALLED S GM L.
STANDARD GENERALIZED MARK-UP
LANGUAGE OR AS WE CALLED IT,
SOUNDS GOOD, MAYBE LATER.
AND WE SAW IN THAT, A WAY TO
BUILD SOMETHING THAT WOULD
IDENTIFY ALL THESE DIFFERENT
OBJECTS AND CONNECT THEM WITH
EACH OTHER.
I HAD THE IDEA, HEY, WHAT COW
SAY WE SHARE WITH PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO A MAJOR
RESOURCE LIBRARY, WHO DON'T HAVE
A BANK OF MICRO FILM READERS.
A WAY TO GET THAT EXCITEMENT FOR
THEMSELVES.
WE START BUILDING IT.
AND ONE DAY, A FRIEND CALLED ME
DOWN AND SAID, YOU NEED TO SEE
THIS.
HERE'S SOMETHING THEY'RE CALLING
THE WORLD WIDE WEB AND IT'S
BASED ON A BABY VERSION OF S GM
L.
WE CAN THINK WHAT THEY'RE
CALLATION SITE FOR THIS WORLD
WIDE WEB PRETTY QUICKLY AND SO
WE DID.
SO WE WERE OUT THERE AT THE VERY
BEGINNING, BEFORE WE WERE READY,
BEFORE WE KNEW WHAT WE WERE
DOING.
BUT WHAT WE DID KNOW IS SUDDENLY
F YOU HAD PLENTY OF PATIENCE,
YOU COULD WATCH AN ENGINE OF A
NEWSPAPER, VERY SLOWLY, APPEAR
ON YOUR SCREEN OVER THAT 240,
2400 BAUD MODEM.  AND PEOPLE
LIKED IT.
SO WE STARTED BUILDING A
MOUNTAIN AND WE BUILT THIS FIRST
PROJECT THAT MANY MUCH YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD OF, THE VALUE OF
SHADOW IT'S LIKE IF I COME UP,
I'M GOING TO SEE MY TALK ON THIS
SCREEN, ON THE HP IF I COULD,
PLEASE.
LET'S SEE IF THIS WORKS.
I WANTED TO SEE ALL OF THE TABS
WE MADE
BEFORE.
IF NOSE TIMES ARE GONE, FOR SOME
REASON, CAN YOU GO BACK AND CALL
THAT OUT.
SO IT'S CALLED THE VALLEY OF THE
SHADOW, AND THE SHORT VERSION
IS, EVERY PIECE OF INFORMATION
ABOUT EVERY PERSON WHO LIVED IN
A NORTHERN COMMUNITY AND
SOUTHERN COMMUNITY, THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE AMERICAN CIVIL CIVIL
WAR.
IT REASON IT DOES EXIST, IF I
CAN ACTUAL, AND YOU SEE WHAT WE
D WE EMULATED AN ARCHIVE.
THIS WAS REALLY, REALLY HARD TO
BUILD.
IT TOOK US 14 YEARS TO DO IT
BECAUSE WHAT WE WERE DOING IS
DESCRIBING BY HAND, 10,000 PAGES
OF NEWSPAPERS AND THIS
CONVENIENT THING IS CALLED PDF
FILES THAT EXIST REQUESTED WE
START.
SO WE HAD
SED WHEN WE
-- FILE
THAT IS EXITED.
THIS CAME OUT IN THE MID 90S
AND 2003, I WROTE AN AN LOG BOOK
ABOUT IT.
AT THE BEGINNING IT SAYS, BY THE
WAY, THIS IS BASED ENTIRELY ON A
DIGITAL ARCHIVE THAT YOU CAN SEE
EVERY SOURCE I USED.
THAT CAME OUT IN 2003.
THEN ARTS  AND SCIENCES AT UVA,
AND I LEFT UVA TO BECOME
PRESIDENT AT RICHMOND AND THIS
IS IMPORTANT FOR ALL THINGS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
UNIVERSITY OF VIRGINIA, RATHER
THAN BEING MAD AT ME, SAID, L
WE'VE BEEN HAPPY TO SEE THE
CREATION OF THIS BIG THING.
WHAT DO YOU SAY WE MAKE SURE,
THAT GIVE THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS, 10 YEARS FROM NOW THAT
IT STILL WORKS OR THAT HE WRITES
VOLUME 2 OUT OF THE VALLEY OF
THE SHADOW THAT AM CONSIST OUT
IN OCTOBER, THE THIN LINE OF
FREEDOM AND HERE'S THE THING.
I SAT THERE AND HIT ON THIS
THING AS FAR AS AS HARD AS I
COULD, FOR A YEAR AND A HALF,
AFTER IT STILL HASN'T BEEN
TOUCHED.
PEOPLE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
VIRGINIA WENT BACK THROUGH AND
CHECKED EVERY LINK TO MAKE SURE
IT ALL STILL WORKS.  THAT'S
IMPORTANT.
WE WONDER IF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE USING TO MAKE THIS DIGITAL
ENVIRONMENT.
EVEN MICRO
FILM.
SO THE VALLEY OF THE SHADOWS
SHOWS THAT IT CAN.
AND I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.BUT
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS, WHEN
I LEFT VIRGINIA, I SAID, YOU
KNOW, OKAY.
TRANSCRIBING BY HAND, AN ENTIRE
INTENTIONAL ARCHIVE, THAT WAS
FUN.
WELL, WHAT DO YOU SAY THAT WE
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ALL THE
PREDIGITIZED SOURCES THAT HAD
EMERGED SINCE 1993 WHEN WE
STARTED THE VALLEY OF THE
SHADOWS.
I BET THERE ARE LOTS OF THINGS
THAT WE CAN PUT TO IMMEDIATE USE
AND SO WHEN I WENT TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF
RICHMOND
WE HAD
MANY NEW PROJECTS AND ONE OF
WHICH IS AMERICAN PANORAM A
WHICH IS A DIGITAL ATLAS OF
AMERICAN HISTORY.
AND THE IDEA THERE WAS LET'S
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF SAY, TWO OF
THESE.
THIS IS THE FORCED MICRO LOAN
OPERATION OF ENSLAVED PEOPLE.AND
I REALLY DO WANT TO EXPLORE
T. AND WHAT IT DOES, IT, BASED
ON THE UNITED STATES CENSUS,
WHICH IS ALREADY A N MACHINE
READABLE FORM.
THINK ABOUT T IT'S GOING TO COME
UP HERE.
LET'S MAKE A KIND OF MAP OF THE
SLAVE TRADE AND THE MOVEMENT OF
AFRICAN-AMERICAN PEOPLE ACROSS
THE VAST SOUTH.
THE AMERICAN NETWORK IS STILL
THINK BEING THAT HERE.
BUT THE IDEA WAS TO SEE THINGS
WE COULD NOT SEE BEFORE BUT THAT
WERE ALREADY HIDDEN BETWEEN THE
LINES OF THE DATA.
BEING ABLE TO SEE THAT THE AREAS
OF THE SOUTH THAT WERE LOSING
ENORMOUS NUMBERS OF PEOPLE, AND
OTHERS WHO WERE GAINING ENORMOUS
NUMBERS AND COME THROUGH THE
NETWORK HERE.
LET'S SEE IF THE OTHER ONE
WORKS.
MAYBE WE CAN SWITCH OVER TO THE
MAP.
FORGET YOU SAW THAT.
THAT'S ANOTHER PART OF WHAT I'M
SHOWING.
WHEN I SAY WE, I DON'T LITERALLY
MEAN ME.
I MEAN MY COLLEAGUES, ROD
NELSON.
AND NATE AYRES WHO ARE MAKING
THESE PROJECTS, INTO THE
CAPACITIES OF COLLECTIONS WE
ALREADY HAVE.
THE OTHER ONE THAT WE MADE WAS
THE FOREIGN BORN POPULATION OF
THE UNITED STATES.
FROM 1850 TO 2010 AND IN THIS
CASE TO BE ABLE TO SEE, OKAY.
THAT GIVES YOU AN IDEA WHATEVER
IT LOOKS LIKE.
AND WE CAN CLICK ON ACCOUNTING,
AND IT WILL SHOW YOU ALL THE
PLACES, THAT ALL THE PEOPLE IN
THAT PLACE CAME FROM IN THAT
YEAR.
SO WHAT YOU'LL SEE IS THAT WE
ARE DISPLAYING DATA IF FOUR OR
FIVE DIFFERENT WAYS.
AND THERE, IT IS VERY SLOW WHERE
THE PEOPLE ARE COMING  FROM.
AND IT'LL SEND OUT
[INDISCERNIBLE] TO ALL THESE
PLACES.
BACK ON THE FORCED MICRO LOAN
OPERATION MAP.
WE COULD HAVE CLICKED ONE THING
AND IT HAD THE NARRATIVE FOR
PEOPLE WHO WERE SWEPT UP.
MERES SOMETHING, WE WERE ABLE TO
MAKE A MAP THAT GOT WIDESPREAD
ATTENTION, FROM SOURCES THAT
ALREADY EXIST AND WERE ABLE TO
MAKE WITH SOME SPEED NOW.
AND WHEN WE HAD LAST YEAR, NAME
ONE OF THE 15 TOP MAPS IN THE
WORLD, BY "NATIONAL
GEOGRAPHIC."
ABOUT MAPPING INEQUALITY.
A COLLABORATIVE PROJECT OF
RICHMOND.
JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY, AND
THE UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND TO
SHOW HOW IT WAS THAT SEGREGATION
BECAME BAKED INTO OUR CULT AND
YOU ARE MAPS OF OVER 150
AMERICAN CITIES.
WE HAVE A NEW MAP COMING OUT OF
URBAN DEVELOPMENT, THAT WILL
HAPPEN ALL THE INFORMATION.
A LOT OF IT HERE FROM WASHINGTON
ABOUT HOW IT WAS THAT OUR
CITIES, INCLUDING VERY SMALL
ONCE, WERE TRANSFORMED IN THE
1960'S BY THE INNER THE STATES
THROUGH THEM, AND BULLDOZING,
SUBSTANDARD HOUSING AND ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
SO ALL THESE HAD THE SAME IDEAS
AS VALLEY OF THE SHADOWS.
THERE IS ALL THIS ENORMOUS POWER
WITHIN OUR REACH THAT WE CAN
MAKE VISIBLE.
WE HAD THESE NUMBERS ABOUT WHERE
PEOPLE CAME FROM IN ALL THESE
PLACES EVERY YEAR.
BUT IF YOU CAN'T SEE IT, YOU
DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT IT
POSSESSES.
AND MY DREAM, TOO, IS THAT EVERY
MIDDLE SCHOOL KID IN AMERICA
WILL BE ABLE TO CLICK ON HER
COUNTY AND SEE HOW THAT HAS
EVOLVED OVER THE COURSE OF
AMERICAN HISTORY.
TO SEE THAT UNITED STATES HAS
ALWAYS BEEN TOGETHER, PEOPLE
FROM A BROAD RANGE OF PLACES.
THE THINGS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY, ARE JUST THE LATEST STAGE
IN A VERY LONG
CONVERSATION.
SO WITH THE AMERICAN PANORAM A
DIGITAL SCHOLARSHIP LAB, THE
VALLEY OF THE SHADOW TURNED
WRONG INSIDE OUT.
INSTEAD OF TAKING AN 65, THAT'S
SCATTERED ALL AROUND, AND
NEGLECTED AND MAKING IT VISIBLE,
WHICH WAS A WORTHY THING TO DO.
WHAT DO YOU SAY THAT WE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ENORMOUS RESOURCES
THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED IN MAKING
THINGS MACHINE READABLE.
BUT THAT STILL DIDN'T HAVE THE
NEWSPAPERS I WAS DREAMING OF.
SO
THE SO MAYBE SWITCH BACK TO
THE H.P. AND SEE THE NETWORK IS
DOING PLENTY OF THINGS IN HERE.
CAN YOU GO BACK THERE AND SEE IF
CAN YOU GET RECONSTRUCTING
VIRGINIA.
YES.
WE CAN.
YOU REMEMBER HOW MUCH TROUBLE IT
WAS FOR PEOPLE TO SIT THERE AND
READ NEWSPAPERS ON MIKE FILM
TRANSCRIBE, FROM SCRATCH.
ALL THE ARTICLES, RUN A SUMMARY
ON THEM.
THERE ARE OVER 2,000 NEWSPAPERS
AND MILLIONS OF PAGES THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DIGITIZED.
WHAT CAN WE DO WITH THAT?
INSTEAD OF JUST SORT OF READING
THEM IN AN LOG FORM?
WELL OUR FRIENDS AT GEORGE MASON
DRIVE AND 16 EAGER FIRST-YEAR
STUDENTS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
RICHMOND AND VIRGINIA CHRONICLE,
WHICH IS THE VIRGINIA VERSION OF
CHRONICELLING AMERICA.
WE SAID, LET'S GO IN AND MAKE
VISIBLE TO THE WORLD, THE
LEADING NEWSPAPER IN VIRGINIA
DURING THIS TUMULTUOUS PERIOD OF
RECONSTRUCTION.
AND SO IN ONE SEMESTER, USING
THE EXPERTISE OF CHRIS KEMP IN
THE LIBRARY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
RICHMOND, WE WERE ABLE TO
TRANSCRIBE OR ACTUALLY CORRECT,
2,000 ARTICLES AND YOU CAN SEE
WHAT EACH ONE OF THEM LOOKS LIKE
AND EACH STUDENT TOOK
RESPONSIBILITY, AND THE
TRANSCRIPTION HAS ALREADY BEEN
DONE BY O.C.R. BUT THEY NEEDED
TO BE CORRECTED.
THEY WENT BACK IN AND CORRECTED
THEM AND IN A FORM OF CROWD
SOURCING, CONTRIBUTED THOSE BACK
INTO THE ARCHIVE, MAKING THE
ARCHIVE BETTER WHILE USING T. WE
HAVE ELABORATE TIME LINES,
BASICALLY, IN THREE MONTHS, WE
DID PROBABLY WHAT WOULD TAKE US
THREE YEARS BACK ON THE VALLEY
OF THE SHADOWS, BY USING OPEN
SOURCE SOFTWARE, THINGS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN DYNEL TIESED,
WE WERE ABLE ARE REFRESHMENT TO
DO SOMETHING THAT WAS IMPOSSIBLE
THE YEAR BEFORE WANT WE DID AN
INSTALLATION OF THIS AT THE
BLACK HISTORY MUSEUM IN
RICHMOND.
WE DID A PREVIEW OF THAT.
SO HAVE I THESE KIDS, SHOWING
VISITORS TO THE MUSEUM WHAT THEY
D. THEY SAID I THEY WANTED TON
IF WE WERE GRADUATE STUDENTS.
WE SAID NO, WE'RE 19!
[LAUGHTER]
SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT WHAT A
COLLECTIVE EFFORT TO UNLOCK ALL
OF THE POWER IN THESE
NEWSPAPERS, BY LOOK AT THEM AS
ARTICLES, RESTORING THE ARTICLE
STRUCTURES, AND THE ALL OF
THESEMENT STRUCTURE AND IT'S
STILL A SUMMARY AND SYNTHESIZING
THEM INTO A WEEK, I THINK WE'RE
JUST AT THE BEGINNING OF REALLY
SEEING ALL THE CHRONICALLING
AMERICA CAN DO.
SO ALL THAT IS GOES GOOD, TOO.
WE'RE GETTING READY TO DO THE
RICHMOND PLAN THIS FALL.
ONE OF THE LEADING
AFRICAN-AMERICAN NEWSPAPERS
AROUND THE TURN OF THE CENTURY.
I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO THE MATT.
I'M TRYING TO MAKE MAXIMUM USE
OF THE INCREDIBLE FACILITY.
SO THIS IS WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON
NOW.
THIS IS CALLED BUNK.
THE HISTORY IS MORE MORE OR LESS
BUNK.
L OF COURSE, WE DON'T THINK IT
IS.
HE SAYS, THE COMPREHENSIVE
HISTORY THAT MATTER CITIZEN
HISTORY
ONLY HISTORY THAT MATTER
CITIZEN HISTORY WE MAKE TODAY.
THE HISTORY, WRITING, AND YOU
POINT AT THE SCREEN.
THAT'S SUGGESTED.
WE'RE ENGAGING YOU ALREADY.
WHAT IS THIS?
WE'RE CURATING EF DAY, ALL
REPRESENTATIONS OF THE AMERICAN
PAST, AMERICAN MEDIA AND PUTTING
THEM IN CONVERSATION WITH EACH
OTHER.
AND THIS HAD BEEN, THIS IS NOT
FLAT OUT YET.
THIS WILL DEBUT VERY SOON AND WE
HOPE THAT YOU WILL SIGN UP FOR
BUNK MAIL.
THE WEEKLY NEWS LETTER AND IT'S
ABOUT THE SAME THING I HAD THE
IDEA BACK IN BROUGHT SCHOOL IN
THE 1970'S.
YOU'LL SEE, THAT I ONLY HAD ONE
IDEA IN MY LIFE.
WHICH IS HEY, THERE'S COOL STUFF
HERE, I WISH OTHER PEOPLE CAN
SEE T. AND MAYBE IF I PUT IT
RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOUR PHONE,
AND THE INTERESTING STUFF IS THE
CONNECTIONS IN
BETWEEN.
WHAT THIS DOES, WE ARE TAGGING
ALL THESE THINGS THAT COME OUT.
YOU'LL SAY THAT THIS IS A
PORTRAIT FROM LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS.
SOME OF THESE THINGS ARE COMING
FROM THE ATLANTIC OR THE
"WASHINGTON POST."
BUT THEY'RE ALSO COMING FROM
BLOG THAT IS PEOPLE WOULDN'T
HAVE SEEN OTHERWISE OR THEY'RE
COMING FROM THE SCHOLARLY
LITERATURE OR COMING FROM
NEWSPAPERS ACROSS THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM THAT DON'T TALK TO EACH
OTHER SO MUCH.
AND HERE'S THE POINT THAT YOU
REALIZE THERE'S HISTORY ALL
AROUND US.
AS PEOPLE ON AIRPLANES TELL ME.
THEY'RE SIGNIFICANT THERE,
BRAIDING PAPERS.
SO.
WERE YOU A HISTORY TEACHER?
YEAH, I'VE ALWAYS HATED
HISTORY.
ALL THOSE NAMES  AND DATES.
YEAH, BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT
HISTORY IS AND IT'S NOT REALLY
THAT.  IT'S NOT THIS TEST.
AND THEY DON'T REALIZE WE'RE
SATURATED IN REPRESENTATIONS OF
THE PAST ALL THE TIME.
WHAT BUNK IS TRYING TO DO IS
MAKE US REALIZE THAT MOST OF OUR
MOVIES  AND TELEVISION SHOWS,
UNLESS THEY'RE SCIENCE FICTION
ARE BASED ON HISTORY.
MOST ARE NAVIGATING THROUGH THE
COMPLEXITIES OF OUR OWN TIME ARE
OFTEN LOOKING FOR HISTORICAL
COORDINATES WANT HERE'S
FREDERICK DOUGLAS AS A REFUGEE.
THE FIRST LINK THERE IS ABOUT
THE CIVIL WAR.
BUT THE REST IS ABOUT OTHER
REFUGEES  AND FRANK.
BUT THEN, YOU CAN SEE NOW, LET'S
THINK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED
HISTORY THE WRITTEN HISTORY OF
JUNE TEETH.
SO PART OF MY INSTINCT ON ALL OF
THIS IS WHY IT IS THAT THERE IS
SO MUCH WONDERFUL HISTORY BEING
WRITTEN IN SO MANY VENENZUELA
YOU'RE.
WE HAVE NEVER TOUCHED
-- SO MANY
VENUES THAT HAVE TOUCHED PEOPLE
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
WHAT BUNK IS TRYING TO DO WITH
THE VALLEY OF THE SHADOW FALL
OH, WITH THE DIGITAL SCHOLARSHIP
LAB IS TO GATHER THE POWER IN
COLLECTIONS AND THEN SHARE THEM
WITH THE WORLD.
YOU'LL SEE, SHARE CONNECTION SO
IF YOU CLICK ON THE SOCIAL MEDIA
BUTTON WHEN THIS IS ACTUALLY
AVAILABLE.
IT MAY BE AVAILABLE AT THIS VERY
MOMENT, FOR ALL I KNOW.
BUT I DON'T MEAN FOR IT TO BE.
IT'S GOING TO BE SO MUCH MORE
AWESOME.
IF YOU CLICK ON THE SOCIAL MEDIA
OR THE E-MAIL.
IT SAYS, LOOK AT THIS COOL
CONNECTION I FOUND ON BUNK.
IT'S THE TWO
THINGS AND THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THEM.
ISN'T THAT AMAZING HOW FREDERICK
DOUGLAS, ANNE FRANK, WE THINK OF
THEM BOTH AS REFUGEES OR THE
CONVERSATIONS ALL ABOUT
MONUMENTS.
WHAT WERE PEOPLE SAYING THIS 15
YEARS AGO, TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WITH SOME
DEPTH.
PEOPLE WILL BE THEIR OWN CURE
EAT ORS.
IT'S LIKE WRAPPING EACH OF THESE
INJURIES LIKE A PROTEIN.
THEY CAN CONNECT IN LOTS OF
DIFFERENT WEARS.
THE FREDERICK DOUGLAS THING IS
ABOUT AFRICAN-AMERICAN HISTORY,
IT'S ABOUT SLAVERY, AND OTHER
KINDS OF COLLECTIONS AS WELL.
THE BACK END WE BUILT IS
ALLOWING THIS STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF RICHMOND TO HELP
US TAG ALL THESE THINGS SO THEY
CAN TALK AND WE CAN RECOGNIZE
THAT WE LIVE IN HISTORY THE WAY
WE LIVE IN
OXYGEN.
NAP IT IS EARLY ALL TIME AND WE
CAN SEE IT IN COOL NEW
WAYS.
MY INSPARATION THROUGH ALL OF
THIS HAVE BEEN ZENIZA BUSH, WHO
IN 1945, INVENTED A MAN THAT WAS
GOING TO REVOLUTIONIZE
EVERYTHING.
PICTURE THIS.
YOU WEAR A WALNUT SIZED CAMERA
ON YOUR FOREHEAD AND THEN YOU
HAVE THE SHUTTER RUNNING DOWN
YOUR ARM.
WHEN YOU SEE SOMETHING COOL, YOU
CLICK IT.
IT TAKES A PICTURE OF IT.
AND YOU'RE ABLE TO ADD THAT
ARCHIVE THAT YOU'RE MAKING, WITH
ALL THE ARCHIVE OF MICRO FILM
AND HE CALCULATES THAT IF YOU
ADD UP THE ENTIRE WRITTEN RECORD
OF HUMANS, IN 1945, IT WOULD BE
IN THE BILLIONS.
BUT WE COULD REDUCE THIS,
EXTRAPOLATING A BIT.
INTO A MOVING
VAN.
AND THE DEVICE THAT WOULD HOLD
ALL OF THIS TOGETHER, WOULD BE A
SERIES OF MICRO FILM SCREENS
THAT YOU'D CAUSE IF FRONT OF
YOU, AND YOU SEE CONNECTION YOU
WANT TO MAKE AND YOU TAKE A
PICTURE OF T. AND YOU WOULD HAVE
ADDED TO THE NETWORK OF
KNOWLEDGE AND INFORMATION.
WELL, MICRO FILM COULD NOT
FORESEE THE INVENTION.
DIGITAL TECHNOLOGY.
HE IMAGINED THAT IN 1945, THERE
WOULD BE A NEW PROFESSION OF
PEOPLE WHO MAKE CONNECTION.
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE TRAILBLAZERS,
WHO WILL FIND ALL OF THE
EXCITEMENT AND THE DRAMA AND THE
MEANING AND THE HISTORY BETWEEN
THE LINE.
I HOPE ALL OF YOU WILL JOIN THAT
EXCITING ADVENTURE.
THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS MAKE ITS
POSSIBLE.
A LOT OF THESE THINGS ARE BASED
ON TREASURES THAT HAVE BEEN
SAFE.SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
HAVE
A GREAT DAY WANT.
[APPLAUSE].
>> NEXT UP IS CANADIAN VISUAL
ARTIST, SARA HAT OWN, SARA'S
DEEP INTEREST IN HUMAN NATURE
AND INSATTABLE
CURIOSITY ABOUT
THE NATURAL WORLD ARE FOUND
THROUGHOUT HER PAINTINGS AND
MIXED MEDIA WORK.
SHE OBSERVES, AND EXPLORING
NOTIONS OF LONGING, TRANSITION,
MORALITY AND HUMAN CONNECTIONS
WITH NATURE.
SHE'S HERE TODAY, TO SHARE ABOUT
HER PROCESS OF CREATE
CREATING.
I LIKE CHALLENGING MYSELF.
IN HORTICULTURAL
WAYS.
SURVIVED THE CANADIAN WINTER.OF
COURSE LIKE ANY
MILLENNIAL.
I'M ALSO A BEE
KEEPER.
SCIENCE AND NATURE ALWAYS SEEM
TO MAKE AN APPEARANCE OF IT,
IT'S SOMETHING I JUST CAN'T
SWITCH OFF.
I WAS INVITED HERE TODAY, TO
TALK ABOUT MY LATEST SERIES OF
WORK CALLED ATTACHMENTS.
BUT I THOUGHT I WOULD GIVE YOU A
BIT OF BACKGROUND INTO A
PREVIOUS SERIES OF WORK JUST SO
YOU START SEAT CONNECTIONS I'M
TALKING
ABOUT.
2013 WAS NOT A GOOD YEAR FOR
BEES.
NOT A GOOD YEAR FOR MY BEES, AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE OTHER BEE
KEEPERS, COLONIES IN THE REGION
THEY LIVE IN.
I LOST ALL OF MY DOG KNEES,
BECAUSE WE'RE A TIGHT NETWORK, I
WAS LEARNING MORE ABOUT
COLONIES, AND SYSTEMIC PESTICIDE
THAT IS SEEM TO BE CAUSING A LOT
OF PROBLEMS WITH THE BEES.
SO WHEN I LOST MY HIVE, I WANTED
TO DO SOMETHING MEANINGFUL WITH
THEM SO THAT I COULD START?
ACTIVISM AND START TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE HAPPENING BUT I DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO.
I HAD ALL OF THESE THOUSANDS OF
DEAD BODIES AND I DIDN'T HAVE
THE IDEA YET.
I BAGGED THEM UP IN ZIP LOCKS
AND PUT THEM IN MY FREEZER.
SO I HAD MY EUREKA MOMENT.
MY FAMILY IS EITHER REALLY
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THIS OR
THEY'RE RESIGNED TO THE STUFF I
DO NOW.
AND THE EUREKA MOMENT CAME WHEN
THE EUREKA MOMENT CAME WHEN, I
THOUGHT ABOUT THE MATHEMATICAL
PATTERNS, THAT ARE INHERENT IN
NATURE, PARTICULARLY, THE
SEQUENCE OF MAPS THAT IS FOUND
IN SEED-PRODUCING PLANTS LIKE
THE SUNFLOWER.
AND IT WAS THESE PATTERNS THAT
GAVE ME MY INSPIRATION ON WHAT
TO FINALLY DO.
THESE ARE THE SORTS OF CRAPS,
TREATED WITH THE SAME PESTICIDES
THAT ARE THOUGHT TO BE
DESTROYING THE BEES.
SO I GLUED, ONE BY ONE, ALL THE
HONEY BEES INTO THESE PATTERNS,
AND I COATED THEM WITH RESINS
AND THE RESULTING WORK, THIS IS
THE PROTOTYPE.
AND I GET TO DO A COOL, BAD ASS
ART DISCLAIMER HERE.
SOME OF THESE PATTERNS TEND TO
SENSE VERTIGO IN SOME VIEWERS.
IF YOU START TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE, JUST CLOSE YOUR
EYES.THESE ARE FOUR FEET
ACROSS.BECAUSE SYSTEMIC
PESTICIDES
AFFECT THE BEES'S CENTRAL
NERVOUS SYSTEM AND THEY WIPE OUT
THE ABILITY TO NAVIGATE, I CHOSE
PATTERNS  FROM CROP CIRCLES AS
WELL, THAT GAVE A SIMILAR
EFFECT, AN OPTICALLY ILLUSION
EFFECT THAT GAVE THAT SAME SENSE
OF
ORIENTATION.
THAT'S ANOTHER PIECE THAT'S
4 FEET BY 4 FEET.
ABOUT 10,000 BEES IN THAT.
SO YOU CAN READ STUDY AFTER
STUDY OF THE DATA BEHIND THE BEE
DECLINE.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT ART, ART
GIVES
YOU THAT VOICE CAL GUT
PUNCH OF EMOTION THAT IS TELLS
YOU THE STORY YOU'RE SEEING.
THE SERIES GOT INNER NATIONAL
PRESS.
THE KEY WAS STARTING TO BE
RECOGNIZED BUT NOT A LOT OF
ARTISTS OUT THERE USING
THOUSANDS OF DEAD BEES AS THEIR
MEDIUM.
I HOPE THAT'S STILL THE
CASE.SO WHAT I WANT YOU TO
THINK
ABOUT HERE IS THAT I'VE USED A
SINGLE ITEM REPEATED ON MAP.
TO SEND A SPECIFIC MESSAGE
THROUGH A SYMBOLIC PATTERN,
WHICH BRINGS ME TO MY NEXT
SERIES OF WORK.
SO MEANWHILE IN CANADA,
LIBRARIAN ARCHIVES  IN CANADA
HAD STARTED THEIR OWN MAP DYNEL
TEASATION PROJECT, A MULTI YEAR,
ENORMOUS PROJECT, WITH MANY
RESOURCES DEVOTED TO T. AND
THAT'S DIGITIZATION OF COMPLETE
COLLECTION OF CANADIAN
EXPEDITION FORCE WARD WAR 1
FILES.
THIS IS AN ENORMOUS UNDERTAKING
AND THE DATA PRODUCE BIDE THE
DIGITIZATION PROBLEMS, IS A
TREASURE IN ITSELF.
BUT AS ANYONE WHO HAS DONE A
MASSIVE DIGITIZATION PROJECT,
THERE ARE BY-PRODUCT THAT IS
COME BY T. YOU HAVE TO HIRE
ADDITIONAL STAPH STAPH TO
PROCESS.
THESE WERE PAPER RECORDS HELD
TOGETHER FOR A HUNDRED
YEARS BY
PINS, STAPLES, AND PAPER CLIPS
Q. I TOURED THE PRESERVATION
CENTER, THE THING THAT STRUCK ME
AS AN ASIDE FROM THE DENSITY OF
THE PROJECT WAS THAT THEY HAD
BEEN BIN AFTER BIN AFTER BIN OF
THESE PINS THAT THAT HELD THE
RECORDS TOGETHER.
IT STRUCK ME AS SO MOVING  TO Z
PHYSICALLY REPRESENTED IN FRONT
OF ME, THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THIS
WAS.
AND I ASKED THEM, CAN WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO DO WITH ALL OF
THESE PINS?
THEY SAID L WE WANT TO DO
SOMETHING TO COMMEMORATE THE
PROJECT BUT WE'RE NOT QUITE SURE
WHAT.
WE'RE THINKING OF MELTING THEM
ALL DOWN, AND MAKING NETTALS.I
THOUGHT, THAT DOESN'T SIT WELL
WITH ME.
I HAD THE REACTION OF SEEING A
NUMBER OF THEM, AND THESE WERE
ITEMS THAT HELD TOGETHER
CANADA'S MILITARY MEMORY FOR A
HUNDRED YEARS.
YOU CAN'T JUST TAKE THAT AND
KIND OF DESTROY IT BY MELT
TOGETHERRAL TOGETHER.
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT AGAIN,
WAITING FOR MY EUREKA AND ALL
THAT.
SO I SAID, GIVE ME ONE OF THEM
TO TAKE HOME, AND I'LL THINK
ABOUT THIS AND SEE WHAT I COME
UP WITH.
SO I TOOK ONE OF THEM BACK.
I WAS JUST SITTING THERE,
LOOKING AT IT AND I THOUGHT EACH
ONE OF THESE HAS BEEN EMBOSSED
WITH A STAR.
SO THIS IS WHAT I
DID.
>> THIS IS A SINGLE BRASS
PASTNER PIN.
IT'S 100 YEARS OLD MUCH THESE
ARE THE PINS THAT HELD TOGETHER
THE MILITARY SERVICE RECORDS OF
EACH CANADIAN SOLDIER WHO SERVED
IN THE FIST WARD WAR.
>> VIDEO: WHEN LIBRARY AND
ARCHIVES CAN DARKS BEGAN THEIR
MASS DYNEL TEASATION OF SOLDIERS
FILES.
EACH PIN HAD TO BE DETACHED BY
HAND.
IN TOTAL, THERE WERE 640,000.
NOBODY QUEUE WHAT TO DO WITH ALL
THIS BRASS.
SO THEY ASKED AN ARTIST.
>> I WANTED TO DO SOMETHING WITH
THESE PASTNERS THAT WOULD
PRESERVE THEIR MEANING AS
HISTORICAL ARTIFACTS BUT THEY
WOULD FIND A RESPECTFUL WAY TO
CONVEY THE MAGNITUDE OF HUMAN
LOSS.
EACH PASTNER IS STAMPED WITH A
STAR.
AND THINK ABOUT THE SACRIFICE
AND (INAUDIBLE) THAT GIVE ME
INSPIRATION.
IT STARTED BY FOCUSING ON THE 5
MAJOR BATTLES OF THE WAR, THAT
INVOLVED THE CANADIANS POSITION
IN THE WAR.
>> AFTER DETERMINING THE
GEOGRAPHICAL COORDINATES OF EACH
OF THESE, HATON GENERATED STAR
MASKLESS OF WHAT THE STARS WOULD
HAVE LOOKED LIKE, ON THE NIGHTS
FOLLOWING EACH OF THESE MAJOR
CONFLICTS.
THEN SHE GOT TO WORK.
THE RESULTS IS A SERIES OF STARS
TITLED
DETACHMENT.
THESE PIECES SHOW US EXACTLY HOW
THE STARS APPEARED 1100 YEARS
AGO.  THE FIST NIGHT AFTER THE
FIGHTING WAS OVER.
THE SKIES THAT NO DOUBT, THE
SURVIVING SOLDIERS WOULD HAVE
BEEN OKAYING
LOOKING AT THAT.
>> THIS SERIES IS A SACRIFICE
TIME TO
REMEMBER.
STARS ARE A CROSS CULTURAL
CONFLICT AS IT LOOKS  TO
DIRECTION.
WHETHER THAT'S SPIRITUAL OR
NAVIGATION.
THERE ARE UNIVERSAL
WAYS WE
MEMBER COMMENTS OR IALIZE THE
WAY -- THERE ARE UNIVERSAL WAYS
THAT WE
MEMORIALIZE THE STARS.
>> THANK YOU TO CANADA FOR
POINTING ME IN THIS DIRECTION
AND IN PARTICULAR, LIBRARIAN
[INDISCERNIBLE] FOR HIS SUPPORT
IN THIS PROJECT.
AND I THANK THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FOR INVITING ME TO SHOW
THIS TO YOU.
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR.
[APPLAUSE].
THANK YOU.
WONDERFUL, SAY A. NEXT IS SARA
STILLER, IN THE RARE BOOK AND
SPECIAL COLLECTIONS DIVISION OF
THE LOCKE.
PRIOR TO JOINING LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS, SHED AS THE PROFESSOR
OF HISTORY, AT WASHINGTON AND
LEE UNIVERSITY WHERE SHE TAUGHT
CLASSES  ON DIGITAL EXHIBITION
AND DESIGN, PUBLIC HISTORY AND
DIGITAL STORY TELLING.
SHE'S GOING TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
WORK AT THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS
THAT RELATES TO COLLECTIONS AS
DATA IN HER TALK, ONLY ONCE
IMAGINED.
STEPHANIE.
I'VE REALLY COME TO REPORT DEPTH
OF KNOWLEDGE AND COMMITMENT THAT
THEY HAVE TO SHARING THE
LIBRARY'S COLLECTIONS, WHICH I
THINK IS SOMETHING THAT WE SEE
HERE TODAY.
AND A SPECIAL THANK YOU ALSO TO
SARA FOR THAT LOVELY
PRESENTATION.
WE WERE JUST COMMENTING OF HOW
WE WERE TEARING UP A LITTLE BIT
IN THE BACK.
SO THE TITLE OF MY TALK I THINK
IS A LITTLE BIT RISQUE TO BEGIN
MY TALK WITH A PEOPLE
CALLED "THE MARRIAGE OF HEAVEN
AND HELL" BUT NONETHELESS, HERE
WE G. I AM THE CURATOR HERE AT
THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS AND I
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF OVERSEEING
ONE OF THE LARGEST WILLIAM BLAKE
COLLECTIONS IN THE WORLD.
AND I NEVER GET TIRED OF SAYING
THAT OUT LOUD.
THAT'S ALWAYS A REALLY FUN
STATEMENT TO SAY AT ANY POINT,
REALLY.
SO SO I THINK ABOUT BLAKE A
LOT.
AND BLAKE WROTE THIS PARTICULAR
WORK IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
FRENCH REVOLUTION.
AND THE POEM IS VERY MUCH THIS
HOMAGE TO THE CONCEPT OF
CHANGE.
TO CHANGE AND CONVENTIONAL
MORALITY, TO CHANGE IN POLITICS
TO, CHANGE IN RELIGION AND IT'S
A QUITE
INSPIRING "D."
SO AS A RARE BOOKS CURATOR, I
THINK ABOUT A LOT, AND I THINK
ABOUT THIS IDEA OF THE ONCE
IMAGINED QUITE A BIT.
AND I USUALLY THINK ABOUT IT IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE WAY PRINTING
CHARGED EUROPEAN SOCIETY AFTER
1455.
AND I LIKE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
EUROPEANS SAW OR WHAT THEY WERE
THINK CHICAGO THEY SAW THE
FIRST
IMAGE OF THE MOON THROUGH A
TELESCOPE OR THE FIRST
MICROSCOPIC IMAGE OF A FEATHER,
AND I THINK ABOUT HOW THESE
VISUALIZATIONS EMPOWERED BELIEVE
KNOWLEDGE, AND REALLY
UPENDED
TRADITIONAL INTELLECTUAL
THOUGHT.
SO I THINK
ABOUT.
SO WHAT IS INSPIRE BEING THIS
MOMENT IN HISTORY, ABOUT OUR
MOMENT IN HISTORY, IS THAT THE
WAY, DIGITAL TOOLS ARE ALLOWING
US TO LIVE IN THIS AGE, WHERE
THE ONCE IMAGINED IS TRUE
AGAIN.
AND THROUGH DATA SETS, THROUGH
NEW VISUALIZATION, WE'RE ABLE TO
ASK QUESTIONS THAT SIMPLY
WEREN'T POSSIBLE
BEFORE.
IN A WAY, WE'RE STANDINGA
AT THIS SIMILAR MOMENT OF
CHANGE.
TODAY I'VE BEEN ASKED TO TALK
ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE AT THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
-- IN TERMS HAVE A CONFESSION
AND I WORK AT THE LARGEST
LIBRARY IN THE WORLD AND I'M NOT
A LIBRARIAN.
THIS IS A RECURRING CONFESSION
IN MY LIFE.
I'VE TAUGHT DIGITAL HUMANITIES,
AND I'M NOT A TECH GIST WANT A
LOT OF MY RESEARCH RIGHT NOW,
PHOBE ON THE IMPACT OF
PRESERVATION TECHNOLOGY, AND I'M
IN NO WAY, A SCIENTIST.
BUT WHAT I AM IS A HISTORIAN
THAT HAS WANDERED INTO THE ONE
OF THE GREATEST REPOSITORIES OF
HUMAN EXPERIENCE OF AMASSED HERE
AT THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
AT OVER 1 60 MILLION ITEMS HERE
AT THE LIBRARY, WE ARE A GALAXY
OF STORIES.
SO TODAY, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
MY METHODS OF USING THESE
RESOURCE.
BUT I THINK THAT'S FAR MORE
EXCITING IS THAT MY VOICE, I
THINK IS PART OF THIS MUCH
LARGER CHOIR OF RESEARCH, THAT'S
REALLY CHANGING THE WAY WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT OUR COLLECTIONS
AT THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
SO THE FIRST TIME I STEPPED INTO
THE LIBRARY WAS NOT AS A CURE
RATER.
IT WAS BECOMEBACK IN 2012.
AND AT TIME.
I HAD THIS VERY SIMPLE GOAL, I
WANTED TO TELL A STORY ABOUT
BOOKS.
I WAS INTERESTED IN HOW BOOKS
MOVED THROUGH TIME AND SPACE.
I WAS INTERESTED IN THE PEOPLE
WHO OWNED THEM AND THE WAY THEY
USED THEM AND CHANGED THEM FOR
THEIR OWN
USE BOOKS HAVE A LIFE
OF THEIR
OWN AND THE EARLY
MODERN WORLD, PARTICULARLY, IN
THE WESTERN WORLD, PEOPLE WOULD
ANNOTATE AND DRAW IN THEIR
BOOKS, TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
THE INFORMATION BETTER.
AND I WAS TERRIBLY INTERESTED IN
THIS IDEA AS ATTEMPTS TO
ORGANIZE KNOWLEDGE.
TO USE BOOKS IN THIS VERY
PERSONAL WAY, TO CLASSIFY THE
WORLD AROUND YOU, TO MAKE
INFORMATION PERSONAL.
BUT ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WORKING WITH OLD BOOKS IS THEY
OFTEN BEAR THE SCARS OF MOVING
THROUGH TIME AND SWAYS.
AN NOTATIONS FADE MUCH PIGMENTS
CARODE.
BOOKS ARE REBOUND AND RESOLD.
MANY OF THEM LIVE THROUGH
REVOLUTIONS AND POLITICAL AND
RELIGIOUS CENSORSHIP, THEY HAVE
CROSSED CONTINENTS SEVERAL TIMES
OVER, AND THIS ALL ADDS TO THE
STORY OF YOUR BOOK.
BUT IT ALSO ADDS ANOTHER LAYER
OF RESEARCH THAT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO ACCESS, AS JUST THE
HISTORIAN.
SO I WANTED TO FOLLOW A BOOK
WHEN I GOT HERE.
BUT I FEEDED A NEEDED SOMEONE TO
HELP ME.
I NEEDED A TEAM OF DETECTIVES
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I FOUND
IN THE PRESERVATION RESEARCH AND
TESTING DIVISION HERE AT THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE, THAT
DO NOT WORK HERE, ONE OF THE
MOST EXTRAORDINARY RESOURCE WE
HAVE AT THE LIBRARY ARE THESE
STEP TRAINING  TRAINING  AND
LABS THAT ARE FILLED WITH THIS
FABULOUS
TECHNOLOGY MUCH THAT I
DO NOT UNDERSTAND, AND TEAMS
LOOKING AT OUR COLLECTIONS AS
OBJECTS AND DIGGING BEYOND WHAT
WE SEE UNDER THE SURFACE.
SO WHEN I ARRIVED AT THE
LIBRARY, I MET PEOPLE THAT
SPECIALIZE IN TECHNOLOGY THEY
NEVER HEARD OF BEFORE.
AGAIN, I'M A HISTORIAN.
SO THINGS LIKE MULTI SPECTRAL
IMAGING AND EXTRA FLORESSENTS,
AND
MICROSCOPE DON'T
[INDISCERNIBLE] INTO MY
CATEGORY.
BUT THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE THE
RESULTLESS I NEEDED TO GET TO
THIS PROBLEMS AND THERE WAS
NOWHERE ELSE I WAS GOING TO FIND
THIS COMBINATION OF RESOURCES
AND EXPERTISE.
BUT AT THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS.
SO EVENTUALLY, I SETTLE BOD THIS
WONDERFUL BOOK.
A WORLD ATLAS.
THE PRINTING WAS LOVELY, BUT THE
COLORING IN THE BOOK WAS SLOPE,
THERE WERE AN NOTATIONS.
IT WAS BORING IN ONE PLACE, AND
INTEREST IN ANOTHER.
AND IT WAS PROBLEMATIC.
I CAME TO APPRECIATE PROBLEMATIC
BOOKS.
THEY TELL GREAT
STORIES.
THE BOOK THAT IS LOOK LIKE CRAP,
BRING THEM ON.
SO I SETTLED ON THIS BOOK.
AND LIKE MOST RESEARCH, THE
CONCLUSIONS OF THE PROJECT ENDED
UP BEING MUCH MORE THAN I
EXPECTED, AND I DON'T KNOW TO
BURDEN THIS WITH TOO MANY
SPECIFICS.
BUT VERY BRIEFLY.
SO THE ORIGINAL PRINT PLACED THE
BEGINNING OF MY STORY WITH THE
SON OF A KNIFE MAKER IN 17TH
CENTURY AMSTERDAM, IN THE PRINT
SHOP CALLED THE THREE CRAFTS:
ANALYSIS OF THE AN NOTATIONS
REVEALED BY BOOK MOVED TO ITALY
W A STUDENT OF MILITARY
GEOGRAPHYY IN THE 18TH CENTURY
AND HE LIKELY HAD SIGNATURE AN
NOTATIONS, SORT OF REVEALING
THIS INTERESTING SORT OF
ORGANIZATION OF HIS GEOGRAPHIC
KNOWLEDGE.
THE PIGMENT ANALYSIS, INTRODUCED
ME TO A 19TH CENTURY OWNER, THAT
TOUCHED UP THE COLORS.
AND EVENTUALLY FOUND ITS WAY TO
THE COLLECTIONS OF ONE OF THE
LIBRARY'S GREATEST BENEFACTORS
AND ONLY INTO THE LIBRARY
COLLECTION IN 1980.
SO THIS WAS, AGAIN, THERE WAS A
LOT THAT IN THE END, OF COURSE I
HAD MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT MY
BOOK.
THIS IS A GREAT STORY.
ONE THAT I'VE BEEN ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT IN TERMS OF THIS JOURNEY
QUITE OFFER, WHICH HAS REALLY
BEEN LOVE LEAST AND ALL EMERGES
OUT OF THIS EARLY RESEARCH AT
THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
SO NOW I HAVE THE GREAT HONOR OF
BEING THE CURE RATER OF THE
COLLECTION, WHICH IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST GRAPHIC ART COLLECTIONS
IN THE WORLD.
AND SINCE I'VE BECOME THE CURATE
O I CONTINUED TO WORK WITH OUR
PRESERVATION DIVISION TO THINK
ABOUT UNLOCKING NEW STORIES.
OPENING NEW
CORES
NEW DOORS AND
NEW RESEARCH.
THROUGH MULTIEL SPECTRAL
IMAGING, WE WERE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY ST. CATHERINE OF
ALEXANDRIA.
IT'S QUITE RARE.
NOT MANY OF THESE SURVIVED BUT
WE'RE ABLE TO RECOVER THIS
IMAGE.
RIGHTFULLY SO, BECAUSE
ST. CATHERINE IS A PATRON OF
LIBRARIANS.
WE HAD TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GOT
HER BACK.
WE SHOULD ALL
EXPECT GOOD
FORTUNATE.
WE HAVE IN THE ROSENWALL
COLLECTION, WE HAVE WILLIAM
BLAKES, THE FIRST OF HIS
CONTINENTAL PROPHECIES  AND THIS
PLATE HAS PERSONAL, PENCIL AN
NOTATIONS FROM WILLIAM BLAKE AND
THEY'RE FADING.
SO THROUGH MULTIEL SPECTOR RAUL
IMAGING AND PRINCIPLE COMPONENT
ANALYSIS, WE'RE ABLE TO PULL OUT
THESE AN NOTATIONS, WHICH ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR THE HISTORICAL
RECORD FOR WILLIAM
BLAKE.
ONE
OF THE RARE BOOKS IS A
PARTICULAR TYPE OF DOWN MARKET
PRINT FIGURE THE 15TH CENTURY.
THESE ARE CALLED BLOCK
BOOKS
THESE ARE REALLY THE PRINTS THAT
HELP GUIDE EUROPEAN DEVOTION FOR
NEARLY A CENTURY.
THESE NEW TECHNICAL STUDIES ARE
REALLY HELPING US THINK ABOUT
NEW SITES OF PRODUCTION FOR
THESE PARTICULAR WORKS, THROUGH
ANALYSIS OF PIGMENTS, THROUGH
ANALYSIS OF INK, THROUGH ANAL IS
ANALYSIS OF INK AND PAPER.
AND WE'RE ABLE TO GET THROUGH
THESE RESOURCES  IN A NEW AND
FASCINATING
WAY.
EVEN WITH NOW BEING THE
ROSENWAL'S CURATOR, I STILL
THINK ABOUT MY ONE BOOK, AND I
THINK ABOUT WHERE IT ALL BEGAN
AND WHY I WAS ABLE TO TELL THAT
STORY.
AND I THINK ABOUT THAT ONE STORY
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF OUR
1 60 MILLION ITEMS AT THE
LIBRARY.
AND EACH ONE OF THEM HAVING
THEIR OWN STORY.
AND A LOT OF OUR COLLECTIONS OF
COURSE TOUCHED BY NAMES THAT WE
KNOW.
NAME THAT IS WE REMEMBER.
NAMES LIKE GEORGE WASHINGTON,
THOMAS
JEFFERSON.
I THINK WHAT'S MOST EXCITING,
AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENING AT THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS RIGHT NOW IS
THAT WE'RE STARTING TO DISCOVER
I THINK, THE PEOPLE THAT WE
RARELY HEAR FROM IN OUR
COLLECTION OR WE'RE JUST
STARTING TO HEAR FROM IN OUR
COLLECTIONS AND NEW STORIES THAT
ARE COMING, OR THAT ARE EMERGING
FROM THE LIBRARY, FROM NEW
PARTNERSHIP AND NEW RESEARCH IN
OUR COLLECTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE CHRONICELLING
AMERICA API, WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP.
IT'S HELPING US LEARN ABOUT
AMERICAN AGRICULTURE.
THINKING ABOUT THIS SORT OF,
WHAT THE ORGANIZERS OF THIS
PROJECT CALL THIS LONG, HUMAN
HISTORY OF AGRICULTURE, AND THE
WAY THAT AMERICANS WERE SWEPT
INTO INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY
AND SCIENCE THAT HAS COME TO
REALLY DEFINE MATERNITY.
I'VE PERSONALLY FORWARD TODAY TO
THE HISTORIAN AT DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE AND HE'S
JUST
DEDELIGHTED BY BY THIS PROJECT.
SO IT'S REALLY SATISFYING TO ME
TO BE ABLE TO SHARE THIS WITH
SOMEONE.
THE AVAILABILITY OF NEWSPAPERS,
AND THE NEW AMERICA API IS
FACILITATING NEW CONVERSATIONS
WITH AMERICAN LYNCHING, PAYING
NECESSARY AND CLOSE ATTENTION TO
THE VICTIMS OF VIOLENT MOBS AND
EXPLORING HOW NEWSPAPERS PLAYED
THIS DUAL ROLE BETWEEN VIOLENCE
AND REFORM AND THINK BEING
THAT
THAT, WE ARE JUST STARTING TO
LEARN, WHAT WILL BE THE RELEASE
OF OUR 25 MILLION MARK
RECORD.
BENJAMIN SCHMIDT FROM NORTHWEST
UNIVERSITY IS USING THE DATA OF
MARKED CATALOGING AT THE
LIBRARY.
IF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN THIS I
ENCOURAGING YOU TO GO LOOK.
IT IS QUITE FANTASTIC AND HAS
THE POTENTIAL FOR INSIGHTS INTO
OUR OWN INSTITUTIONAL HISTORY.
I'VE BEEN AT MANY MEETINGS NOW,
WHERE THIS HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP
AND I CAN ASSURE YOU, EVERYONE
AT THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS HAS
AN OPINION ABOUT THIS PROJECT,
WHICH IS NICE TO SEE.
THIS IS WHAT THESE PROJECTS DO.
THEY FACILITATE THESE SORT OF
FABULOUS CONVERSATIONS, AND IT'S
NICE TO SEE IT HERE, CERTAINLY
AT THE
LIBRARY.
SO JUST TO WRAP
UP.
I'D LIKE TO THINK ABOUT MY
EXPERIENCE AT THE LIBRARY, AND
MY COLLECTION THEY CURATE.
AGAIN, ONE COLLECTION WITHIN A
GALAXY OF
COLLECTIONS AND I'D
LIKE TO THINK OF IT AS THIS
SMART PART OF EMERGING RESEARCH
HERE AT THE LIBRARY, WHERE WE
CONTINUE TO FIND THOSE STORIES
THAT ARE HIDDEN IN OUR
COLLECTION.
AND WHETHER THAT BE AN
AMERICAN
FARMER OR OUR OWN CATALOGERS OR
SON OF A KNIFE MAKER IN
AMSTERDAM IN
THE 16TH CENTURY.
AS WE CONTINUE TO EXPLORE OUR AT
THAT TIME A WHICH AGAIN, WE'RE
AT THIS REALLY EXCITING MOMENT
WHERE WE'RE HAVING A RENAISSANCE
WITH OUR DATA, THAT WE'RE
STARTING TO THINK TOGETHER ABOUT
THE DIGITAL TOOL THAT IS MIGHT
HELP US FIND THESE NEW STORIES.
WE CAN ONLY DO THAT TOGETHER.BUT
WHAT IS SO UNIQUE I THINK
ABOUT THIS MOMENT, IS GOING BACK
TO BLAKE'S QUOTE OF THE ONCE
ONLY IMAGINED.
THAT WE STAND AT THAT MOMENT OF
CHANGE RIGHT NOW AND AS WE KEEP
WORKING TOGETHER, AS WE KEEP
DISCOVERING THESE COLLECTIONS,
AND AS WE KEEP MAKING THEM MORE
AVAILABLE, I FEEL LIKE WE COME
CLOSER TO TRULY SAYING THAT WHAT
WE IMAGINED TODAY, WE VERY WELL
MAY BE ABLE TO PROVE TOMORROW.
THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE].
>> THANK YOU, STEPHANIE.
OUR FINAL TALK BEFORE THE BREAK
IS FROM STEVEN
ROBERTSON.
PROFESSOR OF HISTORY AT THE
GEORGE MASON DRIVE UNIVERSITY.
HE WILL TELL A STORY ABOUT
DIGITAL HARLEM, A PROJECT THAT
WON THE AMERICAN HISTORICAL
ASSOCIATIONS ROY PRIZE FOR
DIGITAL HISTORY AND ABCCLIO ON
LINE HISTORY AWARD OF THE
AMERICAN LIBRARY ASSOCIATION IN
2010.
YOU'RE
OSTEVEN.
>> GOOD MORNING, A QUICK SHOUT
OUT TO THE WONDERFUL PEOPLE HERE
AT THE HI LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
I'M GOING TO GO BACK TO MAPS, TO
TALK ABOUT DATA IF PLACE.
HISTORICAL SOURCES ARE FULL OF
DATA ABOUT PLACES  AND
LOCATIONS.
THE SPECIAL DATA IS NOT VERY
INTELLIGIBLE IN TEXTUAL STORM,
AND EVEN WHEN EXTRACTED IN
TABULAR FORM, IT REALLY DOESN'T
TELL US A LOT.  IT'S HOW TO
DOESN'T THE STORY THAT IT HAS TO
TELL
US.
NOW, MAPPING HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
A LONG TIME.
IT'S BECOME ACCESSIBLE TO A WIDE
ARRANGE OF PEOPLE.
YOU USED  TO HAVE TO GO FIND THE
GAS PERSON, TO MAKE A MAP
PROJECT.
THE PROJECT THAT I AM HERE TO
TALK ABOUT TODAY, OWES ITS FORM
TO A LAUNCH OF GOOGLE MAPS  IN
2005.
SHAUN WHITE PUT TOGETHER A TEAM
OF FOUR HISTORIANS.
UNIVERSITY OF SYDNEY, IN WHICH I
WAS A JUNIOR MEMBER TO COA STUDY
OF EVERY DAY LIFE IN NEW YORK
CITY'S HARLEM NEIGHBORHOOD IN
THE 1920'S.
KEY SOURCES FOR THIS TO GET
BEYOND THE POLITICAL AND
ARTISTIC ELITE THAT DOMINATE
ACCOUNTS OF HARLEM WAS NEW YORK
CITY'S TWO BLACK NEWSPAPERS, THE
AGE IN THE AMSTERDAM NEWS, AND
MANHATTAN DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
I WAS IN THAT PROJECT BECAUSE I
USED THOSE LEGAL RECORDS  IN MY
DISSERTATION AND I KNEW FROM THE
SISERTATION THAT THEY WERE FULL
OF INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE
THINGS HAPPENED, THAT I FOUND NO
WAY TO USE AND ANALYZE REQUESTED
I DID THE DISSERTATION.
SO WHAT I SUGGEST SIDE MY
CONTRIBUTION TO THIS LARGER
PROJECT WITH AN EFFORT TO MAP
OUTSOURCES.
NOW, WHEN WE GOT FUNDING FOR THE
SOURCES  IN 2004, THE TECHNOLOGY
FOR DOING THAT WAS ART GIA.
FIND COLLABORATED AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SYDNEY.
OUR EXPERTS  TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN.
AT THAT TIME, IT WAS THE
ARCHAEOLOGICAL COMPUTING
LABORATORY.
HOWEVER, THE PROBLEM WITH ARC
GIA IN 2004 WAS IT WAS NOT
POSSIBLE TO USE IT ON THE WEB.
IT WOULDN'T RUN ON OUR BE LOVED
MACINTOSH COMPUTERS, AND IT
SIMPLY WAS, AS IT STILL IS, FAR
TOO HARD TO MASTER AND FAR TOO
COMPLEX TO MAKE IT WORTH USING,
TO ANALYZE THE QUALITATIVE DATA
THAT WE HAD.
THANKFULLY, WITH THE LAUNCH OF
GOOGLE MAPS IN 2005 AND THANKS
TO DAMIAN EVAN, ONE OF OUR TEAM,
TACREATE A HACK BETWEEN OUR
DATABASE AND GOOGLE MAPS.
WE LAUNCHED DIGITAL HARLEM IN
2009 AS A WEB-BASED FORM OF
MAPPING.
AS WITH ANY LARGE DIGITAL
PROJECT, THERE'S A WHOLE TEAM
BEHIND IT.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE ALL OF
THOSE PEOPLE, IN ADDITION TO THE
ONCE I'VE ALREADY NAMED, A TEAM
OF HISTORIANS, GRADUATE RESEARCH
ASSISTANTS, TECH GISTS OF
VARIOUS KINDS AND ALMOST A
MILLION DOLLARS OF AUSTRALIAN
GOVERNMENT MONEY UWHICH ALWAYS
AMUSING PEOPLE.
BUT THE AUSTRALIAN GOVERNMENT
WAS INTERESTED IN FUNDING
SCHOLARSHIPS.
DIGITAL HARLEM WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST HISTORICAL MAPPING
PROJECTS AND ONE OF FIRST
DIGITAL PROBLEMSES  TO SHIFT
FROM WHAT THE SHADOW WAS
INTERESTED IN DOING.
DIGITIZE MATERIAL, CREATING ON
LINE COLLECTIONS TOWARDS
VISUALIZING THOSE SOURCES.
YOU KNOW, TECHNOLOGIES NOW,
EXIST.
DIGITAL HARLEM REMAINS A USEFUL
STARTING POINT.
SO THINKING ABOUT MAPPING AS A
MEANS OF MAKING SOURCES MORE
ACCESSIBLE, MORE VISUAL AND MORE
USEFUL.
THE CONTRACT HERE IS WITH
SOURCES FLEW A
-- SOURCES
THROUGH A DATABASE.
SEARCH IS UNGENEOUS.
THE BANDING OF QUERY AND
RETURNING ONLY THE TUNES IN
TURN.
WITHHOLDING MATERIALS ABOUT THE
STRUCTURE, AND MATERIALS
AVAILABLE, AND FILTERING OUT
HYPOTHESES.
VISUALIZATIONS BY CONTRAST ARE
GENEROUS, RICH, BROWSABLE AND
DECISIVE, THAT REVEAL THE SCALE
AND BEAT CITY BEHIND THEM AND
PROVIDE A CONTEXT THAT ENRICHES
THE EXPIRATION, AND ANALYSIS OF
THEIR DATA SO DIGITAL HARLEM IS
NOT A COLLECTION OF SOURCES.
THANKS  TO COPYRIGHT, LICENSING
AND RESTRICTIONS IMPOSE BY THE
ARCHIVES, IS NOT POSSIBLE FOR
US, EVEN IF WE HAD WANTED TO,
WHICH WE DIDN'T.
BUT THOSE RESTRICTIONS DO NOT
CREATE THE PREVENTION OF DATA
FROM THOSE SOURCES, WHICHS WHAT
DIGITAL HARLEM CONTAINS.
INFORMATION ABOUT EVENTS AND ILL
FATED [INDISCERNIBLE] ABOUT
PEOPLE AND TO AN  EXTENT ABOUT
PEOPLE, A LOT ABOUT
PLACES.
THOSE OF US WHO WORK ON THE 20TH
CENTURY AND BEYOND AND CANADA'S
SYSTEM WITH [INDISCERNIBLE]
SOURCES FOR MORE OFTEN THAN OUR
COLLEAGUE THAT IS WORK IN
EARLIER PERIODS WANT WE NEED TO
BE TALKING MORE ABOUT THE WAY IN
WHICH RESTRICTIONS ON THE
SOURCES SHAPE THE KIND OF
DIGITAL PROJECTS WE CAN DO ON
THE 20TH CENTURY AND HOW
CREATING DATA IS A WAY OF
GETTING EXCESS MATERIAL, THAT IS
OTHERWISE UNDER COPYRIGHT.
TO CREATE AT THAT TIME A
HOWEVER, REQUIRED THE DIFFERENT
ENGAGEMENT IN SOURCE THAT IS
HUMANITY SOURCES TYPICALLY HAD.
WE USUALLY IMMERSE OURSELVES
UNLESS OUR SOURCES.
DIVE N. UNDERSTAND THEM FROM
WITHIN TO CREATE DATA IS TO
EXTRACT INFORMATION.
AND FEATURES FROM SOURCES
REQUIRE A DECOMPOSITION IN
ATTRIBUTES  AND VARIABLES.
THE DATA WE GET IS DIGITAL
HARLEM WAS DONE BY HAND AND
BECAUSE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
DIGITIZE NEWSPAPERS AND OTHER
LIMITS OF ACI, IS STILL A
PROCESS THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE BY
HAND.
SO MYSELF, AND THE TEACH MUCH
RESEARCH ASSISTANTS, RECORDED
DETAILS AT EVERY LOCATION, AT
EVERY EVENT ASSOCIATED WITH THE
LOCATION, AND THOSE LEGAL
RECORDS THAT I WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
AND THE HARLEM'S TWO BLACK
NEWSPAPERS.
NOT JUST INFORMATION FROM THE
NEW STORIES BUT INFORMATION ON
EVERY SECTION OF THE
NEWSPAPERS
THERE'S FAR NEAR INFORMATION,
THAN WE'RE USED  TO THINK BEING
WHEN WE ROLL THE MICRO FILM
THROUGH AND LOOK FOR THE NEWS
STORIES.
WE ORGANIZE THAT WOULD
INFORMATION INTO A DATA MODEL.
INTO A DATABASE AND GEO CODED
IT, SO IT CAN BEMAND.
NOW, THE METAPHOR THAT WE
COMMONLY USE TO DESCRIBE MINING,
SITS AWKWARDLY WITH HUMANITY
SCHOLARS, CONCERNED WITH
DEVELOPMENT OF EMPATHY.
WITHIN AN APPRECIATION OF
POSITION OF A PERSONAL GROUP OR
QUALITIES OF AN OBJECT.
SINCE EVER SINCE, CREATING DATA
IS SOMEHOW DEHUMANIZING.
MAPPING DATA CAN MITIGATE THAT
CONSEQUENCE AND ALIGN WITH AN
ORIENTATION OF ONE ELEMENT,
ARTICULATED IS AN APPRECIATION
OF CONTEXT, INTERDEPENDENT, AND
VULNERABILITY.
MAPS, AS A VISUALIZATION, EX
PRESS THIS RELATIONSHIP OF PATH
ONE TO ANOTHER.  AND MANY TO A
GREATER HALT.
MAPPING DATA IS SEEN IN ITS
GEOGRAPHICAL CONTEXT.
RICH AND DIGITAL HARLEM BITE USE
OF A HISTORICAL MAP PLAYER.
A REAL ESTATE ATLAS.
SHE HAS A LOT INFORMATION AND
QUALITY.
-- IT PROVIDES BUILDING
FOOTPRINTS.
INFORMATION ON THE HIDEEL
BERGBERG BELLS -- HIDEEL BERG
BUILDINGS, WHAT IT DOES MOST
DRAMATICALLY IN TERMS OF THE
MAPS WE ARE USED TO LOOK AT IS
FILL IN THE SPACES  ON A STREET
MAP.
IN THAT WAY, IT HELPS  TO
DIVIDE, SUBDIVIDE, HARLEM INTO
MULTIPLE, SMALLER PLACES  AND
GIVES SOME INDICATION OF HOW
THOSE PLACES INTERACT.
IF YOU KNOW GOING ABOUT THE
HISTORY OF HARLEM IN THE 1920'S,
I SHOWED THIS
BLOCK.
NEXT TO THE ESTABLISHMENT, THE
BAPTIST CHURCH, ONE OF THE MAIN
LINE MIDDLE CLASS, RACIAL
CENTERS OF HARLEM.
AND THE RIGHT IS THE QUARTERS OF
BLACK NATIONALIST UNIA.
AN INTERESTING GATHERING OF
PEOPLE WALKING DOWN THOSE BLOCKS
IN A WAY WE DON'T APPRECIATE,
WITHOUT THIS KIND OF LEVEL OF
DATA ONE OF THE VERY EXCITING
THINGS GOING ON HERE AT THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS IS THE
SANDBORN INDICIS MAPS, THAT WILL
PUT THESE RICH SOURCES INTO
PEOPLE'S HANDS.
TRANSFORM THE KIND OF HISTORICAL
MAPPING PROJECTS WE CAN DO, BUT
ADDING THIS INCREDIBLY RICH
LAYER OF DATA ABOUT WHAT THE
PLACE IS LIKE.
LAYER THE DIFFERENT DATA, CAN BE
COMBINED ON A SINGLE MAP.
PROVIDING AN IMAGE OF THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE PAST.  AND I'M
GOING TO COME BACK TO THIS
COMPLEX LOOKING MAP.
YOU CAN EXAM MAPS.
MAKE COMPARISONS.
DISCOVER RELATIONSHIPS.
BY VISUALLY DETECTING SPECIAL
PATTENS THAT, REMAIN HIDDEN IN
THE TABLE THAT IS WE START W.
MAP AND DATA HAS BECOME AN
INCREASINGLY COMMON FORM.
BUT TOPHIC, THOSE PROJECT MAP
ONLY A SINGLE COLLECTION OF
MATERIAL.
THAT APPROACH TAPS REALLY ONLY A
SMALL PART OF THE MAPPING.
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION, PROVIDES A
MEANS  TO INGRATE MATERIAL FROM
A WIDE RANGE OF DESPERATE
SOURCE.
SO WHAT IS IMPORTANT ABOUT
ASSIGNATION GEOGRAPHIC REFERENCE
TO DATA IS THAT IT THEN BECOMES
POSSIBLE TO APPEAR
TACHARACTERISTIC WITH OTHERS
THAT EXIST OR HAVE EXISTED  IN
THE SAME
GEOGRAPHIC SPACE.
THE POWER OF MAPS TO BRING
DESPERATE THINGS TOGETHER L
TOGETHER, AS WE REALLY NEED TO
BE GOING WITH THEM AS A
TECHNOLOGY.
USED IN THIS WAY, THE GEOSPATIAL
CAN HELP CAPTURE THE CONFLUENCE
OF MULTIPLE RHYTHMS.
SO THIS IS ONE OF MY GO-TO
EXAMPLES, TALKING ABOUT HARLEM
IN THE 1920'S.
IT'S A MAP OF NIGHT LIFE DURING
PROHIBITION.
UNDERCOVER INVESTIGATIONS, LEGAL
RECORDS.
IT SHOWS THE VENUES WHICH DREW
CROWDS TO HARLEMS, THE NIGHT
CLUBS, THE SPEAK EASIES, AND THE
VENUES THAT BLACK RESIDENTS,
OPENED IN THEIR APARTMENTS.
CATERING EXCLUSIVE TO BLACKS.
THE MAPS HIGHLIGHTS THE
DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHYIES, AND THE
CONTINUING DUSTERRING SECTIONS,
AWAY FROM THE OTHER VENUES.
WAY AND DREW OUR ATTENTION TO
HOW BLACKS DEVELOPED SPACES
APART FROM WHITES, AS THEY
FLOCKED TO HARLEM'S NIGHT LIFE
IN THE 1920'S.
WHILE THIS MAP CAPTURED HOW SOME
OF HOW PROHIBITION -- IT'S ONLY
A PARTIAL MAP OF THE
COMMERCIALIZED LEISURE AVAILABLE
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
DIGITAL HARLEM LETS YOU CREATE
THE CONTEXT BY ADDING DARK
HOLES, THEATERS, HALL ROOMS.
THE HALLS THAT HOSTED BASK
GAMES, AND BOXING BOUTS AND YOU
CAN ADD TO THOSE COMMERCIAL
VENUES, AND UNDERSTAND ALL OF
THE PLACES WHERE NONCOMMERCIAL
LEISURE TOOK PLACE IN HARLEM.
MEETING THE CHURCH
GROUPS,
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS, AND
SOCIAL CLUBS.
WE END UP WITH IN INCREDIBLE
COMPLEX MAP OF SOCIAL CLUBS AND
INCREDIBLY CONFLICT MAP, WHICH
HIGHLIGHTS, JUST HOW A SMALL
SEGMENT OF SEGMENT, IN HARLEM,
APPEARS  IN DISCUSSIONS, ON
PROHIBITION, WHICH DEFINES THE
WAY WE UNDERSTAND WHAT HARLEM
WAS LIKE IN THE
1920'S.
THE EVENT, RATHER THAN PLACES,
THIS IS ONE OF THE FIRST MAPS WE
CREATED, A RISK FOR NUMBERS IN
1925, WHICH -- IT SHOWS IN THE
FIRST INSTANCE, THE SHEER
PERVASIVENESS OF NUMBERS
GAMBLING, WHICH IS A PICTURE OF
MULTITUDE OF SOURCES REINFORCED
AND IT'S ONE REASON WHY SHANE
WHITE, SHANE GRANT, WROTE A BOOK
ABOUT THE WIDE RANGING ECONOMIC
AND CULTURAL ROLE OF NUMBERS
GAMBLING IS HARLEM IS ONE OF THE
OUTCOMES OF THEIR
COLLABORATION.
ZOOMING IN, HARLEM HELPED
PLACING BITS WAS WOVEN INTO
EVERY DAY LIFE.
A RISK OCCURRED ON STREET
CORNERS, AS RESIDENTS WERE ON
THEIR WAY TO WORK, AND THE BEES
LINING, THE AVENUES AS THEY
WITHIN SHOPPING  AND RANER ANDS,
AND HARLEM ON THE CROSS
STREETS.
NUMBERS WENT DOOR-TO-DOOR,
COLLECTING
BITS.
ENOUGH DATA TO REVEAL MORE THAN
A SINGLE MOMENT OF AN
INDIVIDUAL'S LIFE, PROVED BEYOND
OUR RESOURCES.
HOWEVER, WE DID GENERATE MAPS
FOR A HANDFUL OF PEOPLE.
BASED ON INFORMATION ON THE
RESIDENTS, WORK AND LEISURE AND
PAROLE RECORDS WANT THOSE MAPS
MAKE VISIBLE, THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THE LIVES OF HARLEM
RESIDENTS WERE NOT BOUNDED BY
THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
MAKE CLEAR THAT THE CENSUS DATA
THAT WE COMMONLY RELY ON TO
DETERMINE WHERE PEOPLE LIVED,
ULTIMATELY ONLY TELLS US WHERE
THEY SLEPT.
DURING THE 5 YEAR THAT IS MORGAN
THOMPSON WAS ON PROBATION, HIS
WORK TOOK HIM NOT ONLY UP SIDE
MANHATTAN, BUT TO THE BRONX,
QUEENS, AND BROOKLYN.
WE HAVE USED LINES WHERE OTHER
PEOPLE FREQUENTED.
THE GEOGRAPHYY WORK WAS
DIFFERENT FOR WOMEN.
LIKE THE MAJORITY OF HARLEM
PHONAL IN THE WORK FORCE,
FOUND MMENT AS DOMESTIC SERVER,
AND IN HOTELS AND LAUNDRY IN
LOWER MANHATTAN.
THE NEWEST VERSION ADD ACE TIME
LINE TO THIS, TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THESE TIME LINES EVOLVED.
TWO STRIKINGLY DISTANT
GEOGRAPHYIES, LIVING A CITY IS
NOT LIVING IN A NEIGHBORHOOD.
IT'S MOVING ACROSS THE CITY THAT
WE DON'T OFTEN PLACE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN PLACES LIKE
NEW YORK.
FOR ALL THE MAPS WE FEATURE ON
THE SITE AND WE DISCUSS IN OUR
SCHOLARSHIP, MUCH OF THE
USEFULNESS AND IMPACT OF DIGITAL
HARLEM, COMES  FROM HOW IT
ALLOWS USERS  TO MAKE THEIR OWN
MAPS.
RATHER THAN BEING CONTRAINED TO
WHAT THE ESTATES CREATED.
THAT CAPACITY HIGHLIGHTS THAT
THESE MAPS ARE EXPLORATORY, NOT
ELISE EISENBERG. -- LUST TIVE.
THEY RAISE QUESTIONS, RATHER
THAN ANSWERING THEM.
BUT THE SITE ITSELF, OFFERS
LIMITED HELP IN MAKING SENSE OF
A MAP AND THE DATA VISUALIZES.
THAT DESIGN IS IN KEEPING WITH
THE ORIGINAL CONCEPTION OF THE
SITE, WHICH IS A RESEARCH TOOL
FOR THOSE OF US COLLABORATING ON
THEIR ORIGINAL PROJECT Q. WE
DECIDED TO SHARE THE SITE, WE
ADDED SOME MATERIAL ABOUT THE
PLACES AND VANES FEATURE ON THE
SITE, AND ON THE INDIVIDUALS
WHOSE LIVES CAN BE MET.
AND WE CREATE AID BLOG LINK THE
TO THE ESTATE, WITH POSTS ABOUT
ADDITIONAL PLACES  AND EVENTS,
SUCH AS TRAFFIC MS, THAT
INCORPORATE ADDITIONAL MATERIAL
LIKE PHOTOGRAPHS.
UNFORTUNATELY, IF IT CAN ONLY GO
SO FAR.
CREATING A REAL CONTEXT TO
UNDERSTANDING THE DATA AND
DIGITAL HARLEM IS A PROJECT IN
ITS OWN RIGHT, THAT WILL REQUIRE
A WHOLE REDESIGN OF THE SITE.
IT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WE NEED
TO THINK ABOUT.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PRODUCING
SITES THAT ARE RESEARCH TOOL F
FOR PEOPLE WHO UNDERSTAND THE
DATA AT SOME LEVEL AND SITES
THAT ARE SHARED AND BROUGHT BY
PEOPLE WHO DON'T BRING RESEARCH
OF UNDERSTANDING TO THE SITE.A
MAJOR OPTION FOR MAKING DATA
MORE ACCESSIBLE AND USEFUL IS TO
USE WHAT'S IN DIGITAL HARLEM,
THE BASIS OF A SPATIAL
NARRATIVE, RATHER THAN SIMPLY A
MAP.
I'M CURRENTLY EXPLORING THAT
APPROACH FOR A PROJECT OF THE
1935 HARLEM RIOT, WHICH WE'RE
RATING ANOTHER DIGITAL VERSION
OF HARLEM.
THERE'S A MUCH GREATER WEALTH OF
INFORMATION ABOUT LIFE IN HARLEM
THAN THERE WAS IN THE 1920S --
CREATES A LINEAR SINGLE PATH
THROUGH A MAP CANNOT EFFECTIVELY
TELL THE STORY OF A COMPLEX AREA
LIKE THE RIOTS IN WHICH MULTIPLE
THINGS HAPPENED AT A GIVEN
TIME.
NEITHER CAN FOLLOW THE TIME LINE
IN DIGITAL HARLEM, YET, YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING ON IN
THE RIOT.
NEAT LINE, A METHOD PLUG IN, IT
WAS TALKING ABOUT EARLIER, GIVES
SOME SCOPE FOR MORE COMPLEX
STORY TELLING AND I'VE CREATED A
PROTOTYPE EXPERIENCE OF THE RIOT
JUST TO THINK ABOUT WHAT IS
POSSIBLE.
WHAT I REALLY LIKE ABOUT
NEATLINE IS THE TIME LINE SLIDER
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE IMAGE,
PROVIDES A MEANS OF NAVIGATING
THE EXHIBIT.
DRAGGING IT NOT ONLY CHANGES THE
POINTS APPEARED ON THE MAP.
IT ALTERS THE POINTS VISUAL ON
THE RIGHT.
POINTS DISPLAY INFORMATION.
WAY POINTS, CAN BE USED TO
EXPLORE BROADER ARGUMENTS THAT
CAN BE GROUPED TOGETHER.
RATHER THAN BEING TIDE TO A
SINGLE POINT ON THE TIME LINE.IT
GIVES YOU SOME FLEXIBILITY OF
HOW A NARRATIVE IS REARED.
CAN YOU ROLL OVER EACH WAY, OR
EXPLORE THEM IN A SEQUENCE OR AT
A SEQUENCE.
EACH WAVE POINT CAN BE
ASSOCIATED WITH A ZOOM LEVEL ON
A SPECIFIC LOCATION, CLICKOG A
SERIES OF WAY POINTS CAN THUS,
MOVE YOU AROUND AND YOU CAN
ANNOTATE WANT ATTACH THEM TO
POLYGONS, AND LINES, TO DRAW
ATTENTION TO THE ANALYSIS OF
SPACE IN MY UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE RIOT.
TO MOVEMENT, DIRECTION,
PROXIMITY.
CONNECTION AND PATTENS.
USED IN THAT WAY, AN NOTATIONS,
SHIFT SOME OF THE ARGUMENT INTO
VISUAL
FORM.
BUT THE FUTURE DIRECTION IN
VISUALIZING DATA ABOUT A USING
MAPS OF THIS PROTOTYPE POINTS
TORQUE IS THE CAPACITY TO MORE
EXTENSIVELY AND DYNAMICALLY
INGRATE MAPS  AND NARRATIVES, TO
VISUALLY COMBINE FAT DATA THATTA
AND INTERPRETATION WHILE
RETAINING THE ORIENTATION
TOWARDS PUTTING DATA IN CONTEXT,
WHICH TO ME, IS THE MOST
POWERFUL THING THAT MAPPING
MAKES US DO.
THANK
YOU.
M THANK YOU, STEVEN.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A 45
MACHINE LONG BREAK.
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
EXCEPTS FOR THE SPEAKERS, PLEASE
POST THEM ON SOCIAL MEDIA, USING
THE HASHTAG, # ASDATA.
OR E-MAIL
NDI@LOC GOT GOFF.
IF YOU'RE ON
--
NDI@LOC.GOV.
IF YOU'RE ON THE LIVE STREAM, WE
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING YOU
BACK.
.
[BREAK TAKEN]
...
REFERENCE
.
>> IT IS A GREAT DATA PROJECT
AND WE DO, IF SOME WAYS,
CONTRIBUTE TO T. IF YOU IMAGINE
THOSE, AS A REALLY NICE
RESTAURANT KITCHEN, WITH THE
FANCY, DISHWASHER ^, AND THE
FANCY SINK, WITH THE HOSE THAT
YOU CAN WIGGLE AROUND, AND THE
MAYBE ONE OF THOSE REFRIGERATOR
THAT IS HAS COLD WATER PUMP
THEY'RE LIKE, THAT'S GREAT.
REALLY, LIKE THE THING THAT
CONNECTS THE WHOLE RESTAURANT TO
THE CITY'S WATER MAIN IS REALLY
FAR BACK THERE.
THAT'S HOW I THINK OF SOME OF
THE WORK WE DO ON THE GRABBIVE
TEAM.
I THINK THE BEST WAY TO TALK
ABOUT THAT IS TO SHOW IT,
THROUGHOUT WAY THESE STORIES
COME TOGETHER.
SO HERE'S THE STORY.
ONCE UPON A TIME, THERE WAS A
TROUBLESOME WEB INTERFACE WANT
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE OF A WEB
INTERFACE THAT CAUSED ONE OF OUR
REPORTERS SOME TROUBLE.
THIS IS THE BUREAU OF PRISON.
THEY MAKE A WEBSITE THAT MAKE
ITS EASY TO FIND AN INMATE WHO
IS IN THE FEDERAL SYSTEM.
UNFORTUNATELY F DO YOU WANT FIND
AN INMATE.
WELL, YOU CAN'T JUST TYPE IN AN
AGE AND ANY INMATE THAT HAVE
AGE.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THE PERSON'S
AGE AND INFORMATION ABOUT THAT
SO IN ORDER TO DO THIS YOU HAVE
TO KNOW THAT INFORMATION AND
HERE'S AN
EXAMPLE.
IF YOU WANT TO FIND A LOT OF
PEOPLE, YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
ENTER THEM ONE AT A TIME.
A REPORTER CAME TO ME WITH A
LARGE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
SHE WANTED TO LOOK UP.
SHE WANTED TO LOOK THEM UP
BECAUSE THEY WERE CONVICTED OF
TERRORISM IN U.S. COURTS.
SHE WANTED TON WHERE THEY WERE
LOCATED.
THIS WAS A BIG DEAL, NOT TOO
LONG AGO BECAUSE THERE WAS A LOT
OF QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER PEOPLE
IN GUANTANAMO CAN BE TRIED OR
HELD IN THE UNITED
STATES THERE
WERE A LOT OF THEM AND IT WAS
GOING TO TAKE A LONG TIME.  MANY
OF THEM HAD THREE, FOUR NAMES
AND IT WASN'T QUITE CLEAR HOW
THEY DIVIDED INTO FIRST, MIDDLE
AND LAST NAMES.
SO THANKFULLY, SHE HAS A GOOD
SENSE TO APPLY A LITTLE SOFTWARE
BY TURNING AROUND.
I HAPPEN TO SIT RIGHT BEHIND
THIS PERSON.
SO IT WAS A VERY EASY REQUEST.
SHE SAID RACHEL, I FEED SOME
HELP.
HOW ARE WE GOING DO GET THIS
DATA OUT OF THE WEBSITE.
I KNOW THE DATA IS THERE, I JUST
NEED TO GET IT.
THE BACK END OF THAT WEBSITE
LOOKS LIKE THIS.
ANYBODY WHO HAS A LITTLE
FAMILIARITY, WILL PROBABLY HAVE
A WARM FEELING IN THEIR HEART
ABOUT HOW NICE AND EASY IT IS
FOR A SOFTWARE DEVELOP TORE PULL
DOWN DATA LIKE THIS PROCESS IT,
AND TURN IT INTO USABLE RECORDS
THAT THE REPORTER CAN USE.
I STARTED WORKING ON THIS.
SHE ASKED GOVERNMENT OFFICES,
AND EVERYONE WORKS  ON WHAT THEY
DID WE TURNED THIS INTO A STORY
THAT INCLUDED IN MAP.
WE FOUND OUT WHERE THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE CONVICTED  IN TERRORISM
IN UNITED STATES COURTS ARE
BEING HELD, INDEED, IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AND WROTE AN ACCOMPANYING STORY
ABOUT T. SO YOU NEED INFORMATION
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO GATHER AS A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN A REPORTER
AND A SOFTWARE ENGINEER WHO
WORKS  ON DATA THINGS, WE WERE
ABLE TO TELL A STORY THAT WAS
GENERALLY BEING TOLD AT THE
TIME.
A DOCTOR TESTIFIED  IN COURT,
HIS NAME WAS REDACTED.
SOME OF HIS BIOGRAPHICAL DETAILS
WERE AVAILABLE THOUGH, INCLUDING
HIS DATE OF BIRTH, DATE AND
PLACE OF CERTIFICATION.
AND SOME ADDITIONAL BIOGRAPHICAL
INFORMATION.
A REPORTER DISCOVERED THROSTLES
A SEARCH FUNCTIONALITY AVAILABLE
FOR THE AMERICAN BOARD OF
PSYCHIATRY AND NEUROLOGY THAT
LETS YOU DETERMINE
WHO WAS
CERTIFIED AND RECERTIFIED AT A
CERTAIN PLACE AND
TIME.
IF YOU LOOK AT THIS WEB
INTERFACE, YOU MIGHT KNOW THAT
DATA CERTIFICATION IS NOT AN
OPTION.
WHAT HE REALLY WANTED WAS TO
SEARCH BY DATE.
HE'S STUCK AT THIS
POINT.
SO JEREMY WAS ABLE TO PULL OUT
ALL OF THE DATA FROM THE
DATABASE AND DO THE SEARCH BY,
AND THEN GIVE IT TO THE REPORT
NEVER THIS FORMAT, WHERE HE
COULD SEARCH BY
DATE.
THERE ABOUT 900 PEOPLE THAT
MATCH THE DATE THAT THE REPORTER
WAS INTERESTED IN.
WHAT HE DID AT THAT POINT, HE
STARTED CATEGORY GOOGLING.
HE GOOGLED 88 OF THESE PEOPLE
AND FOUND SOMEBODY WHO, BASED ON
OTHER INFORMATION THAT WAS
AVAILABLE ON LINE, MATCHED OTHER
BIOGRAPHICAL INFORMATION IN THE
TESTIMONY HE HAD
READ.
SO AFTER DOING THIS GOOGLING,
THE REPORTINGS TEAM SENT SOMEONE
TO THE HOUSE-DOCTOR, KNOCKED ON
THE DOOR AND THEY OFFERED AN
INNER VIEW AND THEY GOT AN HOUR
ON THE RECORD TO TEST.
THIS IS REALLY A STORY THAT
COULD NOT HAVE COME ABOUT
WITHOUT TRUE REPORTER
COLLABORATION.  WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE IDEA TO GO AND PULL DATA OFF
THAT WEBSITE.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO
AND KNOCK ON THE DOOR AND ASK.
I'M A SOFTWARE ENGINEER.
CAN YOU IMAGINE ME KNOCKOG YOUR
DOOR, I'D BE LIKE, I'M WITH THE
FORK TIMES AND I'D LIKE TO ASK
YOU?
QUESTIONS.
AND IT PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE
GONE WELL.
SO IT WAS REALLY A GREAT
COLLABORATION.
HERE'S THE STORY THAT RESULTED.
IT WAS ACTUALLY PART OF A 5-PART
SERIES ABOUT MEDICAL AND
PSYCHIATRIC CARE AT GUANTANAMO
BAY WANT THIS IS A CASE WHERE IF
YOU LOOK AT THE STORY, YOU WOULD
HAVE NO IDEA THAT A SOFTWARE
ENGINEER OR ANY KIND OF DATA
COMB POINTS MAY HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED BECAUSE THERE'S NO
GRAPHICS.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT LOOKS LIKE
DATA TO YOU.
BUT THE DATA COMPONENT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT IN THE
REPORTING.
IT'S HOW WE SAW THE SOURCE AND
TOLD THE STORY:  YEAH.
SO I'M GOING TO TELL YOU ANOTHER
STORY.
THIS IS A STORY ABOUT DATA THAT
IS TOO BIG FOR A REPORTER.
ONCE UPON A TIME, THE DATA JUST
KEPT COMING  AND COMING.
THIS IS A LOT OF
DATA CAN ANYONE
TELL WHATS  IN?
CAN YOU GUYS SEE ALONE.
CAN YOU TELL WHAT THIS DATA IS
OF?
OH.
WE HAVE GOT IT OVER THERE.  IT'S
THE OLYMPICS.
THIS IS WHAT THE OLYMPICS LOOKS
LIKE.
ON THE BACK END.
DURING DISNEY COMPETITIONS, WE
CAN GET 20 MESSAGES A SECOND
FROM THE OLYMPIC DATA STREAM.
AND IN THIS CASE, NO ONE PASSES
GO, OR COLLECTS $200.
HUGE AMOUNTS OF THE TIMES
OLYMPICS COVERAGE
IS BY TWO
NERDS SITTING IN THE CITY -- OUR
TEAM KEEPS, IN FACT, OUR TEAM
KEEPS A COLLECTION OF OLYMPIC
MASCOTS, THE LITTLE DOLLS
BECAUSE THE OLYMPICS ARE SUCH A
HUGE PART OF THE DATA THAT WE
DO.
SO WHAT DO WE DO?
WE POWER GRAPH T WE GET
REPORTERS, THE MOST ACCURATE
INFORMATION AND TIME.  AND WE
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
SO IF YOU ENJOY WATCHING "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" COVER THE
OLYMPICS, IF YOU DO THINGS LIKE
SPLIT TIMES, YOU WANT TO SEE
THOSE RACE THAT IS RUN IN REAL
TIME AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
THAT'S ALL THANKS TO THIS DATA
STREAM.ORGANIZATIONS WHO COVER
THE
OLYMPIC FEEDS ARE REQUIRED TO
PARTICIPATE IN MASSIVE TESTING
EXERCISES AS PART OF THEIR DATA
CONTRACT WITH THE GAME, THAT
START NEARLY A YEAR IN ADVANCE
SO IF YOU ENJOY WATCHING KIND OF
COVERAGE, ANY WAY, THIS IS ONE
OF MY FAVORITE STORIES  FROM
RIO.
I KNOW IT'S NOT AS EXCITING AS
KATY LEDECKY WINNING BY
NEVER-SEEN-BEFORE SECONDS OR
WHATEVER IT WAS.
BUT IT'S A NARRATIVE THAT CAME
OUT OF THE
DATA
HE HAD HIS EYE
ON BOXING FROM THE BEGINNING AND
HE NOTICED, HE WAS TALK TO THE
REPORTER WHO WAS WORKING ON IT
AND THEY NOTICED THAT THERE WAS
SOME SCANDAL ABOUT COMPETITORS
WHO WERE WORRY THAT WOULD JUDGES
WERE BIAS AND THEY WANTED TO
TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF A LOOK AT
THAT.
THEY WANTED TO KNOW, WHAT ARE WE
SEEING.
WHEN THEY STARTED LOOKING, THEY
RELIGHTED THERE WERE SOME JUDGES
WHO DISAPPEARED FROM COMPETITION
BECAUSE JUDGES ARE IN THAT DATA
SET.
THERE WERE JUDGES WHO JUDGED AT
THE BEGINNING AND STOPPED
JUDGING AND THERE WAS NO CLEAR
REASON.
THEY WEREN'T LIKE, THEIR RATINGS
WEREN'T BAD.
THEY JUST DISAPPEARED.
SO THEY WERE ABLE TO USE THE
DATA TO FIND THE STORY, THAT THE
JUDGES WERE JUST GONE.
THEY WERE DISMISSED, BUT IT WAS
BECAUSE.
LET ME TELL YOU ANOTHER STORY.
ONCE UPON A TIME, OPEN
GOVERNMENT DATA WAS IN THIS
ADVERSARIAL FORMAT.
UH-OH.
HEARD SOME LAUGHING THERE.
AS YOU MAY BE AWARE WE HAD
ANOTHER EVENT IN WASHINGTON THIS
JANUARY.
THE PRESIDENTIAL INAUGURATION.
AFTER EVERY PARTY COMES, THE
COST OF OUR PRESIDENTIAL
INAUGURATION IS COVERED BY
FUNDRAISING BY THE INAUGURAL
COMMIT AND HE THEY HAVE TO
RELEASE A LIST OF DONARS FROM
THE FEDERAL COLLECTION
COMMITTEE.
WHAT THEY DID, THEY TOOK THIS
REPORT AND DELIVERED IT ON PAPER
TO THE FEDERAL -- WE KNOCKED ON
THE DOOR AND HANDED IT TO THE
FEDERAL ELECTION COMMISSION.
I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THIS IS NOT HOW THEY HAD TO
RELEASE IT.
IT'S NOT IN STATUTE THAT THEY
HAVE TO RELEASE IT IN PAPER.
THE LAST TWO OF THEM WILL BE
SPENT ON LINE AND IT'S NOT LIKE
THEY TYPE THIS OUT ON A
TYPEWRITER AND THAT WAS THE ONLY
WAY THEY COULD DO IT.
THIS IS SOFTWARE.
THEY JUST CHOSE TO HIT THE PRINT
BUTTON, INSTEAD OF SEND TO SEC
BUTTON.
SO IT WAS NOT MACHINE READABLE
DATA SO BASICALLY, THE VERY NEXT
CALL WAS FIND ME A NERD.
THE NEWS NERDS, AREN'T THAT MUCH
HELP IN THIS SITUATION MUCH THE
DATA IS PRETTY BADLY LOCKED UP
AND WE ANYHOW T. WHAT DID WE
DO?
WE COMBINED OUR NERD POWERS MUCH
THIS IS A REPOSITORY FROM AN
EDITOR AT THE "WASHINGTON POST"
NAMED STEVEN RICH.
HE STARTED MANUALLY CLEANING THE
STYLE IN PUBLIC PRETTY QUICK
PRETTY QUICKLY HE HAD
COLLABORATORS AT A VARIETY OF
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND A FEW OTHER FOLKS.
SO IN THE END, WE HAD FIVE
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS
CONTRIBUTED TO THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION.
ANOTHER FUN FANG ABOUT THIS DAY
IS THAT I SAW THIS WAS OUT AS I
WAS EATING MY BREAKFAST AND THE
NEXT THING I REMEMBER, IT WAS
4:00 IN THE AFTERNOON AND I WAS
SITTING IN MY SOFA ON THE
PAJAMAS, MANUALLY ENTERING
THIS.
LIKE THE COLLABORATION, THE NEWS
REGULATIONS READ THEIR OWN
STORIES.
BUT THE BACKGROUND DATA WAS IN
SOME WAYS, COLLABORATIVELY
MANAGED.
THE SAD NEWS NOTORIETY NERDS, BY
DOING ALL THIS WORK.
WE RAPID REPORTERS DISCOVER
THERE WERE SOME ISSUES WITH THE
FILING, AND JUST A FEW ERRORS IN
THE WAY IT WAS FILED.
THAT MEANS THEY HAD TO FILE AN
AMENDED REPORT.
WHAT DID THAT MEAN?
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE PAPER
FILINGS CAME OUT ABOUT THREE
MONTHS LATER THAT WE ALL HAD TO
DIG INTO
AGAIN.PERHAPS YOU HEARD OF
THIS GUY.
HE'S FAMOUS THESE DAYS.
HAMILTON.
APPARENTLY, PEOPLE REALLY LIKED
IT.
THEY LIKED IT SO
MUCH
.
IT WAS THE PRICE FOR ONE TICKET
WANT THEY WOULD DOUBLE IT IF YOU
BOUGHT TWO OF THEM.
ONE OF THE MAJOR PROBLEMS, ONE
OF THE REASONS THE TICKETS ARE
SO EXPENSIVE IS THE RESALE
MARKET.  AND PEOPLE IN KNOWABLY
AT NEW YORK TIMES WERE REALLY
INTERESTED IN HOW THIS MARKET
WAS WORKING  AND WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AND HOW RESALE
COMPANIES WERE USING BOX -- THEY
THOUGHT F ONLY WE COULD MONITOR
WHAT THE COSTS ARE.
I BET YOU'LL NEVER GUESS WHAT'S
COMING NEXT.
YES, THEY CALLED IN THE NERDS.
IN THIS CASES IT WAS MY
COLLEAGUE AND SHE BASICALLY
WROTE A TICKET BUYING BOT.
INSTEAD OF BUYING TICKS, ALL IT
DID WAS LOOK AT THE PRICES.
TURNS OUT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE TIMES
WERE INTERESTED IN THIS.
TIF WAS ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER A
FULL STRUCTURED DATA SET.
THAT HELPED REPORTERS UNDERSTAND
COPING WITH THE SKILLS  ON
BROADWAY FOR A VARIETY OF
STORIES THEY WERE TELLING.
THIS IS WHAT HAMILTON, SCALPERS
WERE MAKE IN (INAUDIBLE).
SO HOW AM I DOING ON TIME?
OKAY.
I'M GOING TO ADD ONE MORE STORY
I DON'T HAVE SLIDES FOR BECAUSE
IT'S PARTICULARLY RELEVANT
TODAY.
THE ONE RECENT SITUATION WHERE
WE REALLY WANTED TO GET?
DATA IS THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, OUR NEIGHBORS
RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET WERE
VOTING ON A HEALTHCARE BILL.
IT'S HARD TO GET DATE DATA
THATTA OUT OF THE HOUSE AND SEN
ATE QUICKLY.
A LOT OF IT IS BEING RECORDED BY
HAND BITE CLERK OF THE
BY THE
CLERK IN THE CHAMBER.
WHAT WE'LL PROBABLY DO NOT HOUSE
AND IN THE SEN ATE THIS
AFTERNOON.
AND I APOLOGIZE, I HAVE TO LEAVE
EARLY S. HAVING PEOPLE SIT IN
THE CHAMBER AND WRITE BY HAND,
RUN OUT, TAKE A PHOTOGRAPH, SEND
IT TO SOMEONE FROM NEW YORK
WHO'S GOING TO TRIBE T. AND RUN
BACK N. WE ARE MANUALLY ENTERING
DATA ABOUT A SEND TOGETHER BACK
AND MAKING IT ELECTRONIC THAT
WAY.  IN SOME CASES, THAT'S THE
FASTEST WAY TO DO IT AND IT
WORKS VERY WELL FOR US IN
GETTING HOUSE VOTES LIVE.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE SAID, WHY DO
YOU NEED TO DO THAT?
THE DATA IS GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE IN 40 MINUTES MAYBE.
ONE THING YOU CAN'T GET FROM
THAT DATA ABOUT A ESPECIALLY IN
THE HOUSE IS WHEN PEOPLE CHANGE
THEIR VOTES WHICH IS A COMMON
SAT STRATEGY IN THE HOUSE.
SOMETIMES IT'S ACCIDENTAL.
THE WAY YOU VOTE IN THE HOUSE, I
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT HOW YOU VOTE
IN OUR BODIES REPRESENTATION.
IN THE HOUSE, YOU SLIDE A LITTLE
CARD INTO A MACHINE AND THEN YOU
HIT, THERE'S A BIG YES AND NO
BUTTON AND YOU HIT THE BUTTON.
PEOPLE HIT THE WRONG BUTTON.
THERE WAS A SCANDAL A LITTLE
WHILE AGO THAT PEOPLE WERE
LETTING THEIR KIDS VOTE FOR
THEM.
WHICH WAS CAUSING THESE FEW
RYSE.
IF THEY VOTE INCORRECTLY, THEY
CAN GO AND CHANGE THEIR VOTE
BACK.
THERE'S SOME THOUGHT THAT PEOPLE
MIGHT VOTE STRATEGICALLY.
THEY MIGHT SAY NO OR YES.
IF IF THEY'RE NOT REALLY NEEDED
IN THE FUNNEL COUNT -- BY
RECORDING THE VOTES  IN REAL
TIME, WE WERE ABLE TO GET NA
INFORMATION OUT.
IT WAS HARD TO DO.
WE NEEDED 5 PEOPLE IN THE
CHAMBER AND WE'RE HOPING TO BE
ABLE TO GET BY WITH A FEW FEWER
PEOPLE.
WE ALSO WORK WITH DATA FOR
NEARLY EVERY DEFINITION OF THE
WORD DATA YEAH.
SO I'M ENDING THIS THE WAY GOOD
STORIES END WITH A HAPPILY EVER
AFTER.
SO THANKS TO MY COLLEAGUES, WHO
WALKED ME THROUGH SOME OF THE
WORK THEY DID, ON DATA TOA
STORIES SO I CAN SHARE A MORE
WIDER PERSPECTIVE AND YEAH,
THAT'S ALL I'VE
GOT.
[APPLAUSE].
>> THANK YOU, RACHEL.
NEXT IS JESSE DANIELS, PROFESSOR
OF SEWS AT HUNTER COLLEGE.
SHE STUDIES RACE AND DIGITAL
MEDIA TECHNOLOGIES  AND SHE IS
GOING TO SHARE A STORY ABOUT HOW
SOME LIBRARY COLLECTIONS CAN BE
MANIPULATED BY HATE GROUPS  ON
LINE, WITH HER
PRESENTATION "EXTREMISTS IN THE
ARCHIVE." JESSE.
>> THANKS.
IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE . I'M HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT EXTREMISTS
IN THE ARCHIVE.
AND PART OF WHAT MY RESEARCH HAS
LED ME TO BELIEVE IS YOU CAN'T
UNDERSTAND A WORLD IN WHICH WE
LIVE TODAY, WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING WHITE SUPREMACY.
BOTH THE SYSTEM OF IDEA THAT IS
SETS WHITE PEOPLE ABOVE ALL
OTHERS, AND ALSO, THE EXTREMIST
GROUPS THAT I'VE ENCOUNTERED IN
SOME OF MY RESEARCH IN THE
ARCHIVE.
THE FIRST THING I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU IS THIS SLIDE.
THIS IS FROM AN EXTREMIST
WEBSITE THAT WAS FOUND AMERICAN
CIVIL RIGHTS
REVIEW AND IT WAS
COVERED BY A COLLEGE STUDENT OF
MINE WHEN I TAUGHT IN SUBURBAN
LONG ISLAND AT THE TIME.
PART OF THIS WEB SIGHS WAS
ARGUING THROUGH A WHITE EXTREME
SIFT LENS IS SLAVERY WASN'T THAT
BAD.  AND THEY WERE USING
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS DIGITAL
ARCHIVES OF THE WPA PROJECT
NA
ARGUED FORMAL SLAVERY.
I WANT TO TELL THE STORY OF HOW
I DISCOVERED THIS WEBSITE, AND
HOW WE GOT TO HERE.
LET ME TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MY RESEARCH.
IN THE 90'S, I STARTED,
ACTUALLY, IN THE LATE 80'S, BUT
I STARTED PUBLISHING IN
19NEVER-SEEN-BEFORE, SOME
RESEARCH I HAD DONE ON A PRINTED
ARCHIVE OF NEWLETTERS FROM SIX
DIFFERENT EXTREMISTS
ORGANIZATIONS, INCLUDING THE KKK
AND DAVID DUKES' ORGANIZATIONS,
A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT ONES, AND
TO DO THIS RESEARCH, THIS IS MY
DISSERTATION AND BECAME MY FIRST
BOOK.
TO DO THIS RESEARCH.
I DROVE 7 HOURS FROM WHERE I WAS
IN SCHOOL TO AUSTIN, TEXAS TO
MONTGOMERY, ALABAMA, WHERE THEY
KEEP A CLAN WATCH ARCHIVE.
THEY KEEP A TROVE OF THESE
PRINTED NEWLETTERS OF EXTREMIST
GROUPS, AND I SAT OVER A COPY
MACHINE FOR THREE, FOUR DAYS AND
THROUGH THEIR GENEROSITY,
DEVELOPED MY ARCHIVE FOR THAT
FIST PUBLICATION.
IN THAT RESEARCH, I ARGUED THAT
WHITE
SUPREMACIST RHETORIC IS
GENDERED.
THE THINGS THEY SAY ABOUT RACE,
OFTEN HAVE SOME OTHER MESSAGE
ABOUT MASCULINITY OR FEMININITY
IN THEM.
I WAS FASCINATED BY THE WAY THEY
TALKED ABOUT WHITE MAN, AND I'LL
SAY MORE ABOUT THAT IN A
SECOND.
THE SECOND YOU WEREMENT I MADE
WHICH I THINK IS RELEVANT TODAY
IS WHITE SUPREMACIST RHETORIC IS
SIMILAR TO MAINSTREAM POPULAR
CULTURE RHETORIC.
SO LOOKING AT THOSE EXTREMIST
PUBLICATIONS AND I COMPARE THEM
TO THE MAINSTREAM RHETORIC TO
POLITICIANS LIKE PAT BUCHANAN,
AND LOOKED AT POPULAR CULTURE
SCENES AND THERE WAS A LOT OF
RESONANCE BETWEEN THE TWO.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THERE ARE
SIMILAR IN SOME WAYS.
AND THEN ABOUT THE GENDER
ARGUMENT, IT CAME TOGETHER WITH
THE ARGUMENT THAT THEY'RE
SIMILAR IN TO THE MAINSTREAM.SO
NOT ONLY DID I LOOK AT THE
TEXT.
I ALSO LOOKED AT THE IMAGES AND
LINE DRAWINGS.
THIS ONE IS FROM TOM
MESSGER'S
-- THAT'S A DRAWING OF A WHITE
MAN, HE'S WEARING BASEBALL CAP.
I DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S RED, BUT
HE HAS ON A CONSTRUCTION VEST IN
THE BACKGROUND ARE BRIDGES AND
CITIES, AND AN AIRPLANE.
THE MANY S WHITE MEN BUILT THIS
NATION, WHITE MEN ARE THIS
NATION AND MY ARGUMENT ABOUT THE
MAINSTREAM, YOU CAN SEE A RECENT
EXAMPLE FROM, THIS IS THE
HISTORY CHANNEL.
THE AMERICAN ECONOMY WAS LINKED
BY RAILROAD, FUELED BY OIL AND
BUILT BY STEEL.
THIS RHETORIC AND ARGUMENT ABOUT
WHITE SUPREMACY IS RACE IS
IGNORE PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
NATIVE-AMERICANS WHO WERE IN
THIS LAND BEFORE.
SO THAT'S THE WORK I DID EARLY
ON.
THEN THE INTERNET HAPPENED.
NOW, I KNOW FOR YOU SITTING IN
THIS SESSION, YOU KNOW THE
INTERNET HAPPENED WELL BEFORE
19NEVER-SEEN-BEFORE, BUT IT
--
WELL BEFORE 1997.
I KEPT FOLLOWING THE SAME GROUPS
I HAD LOOKED AT AND AN LYSED IN
THE PRINTED PUBLICATIONS AND
ANALYZED IN THE PRINTED
PUBLICATION.
SUICIDE BOMBER RACISM.
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO YOU'VE 7
HOURS TO THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER ARCHIVES, THE WHITE
EXTREME SIFT ARCHIVES I STUDIED
BEFORE WAS MUCH EASIER TO
ACCESS.
I COULD FIND IT IN MY LIVING
ROOM AND DIAL IT UP THAT WAY
WANT IT WAS ALSO GLOBAL SO
PEOPLE WERE MAKING CONNECTIONS
ACROSS THE GLOBE, AROUND WHITE
SUPREME S'.  AND PEOPLE WERE
CONTRIBUTING THEIR OWN TAKES  ON
IT.
WHEN I CHECKED LAST WEEK, THEY
WERE AT 325,683.
AND THAT NUMBER ONLY GOES UP OR
IT HAS SO FAR SINCE I'VE BEEN
RESEARCHING IT.
ON THE NIGHT PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS
ELECTED  IN 2008, SO MANY PEOPLE
WENT TO STORM FRONT, THEY
CRASHED THE SERVERS THERE SO I
WAS CONCERN ABOUT THE EXTREMIST
GROUPS, AND I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT MY STUDENTS AND I WAS
TEACHING ON A PRIVATE UNIVERSITY
IN LONG ISLAND WANT I WAS
CONCERN ABOUT HOW THEY WERE
GOING TO STUMBLE UPON WHITE
SUPREMACISTS ON LINE AND DOING
THEIR TERM PAPERS.
I WANT TO TELL THE STORY ABOUT
TAKING MY STUDENTS TO LONG
ISLAND, BEFORE GOOGLE EVEN.
SO WE WERE USING DIFFERENT
SEARCH ENGINES, YAHOO, ALTA
VISTA.
LOTS OF DIFFERENT SEARCH ENGINES
THAT HAVE GONE BY THE WAY SIDE
NOW.
TUNES COME IN, AND ONE STUDENT
TYPES, THE FIRST THING THAT
STUDENT TYPES IN IS "KKK" INTO A
SEARCH ENGINE.
AND ANOTHER STUDENT TYPED  IN
MARTIN LUTHER KING INTO A SEARCH
ENGINE.
THEY BOTH ENDED UP AT WHITE
SUPREMACIST SITES.
AND I SAID THAT'S REALLY WHAT
I'M INTERESTED IN, IN THIS WORK
IS UNDERSTANDING MY STUDENT
SEARCH PATTERNS AND HOW THEY
MIGHT STUMBLE UPON WHITE
SUPREMACIST RHETORIC.
THIS IS THE SITE MY STUDENT CAME
UPON.
THIS IS WHAT I REFER TO, IT
APPEARS TO BE A TRIBUTE TO
DR. KING, BUT IN FACT, IT'S RUN
BY STORM FRONT THAT, LARGE
PORTAL I JUST SHOWED YOU
PREVIOUSLY.
THIS IS WHAT I CALLED A CLOAKED
WEBSITE.
LIKE THE PRESENTATION TALKING
ABOUT SLAVERY, WHAT BOTH OF
THESE SITES  AND LOTS OF OTHERS
I CAN TELL YOU ABOUT LATER DO,
IS THEY INTENTIONALLY DISGUISE
AUTHORSHIP, IN ORDER TO CONCEAL
A POLITICAL AGENDA.
IN SOME WAYS, THESE CLOAKED
WEBSITES WERE PRECURSORS TO
TODAY'S NEWS.
PART OF WHAT MAKES THEM
DIFFICULT TO DECIPHER, IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHO IS PUBLISHING THEM,
AND WHAT THEIR POINT OF VIEW S.
SO THIS IS ESPECIALLY DIFFICULT
FOR MY STUDENTS IN COLLEGE
CLASSES, EVEN THOUGH WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THESE
ISSUES ALREADY, THEY STRUGGLE TO
MAKE SENSE OF THEM.
SO THIS IS WHAT I DECIDED TO DO
IN TERMS OF MY RESEARCH.
I WOULD ASK YOUNG PEOPLE, TILE,
YOUNGER THAN COLLEGE STUDENTS.
SO I RECRUITED PARTICIPANTS WHO
WERE 15-19 YEARS OLD, ALL FROM
NEW YORK, ALL FROM FAIRLY I GOOD
HIGH SCHOOLS AND ASK THEM TO TRY
AND MAKE SENSE OF THESE SEARCH
RESULTS.
LIKE IF THEY SEARCH FOR
INFORMATION ON DR. KING, AND
CAME ACROSS THIS SITE, HOW WOULD
THEY MAKE SENSE TELEVISION, AND
I ALSO ASKED THEM TO EVALUATE
PARIS OF WEBSITE.
SO I WOULD PAIR A CLOAK SITE
WITH A LEGITIMATE CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION SITE.
SO THIS IS A PAIRING HERE OF A
MARTIN LUTHER KING SITE, AND THE
SITE FROM THE KING FAMILY IN
THEIR ARCHIVE OF KINGS PAPER AND
THAT SORT OF THING.
THE SECOND PAIRING I CAN WAS A
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS SITE.
I PAIRED THAT CLOSED SITE, THE
AMERICAN CIVIL RIGHTS REVIEW
THAT HAS THE FLAVOR INFORMATION
WITH WPA, WITH THE HOST OF CIVIL
RIGHTS, WHICH WAS HOSTED HERE AT
THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
AND ASKED YOUNG PEOPLE, HOW
WOULD YOU MAKE SENSE OF THIS?
WHO I FOUND WAS INTERESTING, IN
TERMS OF THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF
THIS MATERIAL, AND HOW THEY MADE
SENSE OF INFORMATION FROM THE
ARCHIVE.
THE FIRST THING, AND THIS IS THE
AND THIS IS THE ENCOURAGING PART
OF MY TALK.
THEY WERE VERY SATISFY.
EVEN IN 2007, 2008 WHEN I WAS
DOING THIS ANALYSIS, THEY WERE
VERY SAVVY ABOUT THE WAY THAT
WEBSITINGS LOOKED.
THEY PICKED UP ON GRAPHIC
USERRISH FACE.
ON COLORS THAT WERE NOT GOOD AND
FONTS THAT WERE NOT CLEAR OR
DIDN'T LOOK SOPHISTICATED THIS.
YOUNG PERSON SAID THE SITE LOOKS
LIKE, YOU KNOW, SOMETHING AN
INDIVIDUAL CREATED.
IT DOESN'T LOOK VERY PROPOSAL.
SO SHE SAID SHE WOULDN'T TRUST
T. THE GOOD NEWS IS, THEY WERE
VERY SOPHISTICATED ABOUT THE
LOOK OF SITES.  THE BAD NUDES WE
KNOW NOW IS ALL IT
NEWS IS ALL
IT TAKES IS A GOOD GRAPHIC
DESIGNER TO FOOL SOMEONE WITH
THE INFORMATION.
BEYOND THE LOOK OF THE SITE, HOW
DO YOU EVALUATE THE CONTENT THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT HERE, AND THIS
IS A PAGE FURTHER INTO THAT ONE
ABOUT SLAVERY, AND WHAT'S
INTERESTING, WHEN I WANTED TO
POINT OUT HERE, IS PART OF THIS
WHITE SUPREMACIST HAD DONE, WAS
TO HE HAD TAKEN THIS APPROACH OF
FORGOTTEN BLACK VOICES, AND
TAKEN THE WTA FORMALLY ENCLOSED
SLAVE PEOPLE WHO WOULD SAY YES,
WE WERE ALLOWED TO GROW
VEGETABLES WHEN WE WERE ENSLAVED
AND TAKE ITS OUT OF CONTEXT AND
REFRAINS THEM IN A WHITE IS R
SUPREMACIST CONTEXT.
FOR SOME OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE I
TALK T. THIS IS VERY HARD TO
MAKE SENSE OF.
THIS IS SOME OF WHAT THEY SAID.
ONE YOUNG PERSON SAID, LOOKING
AT THIS SITE.
I MEAN, I DON'T THINK I WOULD
DISAGREE WITH T. I'M SURE THERE
WERE SOME SLAVES THAT WERE
TREATED L. I CAN UNDERSTAND
THEIR POINT OF VIEW.
THERE'S ALWAYS TWO SIDES  TO
EVERYTHING.
AS AN EDUCATOR, THIS IS A LITTLE
HORRIFYING AND I'M SURE SOME OF
YOU SOME OF THAT AS WELL.
ONE OF THE OTHER PARTICIPANTS I
TALKED TO, READ THIS MATERIAL
AND SAID I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE I'VE READ OTHER THINGS
ABOUT SLAVERY, AND THIS ISN'T
TRUE.
MY RESEARCH, FITS  ON M, ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE INTERNET.
ANALYSIS, AND THE PINNED ONLY
NEWS LETTER, AND THEN IN THE
INTERNET ERA OF THEIR WORK.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT WHETHER IN A
PRINTED ARCHIVE, AT THE SOUTHERN
POVERTY LAW CENTER OR IN A
DIGITAL ARCHIVE AT THE LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS, THE GOAL OF WHITE
SUPREMACY IS THE SAME.
BOTH BEFORE AND AFTER THE
INTERNET.
AND THAT IS TO ROLE BACK HARD
ONE, SOCIAL, LEGAL, POLITICAL
AND MORAL
VICTORIES
AND WHAT WE
KNOW IS DIGITAL ARCHIVES MAKE
THIS IS EASIER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[APPLAUSE].
>> THANK YOU, JESSE.
IN OUR FINAL TALK BEFORE LUNCH,
PATRICK CRONIN AND THOMAS
NEVELL, ORGANIZERS OF THAT
CLASS, WILL SHARE A STORY ABOUT
THEIR SUMMER CAMP LAST YEAR,
WORKING WITH HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS  TO RESEARCH 1968
WASHINGTON D.C. RIOTS.
THOMAS, PATRICK, PLEASE TAKE IT
AWAY.
>> HONORED TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>> VIDEO: EVERYBODY READY.
[SINGING]
>> I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT, I JUST LOOK AT HOW MUSIC
SOCIETY, CULTURE, AND JUST
REALLY, GOING ABOUT MUSIC AND I
WAS TOLD ABOUT A COURT
CASE IT
WAS CALLED HOUND DOG, AND
(INAUDIBLE) AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN
[INDISCERNIBLE] BUT IT WAS THEIR
SONG, BUT ELVIS MADE IT HIS
SONG.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO FIND?
>> I'M NOT SURE RIGHT NOW.
BUT I'M STILL TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT HE GOT ARRESTED FOR.BUT
I DON'T KNOW
YET.>> (INAUDIBLE).
>> HOW DID YOU COME ABOUT,
WANTING  TO KNOW ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, THE IDEA IS THE HOUSING
SO I'M LOOKING AT HOUSING
DESIGN
AND I'M ALSO GOING TO LOOK AT
DESIGN.
I WANT TO HAVE A NEW DESIGN
TADOESN'T VICTIMIZE THE
RESIDENTS.
>> THE INTERNET YOU'RE JUST
LOOKING TO ADD A DIGITAL COPY.I
CAN'T IMAGINE THAT KIDS GET
OPENLY EXCITED.
>> THIS DEFINITELY PROVIDES FOR
MORE INTERESTING ASPECTS THAN IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT COMPUTERS.
TAN JUST COMING HERE AND LOOKING
IN PERSON, YOU GET AN
INTERESTING
VIEW.
>> PHYSICALLY IN FRONT OF YOU,
WHAT IS
THAT?
>> I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY WHAT
THIS IS.
BUT I KNOW, THE ONE BEFORE IT,
BECAUSE THESE ARE RECORDS.
AND
THEY'RE 45.
AND THIS RIGHT HERE IS HOUND
DOG.
>> I WAS LISTENING TO MUSIC ON
THIS -- HOW IS LINKING  TO MUSIC
ON THIS, THAN LISTENING TO IT ON
THAT?
IS IT THE SAME?
>> IT'S NOT THE
SAME.
IT'S VERY AUTHENTIC, I WOULD
SAY.
ALL THE SNAP CRACKEL AND POP.
>> THE OTHER THING IS NOT
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE ON THE
INTERNET.
WE CALCULATED THAT IF WE SCAN
40,000 SCANS A MONTH HERE, WE'D
BE DONE IN 1300 YEARS.
SO NOT EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE
ON THE INTERNET WHAT IS ON THE
INTERNET HAS ALREADY BEEN
DISCOVERED.
WHERE YOU HAVE THE BOX
EXPERIENCE, YOU MAY FIND
SOMETHING ELSE THAT NOBODY ELSE
HAS FOUND.
AND THAT IS ACTUALLY MORE
COMMON.
>> DID THAT HAPPEN TODAY.
>> YEAH, A YOUNG LADY WAS
LOOKING AT A RECORD GROUP.
RG31.
I DON'T REMEMBER THE NAME OF THE
RECORD GROUP.
I HAD NEVER BEEN ON THAT RECORD
GROUP.
NATHAN HAD NEVER BEEN ON THAT
RECORD GROUP.
AND WE HAVE WORKED HERE FOR A
COMBINED 22
YEARS.
>> I WANT SEE IF I CAN BRING
BOTH OF THESE PEOPLE TOGETHER.
SO IT DOESN'T VICTIMIZE A LOWER
CLASS THAN UPPER CLASS.
>>
OKAY.
THANK
YOU.
>> TRADITIONALLY, WHEN STUDENTS
GO TO THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES OR A
SPECIAL COLLECTIONS AREA, THEY
GET A TOUR AND THEY'RE LUCKY, IF
THEY SEE MAYBE SOME PRIZE
COLLECTIONS AND THEN THEY GO
HOME.
SO BEFORE LUNCH, THIS GROUP GOT
TO USE A FINDING AGE THEMSELVES,
THEY GOT TO CONSULT PRIVATELY
WITH AN ACTIVIST AND THEY GOT TO
TOUCH NEGLECTED ARCHIVAL
MATERIALS.SO PATRICK AND I
STARTED WORK
WITH STUDENTS  IN ARCHIVES ABOUT
5 YEARS AGO.
WE WERE BOTH TEACHING HISTORY AT
A NEARBY HIGH SCHOOL TOGETHER.
WHEN WE WHEN WE ARRIVED, IT WAS
ONE OF THE SCHOOLS WHERE LARGELY
THAT ENGAGEMENT IN THE PAST WAS
RESTRICT TO THE TESTING
CURRICULUM.
PATRICK HAD COME IN WITH A LOT
OF LEARNING EXPERIENCE.
I'VE BEEN DABBLING WITH ARCHIVES
AND WE HAD BEEN STRATEGIZEOG
WHAT MIGHT MAKE A RICHER
EXPERIENCE FOR THE STUDENTS  AND
WHAT WHAT MIGHT THEY ACTUALLY BE
CAPABLE OF IF YOU PUT THEM IN
THAT POSITION.
AND THE RESULT WAS, US BEING THE
STUDENT IT IS FIRST, AS YOU SAW
ON THE LAST SLIDE.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T JUST HOP UP AND
LEAVE CAMPUS.
SO WE CANNOT TO THE ARCHIVES, WE
WENT TO ANOTHER ARCHIVE, AND WE
RECREATED WHAT WE COULD OF THE
ARCHIVE IN THE CLASSROOM.
WE REPLACE AID TEXTS BOOK UNIT
WITH LOW ARCHIVE MATERIALS  AND
WE FELT ADDRESSED THE SAME
THEMES, AND CHALLENGES OF THE
AMERICAN EXPERIENCE.
SO JUST A FEW THINGS YOU CAN SEE
IN THIS TIME PERIOD.
STUDENTS MERGING TECHNOLOGY AND
PRIMARY DOCUMENTS IN THE
CLASSROOM.
LOCAL WRITER, AND HISTORIAN JOHN
MULLER.
THIS IS THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES,
JUST DOWN THE ROAD, AND THE
FIRST STUDENT THAT GOT THEIR
RESEARCH ID, WE HAD GO INTO THE
FINDING AIDS TO WORK WITH THE
ACTIVIST.
SHE PUT IN HER POLE AND AS THE
STUDENTS FINISHED GETTING THEIR
RESEARCH CARDS, THEY CAME IN AND
TAUGHT ONE ANOTHER HOW TO DO
THIS IN A WAY, SOME OTHER FOLKS
MIGHT HAVE SAID YEAH, BUT THAT'S
SORT OF ABOVE THEIR PAY GRADE SO
TO SPEAK.
WHEN WE ARRIVED ON THE RESEARCH
SIDE, THEY SAID TUNE
GROUPS,
INCISE DISON THE OTHER SIDE.
[INDISCERNIBLE] ON THE OTHER
SIDE WANT SO THESE
.
THIS IS THE LEGENDARY REVEREND
O.J., GIVING A WALKING TOUR OF
THE ALLEY HE GREW UP IN.
THIS IS ONE OF THE TOPICS OUR
TUNES ARE RESEARCHING, AND AND
WE HAD THEM THINKING B HOW CAN
WE REPRESENT THIS INFORMATION
THAT YOU'RE FINDING, THE
INTERPRETATIONS THAT YOU'RE
MAKING IN DIFFERENT WAYS.  WE
HAD THEM EXPLORING HOW TO
EXPLORE DIFFERENT MAPPING TOOLS,
INCLUDING MAP
STORY AND THE
RESULT WAS, THEY GOT TO PRESENT,
THEY WERE AT THE PROHIBITTATION
OF THE OPEN DC CONFERENCE -- WE
SAW THROUGHOUT THAT SPREAD OF
TIME, THAT IF YOU GAVE THESE
STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY,
WHETHER IN THE CLASSROOM OR IN
THE ARCHIVES, THAT THEY WOULD BE
EXCITED, THAT THEY WERE CAPABLE
AND THEY WOULD CREDIBILITY TO
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
UNDERSTANDING OF OUR
PAST.
BUT WE KEPT RUNNING INTO
LIMITATIONS.
THOSE CONVENTIONAL
STRUCTURAL
LIMITATIONS.
MAY THEY BE A BELL SCHEDULE OR
JUST A CONSTRAIN A CLASSROOM.
PHYSICAL SPACE.
THEY THEY CAN BE SCHEDULING A
FIELD TRIP.
GETTING PERMISSION FORMS.
ALL OF
THESE.
THERE'S MANY, MANY MORE.
OKAY.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING ELSEWHERE,
WHERE THEY HAVE DONE AWAY WITH,
OR A
AMELIORATED SOME OF THESE
OCCURRENCE.
THIS IS A GRAPH OF A STEM LAB
THAT IS IN CAME
BRING,
MASSACHUSETTS CALLED NEW VIEW.
IT WAS STARTED BY AN M.I.T.
ARCHITECTURAL DESIGN PH.D.
TUNE.
AND THE GENERAL MOD CELL KIDS
ARE PULLED FROM THEIR
TRADITIONAL HIGH SCHOOL AND THEY
WORK HERE FULL TIME AS A
STUDENT.
THEY'RE ENGAGED IN SOME REALLY
GREAT
WORK.
WE WENT FROM THAT CONCEPT AND
SAID, HOW CAN WE START A PROGRAM
THAT IS WITHOUT THESE
LIMITATIONS
.
OUR FIRST PROJECT WAS UNCOVERING
THE 1968 WASHINGTON RIOTS  IN
WASHINGTON D.C. AND IT WAS AT
THE WASHINGTON D.C. PUBLIC
LIBRARY CENTRAL COLLECTIONS,
FUNDED BY
THEM.
HERE'S A PICTURE THAT IS IN THE
LAB OF THE HUMANITIES.
IT WASN'T ARTIFICIAL, LIKE THAT
STUDIO YOU SAW IN STEM IN NEW
VIEW WANT IT
WAS A COMMON
LOCATION.
THIS IS THE FORMER KIP LINGER
LIBRARY IN THE CARNEGIE BUILDING
JUST UP THE ROAD, SOON TO BE AN
APPLE STORE.
WE TOOK STUDENTS TO THOSE PLACE
WHERE IS OVERHEAD IS ALREADY
TAKEN CARE OF.
GALLERIES, LIBRARIES, ARCHIVES,
AND MUSEUMS, MOST OF WHICH ARE
FREE TO THE PUBLIC AND THEY'RE
WELCOMING US WITH OPEN ARMS.
PLEASE BRING
STUDENTS.
STUDENTS WEARING QUITE
GLOVES.
THIS IS OUR LITTLE HUB FOR THE
SUMMER.
60 HOUR PROGRAM TWO YEARS AGO
STUDENTS COLLABORATEOG
INDEPENDENT RESEARCH AND WORKING
TOGETHER ON A FORMAL PROJECT.
A PRODUCT, IF YOU WILL.
WE BROUGHT IN OUTSIDE EXPERTS,
HERE, LEANING OVER THE COMPUTER,
AND LEANING OVER THE STUDENT IS
A MAN NAMED BRIAN CRAFT.
HE'S INVOLVED CURRENTLY IN A 10
YEAR PROJECT, TO MAP DIGITALLY,
EVERY BUILDING IN WASHINGTON D.
C.
TO CALL HIM AN EXPERT IS AN
UNDER STATEMENT.
HE'S LEANING OVER A STUDENT,
WHO'S WORKING WITH SOME RTIS
MAPS
THIS IS A STUDENT BRIAN OR
LITTLE BRIAN WAS 14 AT THE
TIME.
ALSO, THE MINIMUM AGE THAT A
RESEARCHER CAN GET A CARD AT THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
AND BRIAN, WHY DON'T YOU COME ON
OUT.
BRIAN IS
CURRENTLY BRIAN IS
CURRENTLY A RISING JUNIOR AT
SCHOOL IN WASHINGTON D.C. BUT
HE'S ALSO ONE OF 15 STUDENTS IN
THE CITY WHO HAS JUST ACCEPTED
TO GEORGE WASHINGTON
UNIVERSITY'S EARLY COLLEGE
PROGRAM.
[APPLAUSE].
WE THOUGHT WE'D HAVE BRIAN, JUST
GIVE US HIS PERSPECTIVE.
WE'LL SHOW YOU SOME VISUALS AS
WE'VE BEEN DOING AND HE'LL MAYBE
TELL YOU IN A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL, WHAT HE'S WORKED ON.
OKAY.
SO THAT'S BRIAN CRAFT.
SO ON MY LEFT IS D.C.
GOVERNMENTAL REPORT.
ON THE RIGHT, AND THE DAMAGE.
SO CAN YOU SEE, IT'S JUST LIKE,
STREET IMAGES, LIKE ON THESE
BLOCKS, THE DAMAGE.
SO BASICALLY WHAT I'M TRYING TO
DO IS REPLICATE THAT IMAGE OR
THOSE IMAGES, AND SO, SORRY.
IF I'M RAMBLING.
BUT IN THIS BOOK, THERE'S THIS
WHOLE LIKE, A FOLD OUT PAGE OF
LIKE A HAND DRAWN DAMAGE MAP OF
THE ENTIRE 7TH  STREET AND 14TH
STREET OF THE RIOT.
SO I'M BASICALLY, TRYING TO DRAW
OUT EACH BUILDING, COLOR IT IN,
IF IT'S DAMAGED, HOW DAMAGED IT
IS.
IF IT'S SALVAGEABLE OR
UNSALVAGEABLE AND REPLICATE IT
DIGITALLY.
AT THIS STAGE, I WAS REALLY
IMMERSED IN MY WORK.
WHEN HE CAME, I WAS LIKE, I
DON'T REALLY NEED HIS HELP.
BUT YOU KNOW, I STILL, YOU KNOW,
WAS POLITE.
TOOK A SIP LIKE, YOU KNOW,.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT STILL, IT WAS A LIVE
EXPERIENCE AND THAT TILE TURNED
INTO AN INTERNSHIP OFFER AT HIS
INITIALING FIRM, GM T.
SO THAT WAS COOL.
I DIDN'T GET TO DO IT.
I DIDN'T GET SECURITY CLEARANCE
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO LET
A 14-YEAR-OLD TOUCH A MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR DOCUMENT.
BUT STILL, GOOD EXPERIENCE.
SO THIS IS A BEGINNING STAGE.SO
THIS IS FROM THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVE.
SO THIS IS OUR ONLY TIME TO
GATHER ORIGINAL DOCUMENTS MUCH
THAT'S ME, HOLING  THAT CAM
REMARKS AND ONE OF MY
APPEARANCE, JAMES.
SO WHAT WE DID FOR TWO HOURS
STRAIGHT.
I HELD THE CAMERA.  HE FLIPPED
THE PAGE.
I TOOK THE PICTURE.
FLIPPED IT.
I TOOK THE PICTURE, AND THAT WAS
30 MINUTES AND I TOOK A
BREAK SO
WE WERE DOING THAT FOR TWO HOURS
STRAIGHT.
ONE WE GOT ALL THAT
INFORMATION.
I SHARED THE PICTURE WITH MY
OTHER PARTNERS, AND WE HAD TO
PUT IT IN THIS SPREADSHEET.
IT'S 30 COLUMNS, HORIZONTALLY,
DIFFERENT INFORMATION LIKE
PERCENTAGE OF DAMAGE, HOW MUCH
THE DAMAGE COST THE OWNER OF THE
BUILDING, IF IT'S REPAIRABLE.
AND IT'S ABOUT LIKE 90 PEOPLE IN
THAT SPREADSHEET.
AND THEN I HAD TO IMPORT THAT
SPREADSHEET INTO THE MAPS.
THOSE ARE EACH OF THE 90 PEOPLE
THAT WE COLLECTED THE REPORTS O.
IF YOU WERE TO CLICK ON IT, YOU
SEE THEIR NAME, THEIR AGE, THE
BUILDING THEY OWNED, THE DRESS,
WHAT TYPE OF DAMAGE.
SO THERE'S THAT.
AND THE RED, YELLOW AND ORANGE
SPOTS, YOU CAN SEE HERE IS THE
EXTENT OF DAMAGE.
THAT WAS THE HAND DRAWN MAP I
WAS TALK GOING.
I HAD TO DRAW THE RECTANGLES,
THE SQUARES AND COLOR IT IN FOR,
I DON'T KNOW, ABOUT 11 STREET
WORTH FROM L TO
Q YOU CAN BARELY
SEE THOSE LITTLE PLUS MARKS.
THOSE ARE THE IMAGES OF EACH
BLOCK.
SO IF YOU WERE ABLE TO GET A
DIGITAL VISUAL AND IF YOU CLICK
ON THE INDIVIDUAL
DETAILS.I SAID, L YOU
JUST CONTINUE
WORKING  ON THE RIOTS.
YOU DON'T NEED ME.
WHAT WHAT AM I GOING TO DO FOR
YOU?
JUST WORK ON THE RIOTS.
JUST GO FINISH YOUR MAP.
NO, I WANT TO DO YOUR NEW
TOPIC.
DOWN TIME AND DEBAUCHERY.
WE LOOKED AT
BROTHELS, AND THE
GOAL OF THE THIS PROJECT WAS TO
TAKE IT TO THE NEXT
LEVEL.
HOW DO WE KNOW WHERE THE BAR
IS.
SO WE LOOKED AT EXISTING
PROJECTS, THIS IS FROM KEN
WINKEL IN UNIVERSITY OF
NEBRASKA.
AND ON THIS MAP, THERE'S A
MISSING LAYER, AND THE LAYER IS
BROTHELS DURING THE CIVIL WAR.
SO BRIAN MADE THE
LAYER.
AND IT BEGAN TO GET THE NATIONAL
ATTENTION, AND BRIAN WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST TO DO THE
DIGITALIZATION THAT EXIST IN
THEAR
CATALOG.
>> AS A TEACHER AT THE AMERICAN
SCHOOL OF [INDISCERNIBLE] I STAR
AID PROJECT IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE LOCAL 111 CEMETERY, AND THE
MEETING WITH THE SUPERVISOR
THERE, THEY SAID WE HAVE ALL
THESE SOLDIERS BURIED HERE, AND
FOR MOST OF THEM, WE DO NOT KNOW
GOING BEYOND WHAT'S ON THE GRAVE
STONE.
AS A TEACHER, THAT WAS THE
PERFECT PROBLEM STATEMENT TO
START W GETTING THE STUDENTS
ENGAGED.
SO I HAD MY 8TH GRADERS  IN
PARIS, PARTNER WITH PARTNERS  IN
WASHINGTON STATE TO RESEARCH.
HERE'S A STUDENT, STARTING WITH
LITTLE BIT OF DATA THAT SHE HAS
AND JUST A GLIMPSE INTO THIS
REMOTE COLLABORATION.
THESE STUDENTS, 9 HOURS APART,
WORKING AT THIS TIME, USING
CHECKEDS TO IN THEIR PERSPECTIVE
COUNTRIES, TO TRY AND
COLLABORATE.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE, THIS IS
RAYMOND BENNETT, HE DIED IN THE
FIRST DAY OF THE BATTLE OF
CHATEAU PARIS.
THIS WAS A MIX OF DOCUMENTS,
DIGITALIZE.
BUT ALSO, ARCHIVES AND MATERIALS
THAT WEREN'T DYNEL TIESED.
AND THESE STUDENTS LEARN HOW TO
ASK THEM IF THEY HAD ANY
RELEVANT DOCUMENTS  AND IF THEY
COULD DIGITIZE THEM AND E-MAIL
THEM TO PARIS AND THEY DID.
AND NOW, THEY HAVE AGGREGATED
THEIR WORK ON AN APP THAT CAN
YOU DOWNLOAD FOR FREE IN THE
APPLE STORE.
YOU CAN GO TO THE CEMETERY.
WHATEVER THEY HAVE FOUND ABOUT
THESE SOLDIERS IS PINNED TO THE
LOCATION OF THEIR BRAVE AND YOU
CAN STAND THERE AND LEARN ABOUT
SOMETHING WHO JUST FOUR MONTHS
AGO, WE KNEW NOTHING
ABOUT.
AND WE WERE JOINED  IN LESS THAN
THREE MONTHS BY AN INDEPENDENT
RESEARCH NOWHERE PENNSYLVANIA,
WHO OFFERED HER OWN RESEARCH
ABOUT
JEWISH SOLD SOLDIERS  IN
THAT STATE.
AND -- A FAMILY, FROM ILLINOIS,
WHOSE ANCESTOR IS BURIED  IN
CEMETERY.
SHE SHARED ALL HER DOCUMENTS AND
SHE LET US DIGITALIZE THEM FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
SHE KEPT THEM IN A CIGAR BOX.
AND PLAIDSON, THEIR STUDENTS
JUMPED  IN AND OFFERED MORE THAN
I COULD HANDLE AT THE TIME.
NOW YOU CAN GO, AS THESE
STUDENTS ARE DOING AND LEARN
ABOUT THE RESEARCH OF OTHERS,
STUFF THAT WAS NEVER AVAILABLE
BEFORE, ON A FREE APP AND WE'RE
HOPING  TO GET MORE AND MORE
INVOLVED ON THIS PROJECT AND
PROJECTS LIKE THIS.
IN COLLECTIONS ACROSS SPACE AND
GET STUDENTS ENGAGED IN
PROCESSES THAT DEVELOP REAL
SKILLS.
>> I'D LIKE TO RE-EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS WAS TOM A WORK WITH MIDDLE
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT.
MAYBE WE CAN TRICKLE
UP THIS IS
AN  EXCERT FROM AN ARTICLE
WRITTEN LAST YEAR.
AND BRIAN WAS THE INTERVIEW FOR
THE
ARTICLE.THE LINE THE LINE
AFTER, HIGH
PARADES INDEED WANT WE WANT TO
COME BACK
TO BRIAN, AND SIMPLY
ASK HIM SORT OF OFF THE CUFF.
HE'S ASKING FOR MORE TIME.
THE MIDDLE SCHOOLERS ASKED, IF
YOU HAD ONE THING, WHAT COULD
YOU DO.
L WE JUST NEED MORE TIME.
WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE DONE WITH
MORE TIME?
>> YEAH, THE MAP, THAT WAS 7TH
STREET.
BUT ANOTHER MAJOR STREET DURING
THE RIOTS WAS 14TH  STREET, AND
I WAS ABLE TO GET TO THAT.
IF I HAD MORE TIME, I WOULD HAVE
DONE 14TH  STREET AND PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE ANYONE BACK TO
ARCHIVES, TAKE MY PICTURES, GET
MORE INFORMATION TO HAVE MORE
INDIVIDUAL IN THE SPREADSHEET
AND IMPORT
THAT AND I THINK
ARCHIVE LEARNING IS JUST SO MUCH
MORE
VALUABLE.
NO OFFENSE, BUT MORE VALUABLE
THAN TEXT BOOK LEARNING.
YOU'RE EXPERIENCING  THAT
INFORMATION FIRSTHAND AND
PRIMARY SOURCES ARE USUALLY
SUPERIOR TO SECONDARY SOURCES
AND YOU CAN REACH YOUR OWN
CONCLUSIONS AND YOU RETAIN MORE
INFORMATION, BASE ON THE
INFORMATION THAT'S GIVEN TO
YOU.
I THINK ARCHIVAL LEARN SUGGEST
MUCH MORE
VIABLE.
>> WHAT IF STUDENTS LIKE BRIAN,
HAD AN ENTIRE
SEMESTER.
YOUR GUT REACTION IS YEAH, BUT
WHAT IF WE RETHINK THAT?
WHAT DO WHAT IF TUNES LIKE BRIAN
HAD AN ENTIRE
SEMESTER EACH OF
THE PROJECTS CAN BE SHOWN ALONG
THE WAY.
AND PATRICK AND I, SORT OF OUR
PROTOCOL, IS WE CALL EACH OTHER
OUT ON THAT.
WE'VE BEEN VERY ADAMANT ABOUT
SAY TOGETHER.
SO WE'RE ASKING YOU TO THINK
ABOUT THAT.
AND YOU CAN SHARE THAT
CONVERSATION THAT THE LOVELY
DEEP VOICE HAS BEEN SAYOG SOCIAL
MEDIA.
THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
[APPLAUSE].
THANK YOU MUCH.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO BREAK FOR
LUNCH.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO VISIT THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS CAFETERIA ON
THE 6TH FLOOR OF THE MADISON
BUILDING OR ANY OF OUR LOCAL
RESTAURANTS.
WE WILL BE STARTING BACK HERE AT
2:00 P.M. PROMPTLY.
AND POST COMMENTS OR WRITE TO
NDI@LOC.GOV TO KEEP THE
CONVERSATION GOING.
LURCH LUNCH PERSON
[LUNCH]
...
WELCOME BACK,
EVERYONE.
THANK YOU JOINING US.
WE ARE PLEASED  TO INTRODUCE OUR
SECOND KEYNOTE SPEAKER.
PAUL FORD, A JOURNALIST, AND
COFOUNDER OF POST LIGHT, A
DIGITAL POST PRODUCT STUDIO IN
NEW YORK.
HE IS AUTHOR OF "WHAT IS CODE"
PUBLISH FEDERAL 2015 IN
BLOOMBERG BUSINESS WEEK
CHAMPIONS RISE IN A SITUATION
BREAK THROUGH PIECE, THAT
REVEALS HOW COMPUTERS,
APPLICATIONS  AND SOFTWARE
WORKS.  HE WAS ALSO PART OF 7 ON
7 DIGITAL ART PROJECT.
TODAY, HE'S GOING TO SHOW US
UNSCROLL, AN APPROACH TO MAKING
NEW THINGS FROM OLD THINGS.
TAKE IT AWAY,
PAUL.
THIS IS A NICE CROWD FROM ME.
THIS FEELS LIKE HOME.
JUST GOOD DATA NERDS
EVERYWHERE.
LET'S SEE, I'M GOING TO START
WITH THE SHORT READING.
IT'S ABOUT TWO MINUTES LONG.
LATER, IT WILL BECOME CLEAR.
IT IS THE COCOON HISTORY FROM
NEW YORK CITY FROM A DISGRUNTLED
RACCOON, BASED ON NEW YORK TIMES
SEARCHES.
WE HAVE BEEN HERE LONGER -- I'M
A RACCOON.
WE HAVE BEEN HERE LONGER THAN
YOU HAVE.
WE DIPPED OUR PAW ON THE SPRING
ON SPRING STREET.
WE CLIMB OUR TREES IN THE FOREST
OF LOWER MANHATTAN.
WE LAUGHED  IN THE MOONLIGHT ...
AND YOU CAME AND YOU STAYED AND
YOU BUILT THE HOUSES.
FINE.
WE'RE SMALL.
WE WILL MAKE ROOM.
YOU MADE MUFFINS.
WE ATE THE CRUMBS.
EVERYONE WAS HAPPY.
BUT NOT FOR LONG.
WE WENT INTO EXILE UPSTATE.
FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS, WE KEPT
TO OURSELVES.
IN THE GARBAGE.
FOR BAKED BEANS.
OUR FUR WAS ALWAYS IN STYLE AND
IT WAS A HARD LIFE WANT WE LIVED
ON OUR LOVE AND OUR WITS THEN IN
THE 1970'S, THERE WAS A FUR
BOOM, AND I WAS SURE THAT WAS
THE END OF US.
BUT THANK GOD, FINALLY, WE WENT
OUT OF FASHION.
AND PEOPLE BEGAN TO REALIZE,
THAT WE, THE RACCOONS HAD A
RIGHT TO BE THERE.
THEY STOOD UP FOR US.
IN 1982, A WOMAN NAMED -- IN
1982, A MEETING WAS HELD IN
SCARSDALE.
RACCOONS ARE LOVABLE CREATURES.
DO WE WANT OUR CHILDREN TO WALK
BY THEIR CARCASSES?
NO, HEAT REATA, WE DON'T.
YOU SEE WHAT WAS HAPPENING?
WE WERE GETTING INTO YOUR HEARTS
A WORD ON RABIES.
I'M FIRST TO ADMIT, RABIES IS A
PROBLEM IN OUR COMMUNITY.
LET ME TELL YOU A STORY.
IT WAS 1998 IN WOOD STOCK, NEW
YORK.
LOTS OF PLACES SELL BAKED GOODS
THERE.  VERY OPEN MINDED.
WE THOUGHT WE COULD TRUST THE
HUMANS.
THIS ONE RACCOON HAD A GOOD
THING GOING WITH BARBARA.
IT WAS A BACKYARD THING, SHE
GAVE HIM TREATS  AND YOU KNOW
HOW THOSE GO.
IT WASN'T ENOUGH FOR BARBARA.
ONE DAY, SHE TRAPPED HIM AND
TOOK HIM TO THE LOCAL DAYCARE
WHERE SHE INTRODUCED THIS TINY
RACCOON TO ALL THE CHILDREN AND
THE RACCOON CUDDLED WITH
EVERYONE.
14 TODDLERS, 10 ADULTS.
BEAUTIFUL, RIGHT?
WELL, IT TURNED OUT ALL 24
HUMANS HAD BEEN EXPOSED TO
RAIN ES, WHO WAS BLAMED?
NOT BARBARA.
WHO WAS SHOT IN COLD BLOOD AND
BURIED BY BARBARA HE'S HUSBAND?
NOT BARB A. WHO HAD HAD IT IS
BODY DUG UP BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH?
NOT BARBARA.
AT THIS TIME LET ME ACTUAL, THE
NAME THEY GAVE THAT RACCOON.
ARE YOU READY?
THE NAME THE HUMANS GAVE THAT
RACCOON IN 1998 WAS SPARTACUS.
THE LEADER OF THE SLAVE REVOLT.
YOU CAN READ IT IN THE ARTICLE
OF THE PAPER OF RECORD WANT
WHO'S TO BLAME HERE?
THE RACCOON DOING IT'S BEST OR
THE SOCIETY THAT ONLY ACCEPTS
CUTENESS?
IN MIDTOWN, IT WAS ENOUGH TO
MAKE "THE NEW YORK TIMES," AND
LET ME ASK YOU, IF YOU DON'T
WANT RACCOON, WHY WOULD YOU
BUILD AN ORNAMENTAL GOLD POND ON
5 4TH STREET.
BY 2002, WE MADE IT TO THE BRONX
AND OVER THE LAST 15 YEARS, WE
FOUND OUR WAY BACK TO THE CITY.
TODAY YOU'LL FIND US EVERYONE.
AND THEY HAVE TAKEN OVER
BROOKLYN.PANDA'S OVERRATED.
THEIR
ECOLOGICAL NICHE IS
5 INCHES WALL F. YOU DON'T FEED
THEM BAMBOO, THEY FALL OVER AND
DIE.
AT FIRST WORD, TRASH.
LET ME ASK, IS IT SO LONG YOU
WANT WHAT WE THROW AWAY YOUR
BLUE SKY BAKERY MUFFIN CHUNKS?I
LIVE FROM YOUR ART IS UNTIL
LEADINGS.
WHY NOT TREASURE PANDA?
AND REMEMBER, YOU ARE THE GUESTS
OF THE RACCOONS.
SO THE REASON FOR THAT WILL
BECOME CLEAR
MOMENTARILY.AND THEN DO A VERY
BRIEF
SOFTWARE DEMO AND ISSUE SOME
RECOMMENDATION TO THE ASSEMBLED
AUDIENCE
IN 2006, 2005, I WAS A
WRITER, AND I WAS DOING OKAY.
AND I GOT A JOB AT HARPER'S
MAGAZINE IN CHARGE OF THEIR
WEBSITE.
I WAS A PROGRAMMER.
AND HARPER'S BEING CHEAP IS
LIKE, WELL, THIS WILL DUE AND
BROUGHT ME ON WANT A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO
WORK THERE, THE PUBLISHER TOOK
ME
ASIDE.
GIVEN LOTS OF TIME,
AND GIVEN SORT OF THE RESOURCES
AT HAND, I REALIZE THIS MAGAZINE
IS GOING BACK TO 1850, AND ALSO,
THERE WAS THIS SORT OF WHITE
ELEPHANT BIBLIOGRAPHY THEY
BUILT.
THEY BUILT IT DURING THE DAYS
WHEN THEY WERE GOING TO LIKE,
MAKE IT AND SELL IT TO TERMINAL
RESEARCH LIBRARIES SO PEOPLE
COULD WALK TO THE STACKS  AND GO
AND GET THE MAGAZINES OFF THE
STACKS GOING BACK TO THE
1850'S.
EVERYTHING WAS BEAUTIFUL.
AND WITH SUBJECT HEADS  AND ON
AND ON.
AND IT HAD GONE TERRIBLY OVER
SCHEDULE.
SO THEY START IN LIKE, '89 OR 90
AND NOW, IT WAS '95 AND
EVERYBODY WANTED PICTURES.
NOW, 10 YEARS LATER, I SHOW UP
AND THIS THING IS GREAT.
LET'S PUT PICTURES WITH IT.
GREAT.
WE'LL GIVE YOU 18 GRAND AND THAT
INCLUDES YOUR SCANNER.
SO I BOUGHT A FIJITSU 57, AND I
SCANNED THE HELL OUT OF THAT
ARCHIVE.
MAKING OF AMERICA HAD GONE FROM
1850 TO 1900 OUT OF CORNELL AND
OTHER PLACES.
I TRADED THEM A HARD DRIVE WITH
HARPERS UP TO 1923 AND GAVE THEM
SOME BIBLIOGRAPHY DATA IT WAS
JUST THIS INSANE HORSE TRADE
WITHING NO MONEY, IN WHICH I WAS
DOING ALL THE PROGRAMS OR
MOSTEST SCANNING I HAD A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT THAT WAS
TERRIBLE, ACTUALLY.
I SHOULD HAVE JUST DONE ALL OF
T. IN THE 70'S, THERE'S THESE
BAD CUTS FROM THE SPINE BECAUSE
HE WASN'T PAYING ATTENTION.
PUT TUP AND SUDDENLY, EVERYBODY
WAS REALLY NICE TO ME.
AND THEY HAD BEEN YELL ATHME
BEFORE.IT'S WORTH TO PAY IT
BECAUSE
ADVERTISING IS REALLY WHAT FUNDS
THE PUBLICATION WANT SO WHAT I
HAD DONE, ALL OF A SUDDEN, THESE
SUBSCRIPTIONS CAME IN.
PEOPLE LIKE ARCHIVES.
THEY DON'T LIKE THEM -- THEY
LIKE SUBSCRIBING BUT THE IDEA OF
GETTING BACK TO 1850 WAS VERY
MOTIVATING.
SO SUDDENLY, INSTEAD OF HAVING
TO SPEND 35 BUCKS YOU'RE GETTING
THESE DIGITAL SUBSCRIBERS WHO
WERE JUST SHOWING UP.  AND THEY
WERE REALLY NICE FOR A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AND REALLY HAPPY I WAS
THERE.
I WAS INN MAKINGN'T MAKING THE
MONEY, I WAS SAVING THE MONEY.
YOU NEED TO KEEP YOUR
CIRCULATION UP, IS BECAUSE
ADVERTISERS BUY BY NUMBER AND
IT'S AUDITED.
IF YOU HAVE A QUARTER MILLION,
HAVE YOU TO SPEND ALL MONEY IN
THE WORLD.
SO
THAT'S ONE BIG INTERACTION
BETWEEN ARCHIVES AND THE MEDIA.
ALSO, THAT WHOLE TIME, I WAS
ASHAMED BECAUSE I WOULD GO TO
THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS WEBSITE
THAT HAD STANDARDS FOR SCANNING,
AND IT WOULD BE ONLY 96 BIT
UNCOMPRESSED HISTORY,
UNACCEPTABLE EVER.
AND I HAD A COUPLE OF HARD
DRIVES  AND NO MONEY.
I JUST SORT OF MADE THE DECISION
THAT IF I CAN SEAT GRAIN OF THE
PAPER THAT WAS OKAY.
BUT NO ONE BACKED ME UP ON
THAT.
SO I BUILT THIS ARCHIVE THAT WAS
GOOD THAT, ENDED UP BEING RESOLD
TO LOTS OF UNIVERSITY
LIBRARIES.
THE WHOLE TIME I DID IT, I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THE RIGHT
ANGLED OF PAGES WAS, AND WHAT
THE TOLERANCES ARE TRULY ARE.THE
STANDARDS PUSH LIBRARY OFFED
ARE TRULY HIGH.
THEY'RE NOT INTENDED FOR
AMATEURS WITH NO BUDGETS.
THAT WAS THE REAL WORLD I WAS IN
TO GET THIS ASSET ON LINE.
ALSO, I SCORED A WHOLE COPY OF
ARCHIVE FROM BENNINGTON.
SOMEBODY DROVE DOWN FROM VERMONT
AND TOYOTA AND JUST GAVE ME ALL
OF HEARTBURN BECAUSE THEY WANTED
DIGITAL
ACCESS.ALSO, ONCE I GOT IT OUT
THERE.
PEOPLE IMMEDIATELY CAME IN AND
STARTED TO THREATEN LAWSUITS.THE
JOB OF AN EDITOR IS NOT TO
MAKE THINGS BEAUTIFUL, OR MAKE
THE PROS GREAT, IT'S TO AVOID
LITIGATION.
PUTTING THESE THINGS ON LINE,
MEANT THAT PEOPLE WHO HAD
FORGOTTEN THAT UNFORTUNATE
INCIDENT IN 1995, SUDDENLY WERE
BACK AND WERE ANGRY IT HAD
FOUNDED ITS WAY ON TO THE WEB
AGAIN.
MY MICROPHONE IS FALLING OFF.
WE'LL SEE HOW IT GOES.
AND THEN I ALSO WORKED FOR A
SMALL MEDIA CONSULTING FIRM THAT
GAVE ME LOTS OF ACCESS TO BIG
MEDIA COMPANIES.
I BUILT A VERSION OF GOURMET
MAGAZINE FOR THE IPAD WHICH
MANY THINGS ASIDE, IT WAS BASED
ON ARCHIVES  FROM
GOURMET, AND I
LEARNED, A THINGS THAT VERY
IMPORTANT THAT I'LL CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT WAS ASSET PANIC.
UNLESS YOU HAVE THE ASSETS  IN
YOUR HAND AND YOU CANNOT BELIEVE
HOW MANY PEOPLE TELL YOU, NO
WORRIES.
I'M GOING TO GO GET YOU A HARD
DRIVE AND LIKE, FOUR MONTHS GOES
BY.
ACTUALLY, THERE'S 12 LAWYERS
THAT GO BY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THE HELL IT
HAPPENED.
BOTH THINGS INCREASE RISK IN AN
ORGANIZATION.
AND API'S AND ARCHIVES ARE
TERRITORIES.
PEOPLE ARE FIERCELY DEFENDANT
AROUND THEM SO I LEARND  TO
NAVIGATE AND REVEAL TO THAT.
THAT'S ANOTHER REALITY IN THIS
WORLD.
SO THAT'S MY ADVICE.
ANYONE F YOU EVER END UP IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
JUST NEVER STOP PANICKING UNTIL
YOU HAVE FULL CONTROL OF ALL THE
ASSETS IN A DIGITAL FORM YOU CAN
MANIPULATE.
THEN IN MY INTRO, I WROTE THIS
THING A COUPLE YEARS AGO CALLED
WHAT IS CODE FOR BLOOMBERG
BUSINESS WEEK.
AND SAID HERE, TAKE THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF THE MAGAZINE.
I WROTE ABOUT CODE.
AND IT WAS TERRIFYING.
THEY WERE LITERALLY LIKE, WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE YOU THE WHOLE
ISSUE.
AND THEY JUST HID UNDER A
BLANKET, AND I MOONED.
I KNEW EVERYONE WAS GOING TO
YELL AT ME.
THERE'S NO WAY YOU DON'T DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND
PROGRAMMERS DON'T COME AND
SCREAM AT YOU.
WE TALK ABOUT THIS AND WE TALK
ABOUT ME, THE WRITER.
I DID IT.
A HUNDRED PEOPLE WORKED ON
THIS.
AT LEAST AND EVEN MORE Z I WANT
TO COME BACK TO THIS POINT.
BUT THERE WAS AUGITE HUB
REPOSITORY.
AFTER IT WAS PUBLISHED, PEOPLE
CONTINUED TO CORRECT T. SO
PROBABLY 200 PEOPLE HAD THEIR
HANDS ON THIS THING.
SOME OF THEIR WORK IS TRACKED
TRACKED AND SOME OF IT
ESTIMATE.
WHAT WE DO ULTIMATE CULT ARALLY,
OH, PAUL FORD WROTE THIS THING.
MY EGO IS CONSTANTLY GRATIFIED,
BY GRATIFIED BASED ON LIES.
BUT I LIVE WITH IT AND I DO
OKAY.
LASTLESS STAGE IN MY LIFE, I
DECIDED I WOULD PAY A -- WE'RE
BUILDING, JUST DIGITAL
PRODUCTS.
WE BUILD APPS  AND WEBSITES  IN
NEW YORK CITY, AND THIS IS T.
DONE WITH ARCHIVES FOR A WHILE.
DONE WITH A CULTURAL SECTION.GO
WORK FOR BANKS BUT THEY FIND
YOU.
YOU CAN'T GET AWAY.
I CAN'T EVEN TALK ABOUT HALF THE
WORK.
BUT A BIG NGOCAME.
I'M LIKE ON THE PHONE FOR AN
HOUR AND A HALF, TALKING ABOUT
NARA AND THAT AREA LOVES
CONFERENCE CALLS.
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU EVER
HAD THAT EXPERIENCE.
BUT.
SO A LOT OF CONFERENCE CALLS.
A LOT OF WHAT ASSET GOES HERE
AND ASSET GOES THERE.
NO MATTER WHAT YOU DO.
YOU DEAL WITH ARCHIVES.
WHAT I REALIZE IS THAT ALL OUR
SOFTWARE PROBLEMS ARE LEGACY
PROBLEMS, AND ARCHIVE SAY NICE
WAY TO SAY LEGACY.
THE CULTURAL SECTOR DEALING WITH
BIG ARCHIVE SYSTEM NOT THAT
DIFFERENT FROM GOING TO SOME
COMPANY AND THEY HAVE, 5 5
TERABYTES OF INFORMATION AND
USER RECORDS THAT THEY NEED TO
MAKE SENSE
OF.A COUPLE MORE THINGS TO KNOW
ABOUT ME.
I LOVE TIME LINES.
TIMELINES ARE GREAT.
BEAUTIFUL.
THAT ONE IS FROM THE "WASHINGTON
POST."
TIMELIPS ALWAYS SEEM LIKE A GOOD
IDEA.
I BUILT A BUNCH, AND THEY NEVER
ACTUALLY SOLVE A PROBLEM AND
THEY LOOK COOL.
SOMETIMES THEY KIND OF D. IT
HURT.
I WANT TO BELIEVE IN TIME LINE
SO BAD.
BUT I
CAN'T.
THIS IS KIND OF THE CONFESSION
PART.
I WANT TO SHARE THIS WITH YOU.
WHY WOULD A GUY WHO HAS WHO HAS
A SOFTWARE COMPANY, AS A WRITER,
GO AND BUILD SOFTWARE.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO WRITE
SOMETHING.
EXPERIMENTAL WEBSITES.
LEARN TWO COMPUTER LANGUAGES.
A LOT OF COFFEE
STUFF.
I WROTE SOFT BOARD.
I WROTE THAT BUSINESS WEEK
PIECE.
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE FROM THE
BOOK.
BUT I DID THAT INSTEAD.
A LOT OF MEDIUM POSTS,
COCOFOUNDED A COMPANY.
I ABANDONED THIS BOOK WRITING.
WHEN YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO WRITE A
BOOK.
YOU WRITE A CMS TO MANAGE THE
--.CMS, AND THEN WRITE THE
BOOK?
SO IT TURNS OUT, I REMAINED
BLOCKED.
AND I'M STILL BLOCKED.
I'M STILL KIND OF WORKING
THROUGH THAT.
THERE'S A THIRD THING THAT GOES
INTO THE SOFTWARE DEMO.
THE MEDIA IS HAVING A HARD
TIME.
NOBODY TRUST
ITS.
ONLY 20% OF THE TRUST IT A LOT.
AND I MEAN, YOU SAW RACHEL HERE
EARLIER.
SHE'S GETTING A LOT OF
STATISTICS ALL LINE UP AND
WORKING WITH JOURNALISTS TO, TRY
AND GET THINGS AS FACTUAL AS
POSSIBLE FOR THE NEW YORK TIMES.
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THAT
FIELD ARE VERY DISCIPLINED AND
SERIOUS AND IT SUCKS THAT THE
WORLD DOESN'T TRUST THEM.
IT'S SAD AND IT'S TOUGH AND BAD
MARKETING, AND IT'S BAD POLITICS
AND IT'S A SITUATION.
AND ALSO, SORRY TO GO BACK TO
THE TIMES, BUT EDITORS  AND
COPYRIGHTERS AND FACT CHECKERS
ARE GETTING LAID OFF
EVERYWHERE.
THERE'S JUST LESS AND LESS MONEY
FOR THEM.
LESS AND LESS MONEY FOR CONTENT
PRODUCTION.
AND SO THEY'RE GOING.
AND THEN THERE'S A HUGE
DISCUSSION AROUND FAKE NEWS AND
I'M NOT GOING TO RECAPITULATE.
YOU'RE ALL LIVING IT.
BUT THERE'S A SENSE OF NEWS
BEING ARBITRARY AND JOURNALISM
BEING
ARBITRARY.
WRITERS IN MY OPINION ARE
LEARNING LESS AND LESS GOOD
PRACTICE BECAUSE THEY HAVE FEWER
AND FEWER PEOPLE TO KEEP AN EYE
ON THEM.
SO MY SOLUTION TO THIS WAS TO
BUILD A TIME
LINE
AND YOU CAN
CLICK ON THE DATE AND ZOOM OUT
AND SEE DIFFERENT CONTEXT, AND
THIS IS ALL POWERED BY AN API.
NICE JOB ON THE FRONT END.
I KNEW I WAS DOING THIS, THAT
TIME LINES AREN'T THE ANSWER BUT
I COULDN'T HELP MYSELF.  THESE
ARE EVENTS  FROM WIKIPEDIA,
EVENTS FROM ALL OVER AND ALL
KINDS OF DIFFERENT SOURCES.
AND SO I'VE GONE OUT TO THE
1800'S, AND THEN, UNDERNEATH ALL
THAT, WHAT YOU CAN DO IS JUST
SORT OF BOOK MARK THE EVENTS.
THEY GO INTO THIS PILE OF STUFF
ON THE RIGHT AND THEN YOU ADD
NOTES TO THE BOOK MARKS AND THAT
TURNS INTO AN ESSAY.
SO WHAT'S NICE ABOUT THAT IS
YOU'RE KEEPING YOUR SOURCES
CONNECTED AND CAN YOU REA RANGE
THESE LITTLE BLOCKS OF TEXT.
LOOK LIKE IT MIGHT BE EASY.
IT'S KIND OF A GREAT WAY TO
WATCH F YOU ARE LIKE ME AND
YOU'RE GETTING OLDER AND YOU
DON'T TRUST YOUR MEMORY AS MUCH
AND YOU CAN'T COUNT ON FACT
CHECKERS IN THE WAY IT USED
TO
WE BUILT CMS'S IN MY COUNTRY.
I BUILT MORE THAN I WOULD LIKE
TO ADMIT IN MY LIFE.
YOU GIVE PEOPLE A TEXT BOX AND
THEN YOU MOVE O. I FEEL THE TEXT
BOXES NEED TO DO MORE
WORK.
MADE A TIME LINE, LOOKED AROUND,
READ SOME RACCOON ARTICLES AND
THEN STARTED TO WRITE
FACTUALLY-BASED, FUNNY RACCOON
PROSE.
THAT PIECE EXISTS.
I BUILT MY SYSTEM AND WANTED TO
TEST IT OUT.
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT.
THERE'S SOME CONTINUITY THERE.
HERE'S WHAT I HAVE REALLY
LEARNED FROM BUILDING THAT AND
DOING THAT.
I WANT TO GET TO A TERBYTE OF
META DATA PROBABLY 50, 100
MEGABYTES.
MAYBE A LITTLE MORE IF YOU COUNT
IMAGES.
AND I WANT TO GET AS MUCH
CULTURAL INFORMATION IN EVENTS
AS I POSSIBLY K OVER THE NEXT
YEAR OR SO.
IT'S A PERSONALIZED SIZE
PROJECT.
I'M USING IT TO WRITE.
IT HAS REALLY UNBLOCKED ME ON
THE BOOK.
BECAUSE IT TURNS OUT THAT
THERE'S A GREAT QUOTE THAT SAID,
WRITER'S BLOCK IS RELATED TO THE
WRITER'S SENSE OF THEIR UNGRADE
LENS.
IT KEEPS YOU FROM FEELING LIKE A
FRAUD YOU'RE LIKE.
ALL RIGHT.
I WROTE AN EVENT, AND A NOTE AND
ANOTHER NOTE.  AND YOU'RE
WRITING KNOW ESSAY, AND THAT IS
WEYMOUTH TO TAKE WATT BLOCK WHEN
YOU HAVE A PILE OF BOOKS  ON ONE
SIDE, AND A BLANK SCREEN ON THE
OTHER.
THIS IS WHAT THE WORLD LOOKS
LIKE A LITTLE BIT AROUND
CULTURAL ARCHIVES THAT ARE
OPEN.
I WON'T EVEN EBBING PLAIN THIS
CHART BECAUSE YOU ALL LIVE IT --
I WON'T EVEN EXPLAIN THIS CHART,
BECAUSE YOU ALL LIVE IT.
I LOVE UTFA DATA I DON'T LOVE
WEB SERVICES BUT I'M MIX BOD
METS.
BUT LIKE, THIS IS HOW STUFF
COMES OUT.
THIS IS WHAT YOU GET TODAY.
AND IT'S REALLY HARD DOOR.
ALL OF IT, AND I'VE WORKED  WITH
TALL.
AND I'M GOOD WITH WORKING WITH
AWFUL T. I'M LIKE 20 YEARS IN.
I PHOTOCOPIED THE SGI
ISOSTANDARD AFTER GET TOGETHER
THROUGH INTERLIBRARY, ALL 900
PAGES, BECAUSE I SAW IT AS
WONDERFUL, SECRET LORE WHEN I
WAS 20 YEARS OLD.
TADOESN'T LEAVE THE ROOM.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I MEAN, I LOVE THIS STUFF.
BUT IT'S ALSO JUST KIND OF
INCREASINGLY HARD.
IT'S INTRACT BELIEFABLE TO WORK
WITH WHEN YOU'RE REALLY TRYING
TO EXPLORE AND UNDERSTAND A DATA
SET OR IMPORTANT IT IN BULK INTO
ANOTHER
VIEW ACTUALLY, KIND OF
HARD BECAUSE IT'S ZILLIONS OF
FILES.
YOU HAVE TO IMPORT IT
SOMEWHERE.
AND SEARCH THROUGH IT.
HARD TO WORK W. DOESN'T DIRECTLY
LINK TO IMAGES.
IT
HAS AN INTERSTITIAL
I.D.
THEN
AM I SPIDERRING EVERY WEB PAGE
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE IMAGE S.
ALL OF THAT COMES UP BECAUSE THE
CSE DOESN'T INCLUDE MASTER
BELLATOR MMAS.
THIS IS ME, BY THE WAY,
CRITICIZING THE COMMENTS.
SAYING THANKS  FOR ALL THE
INCREDIBLE THINGS YOU'VE GIVEN
TO ME FOR FREE.
LET ME TELL YOU WHY I HATE IT.
THIS APIIS AGAIN, WONDERFUL AND
TERRIBLE.
THIS THING IS HORRIBLE.
THIS, WHEN YOU GET INTO THE XML
ON THIS BAD BOY, IT IS AN
ENDLESS BAD BOY OF
PAIN.25MILLION MARK
RECORDS.
THANKS AND
THANKS I GOT PIE
MARK.
STARTED FOOLING AROUND, BUT
THEY'RE HARD TO WORK WITH.
THEY WERE FROM A SPECIFIC
WORLD.
I'M GOING TO SPIDER THE WHOLE
DAMN THING, AND KNOW EVERYTHING
THAT'S IN THERE.
AND THERE'S NO SIMPLE WAY TO DO
THAT, ASIDE FROM WRITATION WEB
SPIEDER AND SORT OF MAP TOGETHER
TO MY SCHEMA.
I THINK THERE'S THIS ARCHIVE
GOING ON WITH ACCESS, WITH HOW
THEY'RE ACTUALLY WORKING  AND I
THINK WE HAVE CUT THINGS UP.
RIGHT NOW, I THINK THE CONSENSUS
IS A GREAT API.
BUT I'M GOING TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING, OUR DATABASES.
THIS IS THE LANGUAGE OF THE
UNIVERSE.
THIS IS HOW PEOPLE STORE AND
RETRIEVE AND THIS LITTLE GUY,
SQL LIGHT IS ENTIRELY PUBLIC
DOMAIN, IT'S ON ALL OF YOUR
PHONES.  IT'S ON ANDROID, ON
IOS.
IT'S BUILT IN EVERYWHERE.
IT AM CONSIST AS PART OF
PYTHON.
IT IS 150K SQL DATABASE THAT
RUNS THE WORLD, AND IT'S SO
POWERFUL AND UNASSUMING THAT
NOBODY REALLY TALKS ABOUT
IT BUT
IF YOU COULD START PULLING YOUR
LIFE INTO SQL DATABASES, I COULD
DOWNLOAD THEM AND SEARCH IT AND
EXPLORE IT WITHOUT HAVING TO PUT
IT ANYWHERE, WITHIN LIKE, FIVE
SECONDS.
I CAN START HACKING  AND MESSING
WITH PUBLIC CORP RAIN THE TIME
IT TOOK TO DOWNLOAD.  ONCE YOU
GET IN AND YOU TYPE SQL LIGHT
DATABASE.
YOU'RE GOOD TO GO.
CAN YOU TURN ON FULL TEXT
SEARCH.
PUBLIC DOMAIN.
IT'S ALL UTF16 BY DEFAULT.
IT ACTUALLY HITS ALL THE SWEET
SPOTS THAT WE TALK ABOUT.
IT DOESN'T TALK ABOUT THEM IN
THE WAY THAT WE USUALLY TALK
ABOUT THEM.
ALSO F YOU CAN MAKE THEM
TURNABLE, THAT WOULD BE GREAT.I
KNOW THAT MAY BE HARD FOR A
LARGE, CULTURAL ORGANIZATION.YOU
CAN TAKE YOUR SQ SPADES
LIGHT FILE AND I'M NOT I SAG GET
RID OF YOUR API.
I'M JUST SAYING, DOING THIS
OTHER THING, TOO OR SUGGEST
SOMEONE TO GO AND DO IT FOR
YOU.
IF YOU POINT TO THE THING, AND
SAY, HEY, WE DIDN'T DO THIS.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO TORRENT
EVERYTHING AS A SQL LIGHT
DATABASE.
GO IT'S OVER HERE.
A LITTLE BIT INSTITUTIONAL AND
PREMATURE TO SAY, THAT IS AT
LEAST SEMI OFFICIAL, A REALLY,
REALLY POWERFUL SIGNAL.
LIKE WIKIPEDIA, THERE'S
8 MILLION EXTRACTING DATA FROM
WINSTAR WORLD CASINO PEED
PEAKEDDIA PROJECTS.
NONE OFEM THEM ARE PARTICULARLY
BLESSED.
IF I CAN CLICK, DOWNLOAD THE
TORENT, I WON'T START MESSING
WITH AND INCORPORATING YOUR
CORPORATE INTO MY HISTORICAL
WRITING TOOL WITHIN HOURS  AND I
WILL MAKE SURE THAT EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THOSE BOXES, HAS A CLEAR
LINK BACK TO A CREDITTATION BACK
TO YOUR ORGANIZATION.
I ABSOLUTELY WANT TO DO THAT IF
YOU GIVE ME AN API OR CSV,
YOU'VE ADD SOMETIMES MONS OF
WORK THAT THAT PROCESS.
SUPPLEMENT.
I'M NOT ASKING PEOPLE TO REPLACE
WHAT THEY ARE WITH THIS FORMAT.
BUT SOME SORT OF COMMON FORMAT I
CAN IMMEDIATELY START TO
MANIPULATE WOULD BE FANTASTIC.
EVEN PUT IT INTO SQL LIGHT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO THROW WATT
PAST.
I KNOW THAT'S REALLY HARD TO DO
CULTURALLY TO THROW AWAY OLD
RECORDS.
JUST LEAVE THEM THERE.
ASSUME STORAGE IS FREE.
I HAVE A 10 TERABYTE DRIVE.
I SPENT LIKE A THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON A REALLY, REALLY POWERFUL
MACHINE AND I HAVE VERY FAST
INTERNET AND THAT'S JUST ME AT
HOME IN
BROOKLYN.
REQUEST GOING YOU CAN DO TO BE
VISUAL WITH YOUR CORPORA IT'S
EASIER FOR ME TO HACK WITH
EXPLORER AND PUT THEM INTO OTHER
CONTEXT.
IT'S SUCH A POWERFUL
SIGNAL.GOOD JOB.
I KNOW IT CAN CULTURALLY BE HARD
TO PUT THINGS WITH YOUR
DATA
GOING BACK TO WHERE WE WERE, I
THINK THERE ARE TWO MAIN
FALLACIES FOR THE ARCHIVES.
PUBLISHERS BELIEVE THERE IS FREE
CONTENT, AND YOU CAN USE THEM
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND FIND
VALUE IN THE PAST THAT CAN BE
EASILY
EXPOSED.
AN UNBELIEVABLE AMOUNT OF LABOR
TO GET VALUE AND MINING AND NEWS
OUT OF OUR ARCHIVES.
I TRY TO CORRECT THE PUBLISHERS
ON THIS.
WE'RE GOING TO BUILD AN ARCHIVE
OF OUR WONDERFUL PUBLICATION.LET
ME TELL YOU WHAT THAT WILL
TAKE.  AND 10 MINUTES LATER.
THEY ASK ME TO LEAVE THE ROOM.
THE NEWS IS AN ARCHIVE WAITING
TO HAPPEN.
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF THINGS THAT
ARE GOING ON AROUND HOW MEDIA IS
PRODUCED
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING.
AND NOW, I'M PROCRASTINATEOG
THAT, TOO.
BUT I AM USING THE TOOL.
I'M GOING TO TRY TO OPEN IT
REALLY SOON.
I'M JUST A LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT
API SECURITY.
PRETTY SOON, I'LL HAVE PROBABLY
A COUPLE MILLION EVENTS ON
THIS.
SO I THINK THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THINGS LIKE
THIS.
THIS IS JUST A HYPOTHESIS.
THIS IS NOT A [INDISCERNIBLE] ON
THIS PRODUCT.
THIS IS SOMETHING I REALLY
WANTED TO SEE IN THE WORLD AND I
WANTED TO RESOLVE MY OWN
ANXIETIES ABOUT FACTS  AND SORT
OF WHAT ARCHIVES CAN
DO
I CAN
USE THE HELP IN
EASILY
IMPORTABLE
DATA
SO THAT'S THAT.
IPHONE, IPADD  TO SHOW YOU
THAT.
AND THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH.
NEXT, WE HAVE NICK ADAMS, A
SOCIOLOGIST AND RESEARCH FELLOW
AT THE BERKELEY INSTITUTE FOR
DATA SCIENCE.
HE'S GOING TO TALK ABOUT HOW
SOCIAL SCIENTISTS USE THE
CONGRESSIONAL RECORD AS A DATA
SOURCE.
WELCOME,
NICK.
HELLO.
HELL O. LET ME PULL UP MY SLIDE
HERE.
THIS IS SOMEONE ELSE'S LAP TOP
AND IT'S HIDDEN HERE.
IT'S ON THE
BOOM.
I'M GOING TO WALK ON STAGE, I'M
GOING TO WALK BACK ON STAGE.
HELLO.
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
ARCHIVISTS.
LIBRARIANS, JOURNALISTS, DATA
NERDS.
FELLOW SOCIAL SCIENTISTS AND
DIGITAL HUMANS, I'M VERY HONORED
TO BE HERE TODAY.
THIS IS REALLY EXCITING FOR ME,
KIND OF A MECCA FOR SOMEONE LIKE
ME.
I'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK WITH A
LOT OF TEXTUAL DATA AND TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK HERE IS TRULY AN
HONOR.
FOR MANY OF US, ARCHIVES EVOKE
IMAGES OF OLD LEATHER BOND
BOOKS, SWEET ODORS OF OXIDIZING
PULL M AND THEY AROUSE THE
EXCITEMENT OF DISCOVERING SOME
LONG LOST HISTORY AS IF IT WERE
A BURIED TREASURE.
MY PARTICULAR EXCITEMENT OF
ARCHIVE SYSTEM A BIT DIFFERENT.
LIKE ALL MY FELLOW SCHOLARS, I
SWOON AT THE THOUGHT OF
UNCOVERING OLD WORLDS, AND
NEWSPAPERS, POLICY TRACKS,
MEETING MINUTES, CONTRACTS OR
EVEN RECEIPTS.
THESE ARE THE SORT OF DOCUMENT
THAT IS MOST PEOPLE THROW AWAY
WITH THE RECYCLING.  WE REALLY
CHERISH THESE DATA AT UNSPOILED
RECORDS OF HUMAN BEHAVIOR.
THEY TELL THE STORIES OF WHO WE
WERE ECONOMICALLY, POLITICALLY,
SOCIALLY AND CULTURALLY.
I WANT TO FIRST SAY THANK YOU TO
ALL THE LIBRARIANS AND
ARCHIVISTS WHEN, MAKE THIS DATA
AVAILABLE.
WHICH REALLY ALLOWSES  TO DO OUR
WORK.
WE COMPLETELY DEPEND OURAR
TEARIO.
SO IN A WAY THAT I CAN'T BECAUSE
I ONLY HAVE TWO HANDS, CAN YOU
HELP ME GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
TO THE PEOPLE THAT HELP MAKE
THIS HAPPEN.
[APPLAUSE].
A LITTLE LOUDER.
OH.
NO.
OKAY.
MAYBE I SHOULD END
THERE.
MY LOVE FOR ARCHIVE SYSTEM A BIT
DIFFICULT.
ARCHIVES CAN BE POWERFUL THAN
MOST OF MY SCHOLARS HAVE MET
IMAGINED AND I WANT TO SHOW YOU
TO THE EXTENT I CAN WANT WE CAN
BRING ABOUT A FUTURE WHERE
ARCHIVES ARE USED MUCH MORE
OFTEN, AND RESPONSIVELY, TO GIVE
US A MUCH DEEPER UNDERSTANDING
OF HUMAN BEHAVIOR.
RIGHT NOW, SOCIAL SCIENTISTS
AND DIGITAL -- ARE AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE IDEA OF A
DECADE-LONG PROCESS, WE'RE
LEARNING  TO READ, RIGHT
ALONGSIDE COMPUTERS.
WE'RE BEGINNING TO UNDERSTAND
AND TRUST HOW THEY CAN READ
DIFFERENTLY AND MUCH FASTER THAN
WE CAN AND FIND PATTERNS AND
METS THAT WE REALLY COULDN'T
FIND WITHOUT MONTHS OF CLOSE
READING.
SO THERE'S A BURN OF NEW
COMPUTATIONAL TEXT ANALYSIS
APPROACHES THAT PEOPLE USE.
WE CAN PARSE SENTENCES BY
GRAMMAR.
WE CAN FIND NAMED ENTITIES.
WE CAN MODEL TOPICS WHAT PEOPLE
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
WE CAN MODEL NETWORKS OF
INDIVIDUALS AND HOW THEY
RELATE.
AND WE CAN EVEN DO REALLY
SEEMINGLY CLASSICAL,
ETHNOGRAPHICS RESEARCH, LIKE
GROUNDED THEORY, WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF COMPUTERS.
THERE'S SO MUCH WE CAN DO RIGHT
NOW.
BUT THESE POWERFUL
TOURS -- MOST
OF US HERE ARE FAMILIAR WITH
TRADITIONAL PRACTICES OF
ARCHIVING, THE PRESERVATION,
ORGANIZATION, MAINTENANCE AND
THE CAREFUL CONTROL AND
PROTECTION OF DOCUMENTS AND FROM
THE RESEARCHER'S STANDPOINT,
WHEN WE WANT TO PULL AN ARCHIVE,
WE CAN PULL A LIBRARIAN AND LOOK
AT THE DOCUMENTS, USUALLY, ONE
DOCUMENT AT A TIME.
OFTEN WEARING GLOVES OR VIEWING
THROUGH SOME PANE OF GLASS.
AND THESE ARCHIVES ARE REALLY
HELPFUL.
THEY ALLOW US TO ASK SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS OF SPECIFIC COUNSELS,
QUESTIONS LIKE, WHAT HAPPENED
WHEN?
DID HE OR SHE REALLY SAY OR DO
THAT?
WHO PAID WHOM?
AND WHO VOTED WHICH WAY ON WHICH
BILL BUT THESE QUESTIONS ARE A
FORENSIC STYLE OF RESEARCH WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A PARTICULAR
DATE ON A PARTICULAR DOCUMENT.
NOW, WE HAVE ENTERED THIS AGE OF
DIGITALIZATION.  NO ARCHIVIST OR
LIBRARIAN WOULD WANT ME TO THUMB
THROUGH THEIR MOST AGED AND
CHERISHED RECORD.
APPLYING AN ARRAY OF HIGHLIGHT
COLORS DIRECTLY TO THE
COLLECTIONS.
I CAN HEAR SOME OF YOU, WINCING
AT THE THOUGHT.
THAT SORT OF THING CAN EASILY BE
DONE WITH DIGITAL RECORDS.
HOW IS THAT GOING TO CHANGE
RESEARCH, AND HOW ARE WE GOING
TO ADAPT TO
THAT
THERE ARE
DIGITAL ARCHIVING PRODUCTS.
CHRONICLING AMERICA IS ALLOWING
RICHERS  TO SKIM THROUGH
THOUSANDS OF NEWSPAPERS, USING
DIGITAL APPROACHES.  IN THIS
TALK SERIES, MATTHEW WEBERS,
WE'RE CAVES UNUNLEASHED PROGRAM
WAS DISCUSSED.
IT'S GENERATING VALUABLE
FINDINGS.
HACKING AWAY AT WELL-CURATED
ARCHIVES.
THESE ARE NOT REALLY THE NORM.
WHAT'S NORMAL IS QUITE A BIT
DINNER.
AS ELIZABETH LURANG MENTIONED,
ONE OF THE MOST PROMINENT
CHALLENGE CHALLENGES, IN THEIR
USE OF DIGITAL COLLECTIONS WAS
THE INABILITY TO SEARCH
COLLECTIVELY THROUGH THE
MATERIALS.
EXAMPLE.
THE GOVERNMENT PUBLISHING
OFFICE, THE GTOWEBSITE HAS A LOT
OF REALLY IMPRESSIVE HOLDINGS,
DESCRIBING THE ACTIVITIES OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.  THE CONGRESSIONAL
RECORD HEARINGS AND THESE DATA
ARE ESSENTIAL TO DEMOCRACY, AND
TO THE GPO'S MISSION OF KEEPING
AMERICA INFORMED.
THEY'RE TOTALLY AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC, WHICH IS GREAT AND
THEY'RE EVEN DIGITIZED  IN AN
IDEAL, KIND OF MACHINE READABLE
FORMAT.
LET ME GIVE YOU A SENSE WHATEVER
THAT LOOKS LIKE WANT HERE'S A
GGPOWEBSITE.
IF I WANTED TO UNDERSTAND HOW MY
CONGRESS PERSON IS DEALING WITH
SCIENCE, I CAN GO TO A
PARTICULAR CONGRESS.
I CAN GO TO THE HOUSE HEARINGS I
CAN LOOK FOR THE COMMITTEE ON
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY AND THEN
I CAN READ THE TEXT OF EVERY
LAST COMMITTEE HEARINGS, AND TRY
TO FOLLOW ALONG WITH WHAT MY
CONGRESS PERSON WAS DOING.
SO WE SELECT A FILE.
WE READ AN INTERVIEWER.
IN THIS CASE, A WEB BROWSER WANT
WE VIEW IT WITHOUT TOUCH
TOGETHER, WITHOUT SCRIBBLING
TO.
AND WE HAVE TO TAKE OUR NOTES
FROM A SEPARATE DOCUMENT.
SO IF A LOT WAYS, EVEN THOUGH
THIS TEXT IS FULLY DIGITAL,
WE'RE STILL WEARING THE GLOVES,
AND LOOKING AT A DOCUMENT FROM
BEHIND A PANEOF GLASS.
NOW, TO BE CLEAR, I DON'T
BELIEVE THIS IS A STATE OF
AFFAIRS BECAUSE ACTIVISTS ARE
SOMEHOW, YOU KNOW, OVER
PROTECTIVE OR UNINTERESTED OR
HONOREE.
MAYBE SOME OF YOU ARE.
THIS IS A VERY WELL ORGANIZED
SET OF LINK THAT IS MAKES
PERFECT SENSE FOR HUMAN LOOKING
FOR INFORMATION ABOUT A
PARTICULAR HEARING.
AND WE ORGANIZE OUR DIGITAL
RECORD THIS IS CHAMPIONS RISE IN
A SITUATION THE SAME WAY WE
WOULD ORGANIZE OUR PHYSICAL
RECORDS BECAUSE THESE SYSTEMS
ARE SO SENSIBLE FOR TRADITIONAL
RESEARCH AND SO EXPEDIENT FOR
ARCHIVISTS' FUNDAMENTAL TASK FOR
PRESERVATION IF WE DON'T WANT TO
CLICK AND CLICK AND CLICK AND
DOWNLOAD EACH FILE.
WHAT DO SOCIAL SCIENTISTS
WANT?WE WANT DATA THAT ARE WELL
STRUCTURED.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT.
AND I'LL HAVE A SLIDE IN A
MOMENT THAT KIND OF LAYS THAT
OUT.
LET ME OFFER YOU A SENSE, JUST
THROUGH SOME EXAMPLES.
PERHAPS WE WANT TO SEE ALL THE
MATERIALS IN THE CONGRESSIONAL
RECORD OR IT COULD BE FOR ANY
ARCHIVE.
WE WANT TO SEE THE MATERIALS,
OCTODE BY MEN OR WOMEN,
AUTHORED
BY MEN OR -- DATE OF THE
UTTERANCE.
WHO SAID IT WANT WHAT DISTRICT?
EVEN ADJECTIVES THAT ARE
MARSHALLED TO DESCRIBE
PARTICULAR NOUNS LIKE VETERAN,
TEACHER, DOCTOR OR CHILD.
PERHAPS I WANT TO ASSESS THE
COMFORT OF CONGRESS MEMBERS WITH
THE SCIENTIFIC PROCESS.
SO I WANT TO DO SOME SORT OF
SEARCH AND THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
OF PSEUDOCODE HERE.
I WANT TO SEE IF I CAN FIND ALL
INSTANCES WHERE PEOPLE SAY THE
WORD HYPOTHESIS OR FALSIFY,
CORRELATION, CAUSATION,
STATISTICAL SIGNIFICANCE.
IF I FIND THAT, I WANT TO SEE
THE SPEECH DISPLAYED, ALONG WITH
THE IDEA OF THE SPEECHER, THE
IDENTIFICATION OF THE SPEAKER,
THE
PARTIES THEY'RE ASSOCIATED
WITH, ET CETERA.
THAT WOULD BE REALLY NICE AND
I'D BE ABLE TO COMPARE HOW
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
SCIENCE.
BUT THAT'S NOT REALLY WHAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S JUST NOT POSSIBLE ON THE
GOVERNMENT PUBLISHING OFFICE ^,
AND THE SORTS OF AGAINST DIG
INTO THE NETTA DATA AND THE
CONTEXT OF IT ITSELF, SO WE
CAN'T CHECK ALL THE TEXTS OF ALL
THE SCIENCE HEARINGS.
WE CAN'T IDENTIFY PARTICULAR
SPEAKERS AND ETCH SPUES.
AS A READER, AS I READ THROUGH
THAT DOCUMENT, I KNOW WHEN
MEMBER JONES IS SPEAKING  AND
WHEN MEMBER SMITH SIMPLE
SPEAKING.
AND I CAN'T KNOW THE
IDENTIFICATION OF THE PARTY OF
THE CONVERSATION.
EVEN THOUGH THIS IS REALLY
COMMON KNOWLEDGE, THIS STUFF IS
NOT ACTUALLY CONNECT TO THE DATA
RIGHT THERE AS A RESEARCHER WHEN
I WANT TO QUERY
IT.IT'S JUST TOO HARD TO LOOK
THROUGH ALL THAT DATA.
ONE DOCUMENT AS AT A TIME.
OR TO LEADERSHIP ALL THE SKILLS,
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BRING IT
TOGETHER.
SO YOU CAN SEARCH AT THIS TIME
WAY YOU WANT TO SEARCH T. BUT
I'M HERE
TODAY.I FEW YEARS AGO, I FOUND
THE
COMPUTATIONAL ANALYSIS WORKING
GROUP AT UC BERKELEY AND A KEY
POINT WAS TO SCOTT KNOT JUST
TEACH RESEARCHERS HOW TO FISH,
BUT TO TEACH A RESEARCH TEAM HOW
TO WHALE NO MARINE MAMMALS OF
COURSE HARMED.
BUT TO TEACH A RESEARCH TEAM,
HOW TO DO THE WORK NECESSARY TO
ACQUIRE, CLEAN, PROCESS,
ANALYZE, INTERPRET AND REPORT ON
MASSIVE TEXTUAL ARCHIVES.
NOW, WE'RE PARTNERING WITH THE
SOCIAL SCIENCE RESEARCH COUNCIL,
SO WE CAN NOT ONLY CONVERT INTO
A QUERY ANNUAL RECORD OF WHAT
CONGRESS IS UP TO.
BUT ALSO, SO THAT WE CAN CREATE
TUTORIALS.
SHOWING ANYONE HOW TO DO THIS
FOR THEIR OWN DIGITAL
COLLECTION.
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE SOME OF MY
TEAMMATES HERE QUICKLY.
AND ANY OF YOU CAN JOIN THIS
SLIDE.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT
LATER.
WE'RE GOING TO GATHER ALL THE
DATA AND DOCUMENTS.
NEXT, WE'RE FINDING AND LABELING
STRUCTURES IN THE TEXT.
SO MAYBE WE'RE LOOKING FOR A
PARTICULAR SPEECH ACTS OR EVENT
IT IS OR LOCATIONS OR AD HOC
GROUPS AND WE CAN ADD THAT
STRUCTURE TO THE TEXT FLEW AN
NOTATIONS THROUGH XML.
AND
THEN LINK IT INTO EXTERNAL
DATA SOURCE THAT IS ENABLE US TO
THAT, ENABLE POWERFUL QUERIES,
THAT WE ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT WE
COULDN'T ASK BEFORE.
SO LET ME SAY A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WELL STRUCTURED.
READY RESEARCH DATA THAT'S THE
HARD PRODUCT S. TO CREATE A
DATABASE.
AND FOR THE RECORD, WE SHOULD
KNOW WHAT WELL STRUCTURED
RESEARCH DATA LOOKS LIKE.
FIRST OF ALL, IT SHOULD BE
DIGITAL TEXT.
MACHINE READABLE SO THAT A
COMPUTER CAN LOOK FOR DIFFERENT
TOKENS AND COMPARE ACROSS
VARIOUS DOCUMENTS.
IT SHOULD BE QUERIABLE, BUT
ALSO, ACROSS A SET OF DOCUMENTS
THE RESEARCHER HAS DEFINED.
SO IF THEY WANT EVERYTHING FROM
ARIZONA OR A DECADE, YOU SHOULD
BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THAT
IMMEDIATELY.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHEN THEY MOVE
INTO A DIGITAL ARCHIVE AND THEY
TRY TO MAKE IT PUBLIC.
THEY MAKE THIS MISTAKE.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO RETAIN
THE ORIGINAL STRUCTURE AND
FORMATTING OF THE DOCUMENTS.
SO I'M GOING TO DING PRO QUEST
HERE.
I DON'T THINK.
PRO QUEST TRIP ITS OF ALL THE
WHITE SPACE, ALL THE NEW LINE
CHARACTERS, AND THE PARAGRAPH
BREAKS, AND THE SUBHEADINGS HELP
US READ THROUGH THE DOCUMENT AND
UNDERSTAND OH.
THIS IS JUST THE TABLE OF
CONTENTS OR THIS IS A PORTION
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO DO SOME
PREMATTER BUT THEY'RE NOT REALLY
TALKING ABOUT THE HEARING YET.SO
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RETAIN THE
ORIGINAL STRUCTURE THAT THE
ORIGINAL AUTHORS USED TO KEEP
TRACK OF WHICH PORTIONS OF TEXT
ARE DOING WHAT SORT OF
CONCEPTUAL WORK.
WE WANT TO ADD IN SOME SUP
ELIMINATAL AND ANNOTATABLE THING
ON THE TEST.
LOOKING FOR SPEAKERS, LOCATIONS,
ET CETERA.
AND WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO LINK
THE DATA TO OTHER DATA THAT
DESCRIBE THE SAME OBJECTS.
THE ERRORRING MEMBER IS GOING TO
TALK ABOUT CONGRESS MEMBER
SMITH.
BUT THERE'S A LOT I KNOW ABOUT
CONGRESS MEMBER SMITH IN ANOTHER
DATABASE THAT TELLS ME ABOUT HER
AGE AND HER DISTRICT.
THE POPULATION AND DEMOGRAPHICS
OF HER DISTRICT, WHICH MIGHT
INFLUENCE THE WAY SHE'S BEEN
BEHAVING.
IN ALL OF THIS, WE'RE NOT JUST
CREATING A QUERIABLE DATABASE.
THERE'S LEARNING OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO TAKE THEIR
DIGITAL ARCHIVES AND MAKE IT
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO A LARGER
AUDIENCE OF RESEARCHERS AND THE
PUBLIC.
WE'RE GOING TO BE CREATING A
STEP BY STEP HOW TO GUIDE.
WEE BE USING NOTES WHICH ALLOW
US TO WRITE IN PLANE ENGLISH,
WHAT WE'RE DOING.
RIGHT RITE NEXT TO A CELL WHICH
RUNS EXECUTABLE CODE.
SO FOR THOSE THAT ARE A LITTLE
AFRAID OF PROGRAMMING, THE IDEA
IS TO TAKE YOU STEP BY STEP
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF DOING
THAT PHASE 1, GATHERING AND
ADDING THE DATA.
PHASE III, LINK IT TO OTHER
USEFUL DATA TO DIG INTO THESE A
LITTLE BIT.
PHASE 1, BRINGING ALL YOUR DATA
TOGETHER, THIS IS JUST TRYING TO
GET AROUND, POINTING, AND
CLICKING AND DOWNLOADING A
THOUSAND TIMES.
WE CAN ACTUALLY DRAIN A COMPUTER
TO DO THIS.
OR TRIP PEOPLE TO TELL A
COMPUTER HOW TO DO IT.
SO WE'LL BE TRAINING PEOPLE IN
THESE NOTEBOOKS TO USE REGULAR
EXPRESSIONS  TO USE X PATH SO
THAT THEY CAN LOOK ON A WEBSITE
AND A WEB BROWSER AUTOMATION
TOOL LIKE SELENIUM, YOU CAN HAVE
A COMPUTER DO IT FOR YOU.
PHASE 2 IS REALLY WHERE WE'RE
TRYING TO MOVE FROM THE CURRENT
STATE OF THE ART, WHICH IS KIND
OF A CRAFT, TO A SCIENCE.
FINDING STRUCTURE AND TEXT IT
TAKES A LOT OF WORKING BACK AND
FORTH WITH THE TEXT, KNOWING
WHAT IS THEOCRATICAL IMPORTANT
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO FIND
THERE, AND USING THE COMPUTER TO
HELP YOU FIND THAT STRUCTURE TO
CHUNK IT OUT, TO LABEL IT AND TO
ADD STRUCTURE WHERE THERE WASN'T
BEFORE WANT SO WE TAKE TAKE
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT VARIOUS
EXPRESSIONS  AND HOW TO USE XML
AND WE SHOW THEM SOME OF THE
TEXT ANALYSIS TECHNIQUES THAT I
TALKED ABOUT AT THE TOP.
AND WE'RE EVEN USING CROWD
SOURCE AN NOTATION SOFTWARE,
CALLED TEXT [INDISCERNIBLE].
CREATED BY THE GOODLY LABS.
ALL OF THESE THINGS ALLOW US TO
GET THE COMPUTERS TOGETHER TO
FIND THAT STRUCTURE IN THE
TEXT.
IN ORDER TO DO IT EFFICIENT
LEEWAY PROGRAMMING SCRIPT, YOU
NEED TO KNOW SOME BASIC
PROGRAMMING ARCHITECTURE, IT'S
NOT SUPER HARD TO LEARN, BUT
WE'LL TEACH
YOU.
IDENTIFYING RELEVANT DATA Z.
EFFECTIVELY STRUCTURING YOUR
DATABASE SO TAYOU'RE
ANTICIPATING THE QUERIES OF THE
RESEARCH COMMUNITY AND YOU'RE
ALSO REDUCING REDUNDANCIES IN
THE DATA STORAGE.
PAUL, WHO SPOKE JUST BEFORE ME,
REALLY KIND OF SET THIS UP.
IF WE CAN USE SQL AND RELATIONAL
DATABASES, WE CAN COMPUTE MUCH
MORE QUICKLY OVER SOME OF THIS
MULTI LAYERED STRUCTURED
TEXT.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ALL TO GET
RESEARCH READY.
YOU KNOW, WE'LL BE PUSHING SOME
OF THIS OUT IN NOVEMBER AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT PEOPLE WILL
GIVE US
FEEDBACK.
YOUR PHASE 2 TUTORIALS WERE
QUITE CONFUSING.
NEED TO GO BACK TO THE DRAWING
ROOM.
WE NEED TO LOOK FOR ENGAGEMENT
FROM THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS.
SEEMS THEY CUT ME OFF.  HERE WE
GO.
YEAHS IF YOU WANT TO JOIN IN
THIS EFFORT OR FOLLOW ALONG.
HERE ARE SOME LINKS.
WHAT I WAS GOING TO SHOW
YOU IS
THE ENTIRE PROJECT IS COMPLETELY
OPENED TO THE PUBLIC.
YOU CAN GO TO THE OPEN SOCIETY
FRAMEWORK, HOST BY THE THE
CENTER FOR OPEN SCIENCE AND YOU
CAN WATCH AND FOLLOW ALONG WITH
OUR PROJECT.
IF YOU WANT TO JUMP IN, CAN YOU
ACTUALLY GO TO OUR GITA GITA HUB
PAGE AND START DOING FULL
REQUESTS.
ALTHOUGH, FEEL FREE TO CONTACT
US FIRST AND MAYBE WE CAN LEAVE
YOU TO THE WORK THAT'S MOST
PRESSING AT THE MOMENT.
I'M REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
GETTING IN BLUE SKY IN THE
FUTURE.
HELP US OUT IF YOU CAN.
THANKS A
LOT.
NEXT, WE
HAVE, TAHIR SPADES
TEMPO, WORKING IN
INTERDISCIPLINARY COLLABORATION,
THOUGHTS  AND RESEARCH.
HE'S PLANTED BUSINESS STRATEGY
IN THE ENTERTAINMENT, NONPROFIT
INDUSTRIES.
HE PRODUCES ART, MEDIA ART
EDUCATION PROGRAMS  AND MANAGES
THE WRAP RESEARCH LAB.
HE'S GOING TO SHARE A STORY
ABOUT HOW VISUALIZING RAP LYRICS
HELPS  TO TEACH DATA LITERACY TO
HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
TAHIR, YOU'RE UP.
HOW ABOUT A ROUND FOR TAHIR.
[APPLAUSE].
>> SO I HAVE A REQUEST.
CAN YOU CUT ALL AUDIO TO MY
PRESENTATION?
I KNOW IT'S A LITTLE IRONIC.
MY NAME IS HAHIR HEMPHILL.
I AM AN ARTIST,
EDUCATOR,
RADICAL ACTIVIST AND A CREATIVE
TECHNOLOGIST AND I'M GOING TO
TALK ABOUT MY PROJECTS AT THE
RAP RESEARCH
LAB.THE ROLL THAT COLLABORATIVE
PRODUCTION PLAYS IN THE.
THE SLIDES I'M GOING TO GO
THROUGH TODAY, WILL FIT IF THOSE
TWO AREAS.
SO THE SYSTEM THAT I DEVELOPED
IS THE RAP ALMANAC.
AND IT'S ON LINE SEARCHABLE
DATABASE AND IT CONTAINS A
NATURAL LANGUAGE PROCESSING OF
TONS OF HIP-HOP SONGS.
RIGHT NOW, THERE ARE ABOUT 25,
30 ARTISTS.
BAY QUARTER OF A MILLION SONGS
AND THIS IS SOME OF THE DATA
ANALYTICS ASSOCIATED  WITH THE
SONGS.
THE ALBUM TITLE, GEO LOCATION,
RELEASE DATES FOR ALL OF THE
SONGS AND SOME OF THE SYNTAX
ANALYSIS IS THE WORD COUNT
READING
LEVEL, RHYME DENSITY AND
THIS RHYME ANALYSIS THAT WILL
TELL YOU THAT IF WHAT YOU ARE
READ SUGGEST A PERFECT RHYME.
IT'LL ALSO TELL YOU WHERE THE
RHYMES FIT WITHIN THE
LINES.
AND THE SENTIMENT ANALYSIS
COVERS SENTIMENT KEY WORD,
PEOPLE AND
PLACES.
AND THIS IS WHAT A SEARCH IN THE
DATABASE LOOKS LIKE.
IN THIS CASE, THE USER TYPED IN
POWER.
AND YOU GET THIS BALL DATA SONG
TITLE, ALBUM TITLE AND CAN YOU
ADD THESE ADVANCED SEARCH
OPTIONS.
IN THIS CASE, THEY'RE ADDING
SENTIMENT AND SYLLABLES PER
WORD, AND REDOING THE SEARCH.
AND THE MOST EXCITING PART ABOUT
THIS IS THE FACT YOU YOU PRESS
THE BUTTON, AND GET A MACHINE
READABLE OUTPUT AND A HUMAN
READABLE
OUTPUT.
IT TOOK A LONG TIME TO GET GET
TO THAT POINT.
I WAS ECSTATIC WHEN WE GOT TO
THAT POINT.
SO WHAT THE DATABASE GIVES US IS
A NEW CONTEXT FOR HIP-HOP.
SO THERE'S CONTENT.
THERE'S A LOCATION TAG FOR THE
CONTENT.
AND THERE'S A TIME.
SO FOR EVERY UTTERANCE OF
HIP-HOP.
THERE'S A TIME AND PLACE.
CAN YOU SEARCH FOR POWER AND
FIND EVERY RAPPER THAT RAPID
ABOUT POWER.
WHEN THEY RAPID ABOUT POWER AND
THE CONTEXT.
SO IT'S A BIG DATA RAP PROJECT.
SO I'M GOING TO GO THROUGH A FEW
SLIDES OF EXAMPLES OF
VISUALIZATION.
SO ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS I DID
IMMEDIATELY WAS TO DUMP ALL THIS
ON GOOGLE EARTH.
WHAT YOU JUST SAW WAS STAT
INILAND RAPPERS AND NOW YOU'RE
LOOKING AT BROOKLYN RAPPERS AND
QUEENS RAPPERS.
SO THE PROJECT MATCHES THE
GEOGRAPHYY AND LANGUAGE OF
HIP-HOP.
SO YOU CAN FIND OUT HOW SLANG
TRAVELS, HOW R IT ORIGINATES.HOW
REGIONS INFLUENCES OTHER
REGIONS AND I THAT CAN BE DONE
FOR SLANG, FOR POLITICS, AND
THAT CAN BE DONE FOR MANY OTHER
THINGS.
ANOTHER EARLY
DATA.
ARE CHAMPAGNE BRAND MENTIONS.AND
OF COURSE, IT'S LIKE, IT'S
QUAINT.
IT'S
FUNNY.
WE ALL HAVE AN IMAGE OF RAPPERS
AND SHAME PAIN USE.
IF YOU LOOK AT CHAMPAGNE AS AN
ASPIRATIONAL PRODUCT, AND TIMES
FOR CHAMPAGNE USE, THAT ARE TIED
TO EXPRESSIONS OF CELEBRATION OR
EXPRESSIONS OF WEALTH OR THE
FACT YOU WANT TO PRETEND LIKE
YOU HAVE WEALTH, AND UP TO DIG
DEEPER INTO THE CULTURAL
MEANINGS OF CHAMPAGNE AND RAP.
THIS IS A NETWORK RAP I MADE
THAT LOOKS AT CONTEMPORARY AND
MODERN PAINTERS THAT ARE
MENTIONED  IN
RAP.
AND JOHN MICHELLE
BOTSKY BECAME
REALLY POPULAR RECENTLY, IT'S
CALLED PICASSO BABY.
AND IT SHOWS THE DIFFERENT
CONNECTS, THE DIFFERENT CONTEXTS
BETWEEN RAP LYRICS  AND
CULTURE.
AND A PROJECT THEY MADE LAST
YEAR IS CALLED SPOTTIFY CITY,
AND IT DEALS WITH VIRTUAL ELISE
EISENBERG.ITY.
SO I HAD A RESIDENT AT SPOTTIFY
WANT I LOOKED AT THE CONTENT OF
THE STREAMS, AS A REPRESENTATION
OF A LISTENER'S ASPIRATIONS  AND
DESIRES, AS REVEALED THROUGH THE
MUSIC THAT THEY LISTEN TO.
SO THE IDEA IS THAT IF YOU'RE
DRIVING TO DO WORK, ON YOUR WAY
TO WORTH YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT
LISTENING  TO A SONG ABOUT BE AT
WORK.
YOU'RE LISTENING  TO A SONG
ABOUT BEING SOMEWHERE ELSE AT
WORK AND HOW DO WE EXTRACT THAT
VIRTUALITY FROM
STREAMS.
THIS IS A LIGHT LIGHT PEN
DRAWINGS, MADE FROM 20-FOOT TALL
INDUSTRIAL ROBOT.
SO USING THE SEMANTIC ANALYSIS.
I EXTRACTED THE LOCATIONS THAT
ARE MENTIONED IN 12 RAPPERS'
BODIES OF WORK FROM THEIR FIRST
SONG TO THE LAST SONG, AND
THROUGH I THINK IT WAS LIKE A 14
STEP PROCESS, SENT THESE CODES
TO A ROBOT ARM.  AND PUT A LIGHT
PEN IN A ROBOT ARM'S HAND AND
HAD THE ROBOT ARM TRACE THE
LOCKEDS AROUND THE GLOBE.
IN THIS
CASE, IS KANYE WEST.
THIS IS A DIGITAL MODEL OF THE
SAME THING WE ARE DEVELOPING
INTO A VR EDUCATIONAL PIECE.
SO THE GREEN PATH ARE THE PATHS
THAT THE RAPPERS
-- THAT THE RAP
TRAVELS AND I WASN'T SATISFIED
WITH JUST TWO DIMENSION WANT I
WAS INN SATISFIED WITH TWO
DIMENSIONAL REPRESENTATION.  SO
PRODUCING DATA SCROLL PURE OF IT
WORK.
AND THIS WAS THE SUITE OF ALL
THE RAPPERS.  I'M HAVING A SOLO
SHOW AT CCA IN SEPTEMBER,
EVERYONE IS INVITED HERE, TOO.
AND I'M GOING TO PRESENT THIS
WORK.
SO THE PROJECT VISUALIZES
HIP-HOP AS A CULT AURAL
INDICATOR.
CAN YOU IMAGINE OVERLAYING
HEALTH DATA SETS.  CRIME,
STATISTIC DATA SETS.
EDUCATION DATA SETS DOWN TO A
COUNTY LEVEL AND OVERLAYING
THOSE WITH THIS DATA
SET.
AND THIS IS THE ANALYSIS, THE
SEMANTIC ANALYSIS OF DRAKE'S
ENTIRE BODY OF WORK BEING
PROCESSED.
COL, BUT DATA NEEDS MEMORY,
RIGHT?
IT'S NICE TO HAVE PAGES  AND
PAGES OF DATA, YOU KNOW, WHETHER
IT'S MACHINE READABLE.
BUT IN ORDER TO TELL A STORY
WITH DATA, YOU KIND OF NEED AN
EXPERIENCE TIED  TO IT, TO BRING
IT TO LIFE.
AND IT WAS THIS QUESTION OF
THESE TYPES OF QUESTIONS THAT
MADE ME START TO WRITE RESEARCH
LAB AND ESPECIALLY THIS
QUESTION.
SHOULD A CULTURE OWN ITS OPEN
DATA.
LIKE, WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROTECTING THIS DATA WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR TELLING THE
STORIES ABOUT THIS DATA.
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR CHECK
BEING THE STORIES TOLD ABOUT
THIS CULTURAL DATA AND AND EVEN
WHEN TECHNOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENT
ADVANCES ITS WORKERS INTO
EXCITING NEW SPACES OF CREATIVE
INQUIRY, THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHALLENGE TRADITIONAL MODES OF
HIERARCHY IS OFTEN MISSED.
AND MOST OF THE TIME, IF THERE'S
A NEW SPACE OPENED, WE BRING OUR
SAME BIASES TO THESE OPEN
SPACES, INSTEAD OF TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING NEW OR IMAGINING
SOMETHING NEW.
WE JUST POURED OUR OLD STUFF TO
THE NEW SPACES.
SO SEW IN THE AGE OF BIG DATA
NORMATIVE NARRATIVES AROUND
HIP-HOP WANT WE PRODUCE STORY
TYPES.
FOR ME, THAT ALSO EXTENDS TO THE
SINGULARITY AND ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE LIKE, THE
SINGULARITY IN A WAY WAY IS A
COLONIZING PROCESS.
IT IGNORES WHAT HAPPENS ON THE
SIDES, AND JUST FOCUSES ON WHAT
WORKS FOR THE
SYSTEM.
I HAVE TO INVITE PEOPLE TO TALK
ABOUT THESE QUESTIONS, EXPLORE
THESE QUESTIONS AND GRAPPLE.
THE RAP RESEARCH LAB SAY
CREATIVE TECHNOLOGY STUDIO AND
WE EBBING PROPER RAP AS A
CULTURAL INDICATOR THROUGH
EDITORIAL AND CREATIVE
INTERROGATIONS.
I'M GOING TO READ A BIT.
WE ARE A TEAM OF RESEARCHERS,
RADICAL EDUCATORS.
TECHNOLOGY GIST IT IS AND ARTIST
WHO IS USE RAP AS TEXT, TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND YOUTH
CULTURE.
WE EXPLORE QUESTIONS OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND FACILITATE
RESILIENCE FLEW DATA PROJECTS.
AND WE DESIGN PROJECTS AND ASK
QUESTIONS, BOTH COLLABORATIVELY
AND INDIVIDUALLY, THAT CHALLENGE
NOTIONS OF OWNERSHIP AND AGENCY,
AND NEW SPACES.
SO JUST A FEW AXIOMS RULES OFF
THE TOP, THAT WE BELIEVE AT THE
RAP RESEARCH LAB.
RAP IS THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
GLOBAL AND YOUTH ART FORM,
PERIOD MUCH ACCORDING TO A
SPOTTIFY ANALYSIS OF 20 BILLION
STREAM SONGS, BACK IN 2015, RAP
IS THE MOST LISTENED TO GENRE IN
THE WORLD.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT STUDY, RAP
IS MORE POPULAR THAN ROCK, BUT
WE ALREADY KNEW THAT.
I MEAN, RAP HAS MORE WORDS.
ANOTHER AXIOM IS, HIP-HOP ISN'T
RAP, GRAFFITI, DJING AND BREAK
DANCING.
RAP IN THE BEGIN THERE WAS A DJ
AND NO HIP-HOP RECORDS.
COOL HERK, PLAYING IN 1973 IN
THE BRONX WANT THERE WERE NO RAP
RECORDS.
THERE WERE NO HIP-HOP RECORDS.
THERE WERE SOUL, FUNK RECORDS,
PLUS RECORDS, THERE WERE ROCK
RECORDS, BUT WHAT WAS HIP-HOP
WAS THE WAY HE PLAYED THOSE
RECORDS.
SO HIP-HOP IS A FRAMEWORK AND
THE FRAMEWORK IN WHICH HE PLAYED
THOSE RECORDS.
AND THE QUOTE FROM MY COLLEAGUE,
DAVID GOLDBERG, THIS FRAMEWORK
IS HELPFUL, IN A FRAGMENTED
WORLD, HIP IS AN EFFECTIVELY
APPROACH TO PROBLEM SOLVING,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOUR FUTURE
DEPEND ON THE RISING RUINS OF
INHERENTED MISTAKES.
SO BECAUSE OF THIS FRAMEWORK.
WE DECIDED TO TEACH.
AND THIS IS A MAP OF A CRUMB
ALMOST IN OUR LESSON
PA PLANS.
WE START WITH AN INTRODUCTION.
THE HISTORY OF THE TECHNOLOGY.
HISTORY OF THE CULTURE.
AND THEN WE STEVE THE STUDENTS
HOW
TEACH THE STUDENTS HOW TO
ASK QUESTIONS.
HOW TO FORMULATE GOOD RESEARCH
QUESTIONS.
THEN WE HAVE A CONTENT CODING
EXERCISE WHERE WE DO CLOSED
READINGS OF LYRICS, AND CONTENT
CODES THEM.
THIS IS AN LOG.
WE ALSO HAVE A DIGITAL VISIONER.
THEN WE TEACH THE CITY COUNCILS
HOW TO CONDUCT THE SEARCH, HOW
TO USE THE TOOLS AND WE DEAL
WITH DATA BIAS.
LIKE, THEIR OWN IMPLICIT BIAS
AND EXTERNAL BIAS.
HOW DO THEY COLLECT THE DATA
ABOUT A WHAT DID THEY LEAVE
OUT.
WHAT WAS LEFT OUT IN THE INITIAL
PROCESS OF THE DATA THAT THEY
COLLECTED AND HOW THINGS FALL
OFF ALONG THE WAY.
AND THEN WE HAVE SOME MAPPING
LESSONS AND VISUALIZATION
LESSONS WANT SO THE
METHODOLOGIES IN THIS
FRAMEWORK.
WE INVITE PARTICIPANTS TO ENGAGE
CRITICALLY, WITH CULTURAL
RESEARCH, DATA COLLECTION, DATA
ETHICS, IMPLICIT BIAS, DATA BIAS
AND STORY TELLING.
THESE ARE ELEMENTS THAT
ULTIMATELY EMPOWER THE CRITICAL
THINKINGS AND DECISION MAKING
THAT LEAVES A STATUS CAPABLE TO
BECOME ESTABLISHING INFORMED
POSITIONS.
THIS OUTCOME NOT ONLY INFLUENCES
BEHAVIORAL CHANGE, BUT IS A
PRECURSOR TO DEPLOYING A HEALTHY
DEMOCRACY, ESPECIALLY IN THIS
PIST TRUTH ERA.
SO WE'RE DEALING WITH DATA
LITERACY.
MEDIA
LITERACY AND ACTUALLY,
LISTENING  TO RAP AND HAVING FUN
DOING IT.
I'M MAKING IT SOUND SO BORING.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT IT'S REALLY
COOL.WE PILOTED A FEW YEARS
AGO.  AND
I INVITED TEACHERS TO PRODUCE
THE CURRICULUM WITH ME.
AND THE THIRD PHASE WAS THE
SPREAD.
SO THIS IS MY ONE ROOM SCHOOL
HOUSE IN THE SOUTH
BRONX.
AND DOWN ON THE BOTTOM RIGHT,
THIS IS A DESIGN THAT WE HAVE,
WHERE WE INVITED EDUCATORS IN TO
TEST OUR CURRICULUM.
AND ON THE TOP RIGHT IS ACTUALLY
THE GRADUATION DAY, WHERE I
INSIGHTED SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES,
IN THE ART AND TECH WORLD TO
COME AND GIVE CRITIQUE AND
SUPPORT TO THE STUDENTS.
TOP LEFT, THAT'S A PICTURE OF
ME, AND ON THE BOTTOM LEFT IS
ONE OF OUR CONTENT CODING
EXERCISES WHERE WE ASKED THE
TUNES TO IDENTIFY IN THIS CASE
-- WE ASKED THE STUDENTS TO
IDENTIFY, IN THIS CASE, 5 THEMES
THEY THINK THEY'LL FIND IN THE
MUSIC.
BODY, SEXUALITY, ACHIEVEMENTS,
RELATIONSHIPS, LOVE, FAMILY,
CONFLICT AND ORIGINS, POLITICS.
WE GIVE THEM TEXT AND WE ASK
THEM TO CONTENT CODE.
SO EVERY TIME THEY SEE ONE OF
THESE TEAMS, AT A TAG IT IN THE
TEXT.
AND THAT'S AN AN LOG PROCESS
THAT
HELPS BUILD AILING
ALGORITHMIC SYNCHING, AND THESE
ARE SCALED.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE WORKSHOPS
WE DID IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
PARKS
DEPARTMENT AND THEN THE
LAST PHASE IS THE SPREAD WHERE
WE TOOK OUR CRUCK ALMOST AND
TRAINED THE NEW YORK CITY'S
PARKS DEPARTMENT EDUCATORS TO
IMPLEMENT OUR CURRICULUM IN 10
LOCATIONS, IN 5 BURROWS, FOR 9
MONTHS AROUND NEW YORK
CITY.
AND IT WAS A TRIP TO SEE
STUDENTS STUDY ME AND MY PROCESS
ON THEIR SCREEN.
BUT IT WAS EXCITING  TO SEE THIS
PROCESS CAN BE SPREAD AND SCALED
SO I WOULDN'T HAVE TO BE THE
ONLY ONE, STANDING IN FRONT OF
THE
CLASSROOM.  I'M GOING TO
SHOW YOU TWO STUDENT PROJECTS.SO
WE HAVE A STUDENT RESEARCH
PAGE.
AND GABRIEL WAS INTERESTED IN
DOING RESEARCH ON THE Q-WORD IN
AWFUL HIP-HOP.
HE QUICKLY REALIZED THAT WAS TOO
MUCH DATA FOR HIM TO PROCESS.
SO EAST KIND OF BUMMED OUT.
SO I WAS LIKE, WHAT DO YOU WANT
TO DO?
THEN HE REALIZED  IN HIS
RESEARCH, THERE WAS AN ARTIST
THAT HAD A SONG, WHERE HE
MENTIONS THE N-WORD ALMOST 200
TIMES SO HE DECIDES TO FOCUS ON
THAT ARTIST, AND CONTENT CODE.
ALL OF HIS SONGS, THROUGH A LENS
OF THIS DICTIONARY OF SLANG THAT
GIVES 8
MEANINGS OF THE N-WORD
WANT SO YOU'RE SEEING DIGITAL
CONTENT CODING.
SO THESE ARE THE SONGS ON THE
DROP DOWN MENU.
ON THE RIGHT, THESE ARE THE
DIFFERENT
DESCRIPTIONS.
SO
SOMEONE'S LOVER, SOMEONE
THAT'S REBELLIOUS.
SOMETHING THAT'S NEGATIVE.  AND
A FILLER THIS IS A PROJECT BY
EMMANUEL, WHO WAS READING SOME
OF THE ARTICLES ABOUT RAPPERS
AND RAPS THAT WERE BEING USED AS
TESTIMONY IN COURT AND HE WANTED
TO INVESTIGATE THE DIFFERENCES
OR WHETHER THERE WAS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CRIMES THAT
WERE RAPPED ABOUT, AND ACTUAL
CRIMES THAT WERE HAPPENING.
SO THIS IS A MAP THAT HE
MADE.
CORRELATION, OF COURSE, YOU
KNOW, AREN'T TIED BUT THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE.
SO WHEN CRIME IS DOWN,
BASICALLY, CRIME CRIME RAPS ARE
HIGH.
AND I'M GOING TO CLOSE WITH THIS
ONE QUOTE BY DJ PREMIERE AND HE
TALKS ABOUT PRODUCING JAYS-Z'S
FIRST ALBUM.
HE SAYS ONE THING HE LOVES ABOUT
HIP-HOP IS YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO LISTEN TO T.
JUT BECAUSE JAY Z-SPEAKING IN
ENGLISH DOESN'T MEAN YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT HE'S SAYING.
THAT'S THE REASON FOR THE RAP
RESEARCH LAB.
TO DO A DEEP LIVE, IN DECODING
THE MOST POPULAR ART FORM IN THE
WORLD.
THANK
YOU.[APPLAUSE].
>> OUR FINAL SPEAKER BEFORE
BREAK IS JEFF HANES STYLES WHO
HAS WORKED ON INNOVATIVE SCIENCE
MEDIA PROJECT, WHEN HE WAS
DIRECTOR AND SENIOR PRODUCER FOR
CARL SAGIN'S, LAND MARK AND
COSMOS WINNING SERIES.
HE'S HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
CROWD AND THE CLOUD AND HOW
CITIZEN SCIENCE HAS
REVOLUTIONIZED SCIENTIFIC DATA
SCIENCE BY, FOR AND WITH THE
PEOPLE.
HOW CITIZEN SCIENCE AND MOBILE
TECH HAVE REVOLUTIONIZED THE
COLLECTION AND USE OF SCIENTIFIC
DATA JEFF, TAKE IT AWAY.
>> THANKS VOICE OF GOD.
APPRECIATE IT.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY,
INTERACTIVE GOD.
IT'S EVEN BETTER.
I WAS GOING TO SAY, SOMETHING
DISH.
BUT EVERY SINGLE TALK HAS BEEN
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
THANKS TO THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FOR INVITING US ALL
TODAY AND I'VE GOT SOME
REFERENCES THAT ACTUALLY TIE
INTO THE SOME OF THE
THEMES-TALK.
I'VE BEEN A SCIENCE PRODUCER
SINCE 1980.
IT'S TAKEN ME TO THE END OF THE
EARTH WHICH IS FORTUNATE.
THEY GIVE YOU HELMETS  TO COVER
YOUR BALD SPOT, WHICH IS GOOD.
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE CROWD
IN THE CLOUD.
MY COLLABORATORS, INDITE AT THIS
TIME FORMER NASA CHIEF
SCIENTIST.
AND MY COLLABORATOR IN LIFE AND
WORK, WHO IS IN THE FRONT
THERE.
RECENT GRANDMOTHER.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[APPLAUSE].
SEE, THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS
CONGRATULATES YOU AS WELL.
ISN'T THIS GREAT.
I'VE HAD A GREAT TIME WORKING
WITH SOME OF THE MOST CELEBRATED
SCIENTISTS IN THE COUNTRY, AND
ALSO COMEDIANS LIKE LILLY
TOMLIN.
WHAT I HADN'T BEEN AWARE OF S&L
I WAS WALKING AROUND YESTERDAY,
IS THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS HAS A
COLLECTION OF
-- DESIGNED TO
INCREASE THE VISIBILITY AND
PARTICIPATION IN CITIZEN
SCIENCE.
HOW MANY IN THE AUDIENCE COULD
DEFINE CITIZEN SCIENCE AT A
COCKTAIL PARTY?
ABOUT FIVE OR SIX PEOPLE OUT OF
A COUPLE HUNDRED.  THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WE DECIDED WE SHOULD
DO THE SERIES.
CITIZEN SCIENCE M YOU'LL HEAR
FROM SOME OF THE CITIZEN
SCIENTISTS YOURSELVES.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE WORD THAT
IS OF COURSE USED TO DEFINE
CITIZEN SCIENCE OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS.
YOU'LL SEE CYBER IS IN A LOT
THEM.
A LOT OF THEM HAVE NATURAL
HISTORY ENVIRONMENTS AS PART OF
THE SUBJECT MATTER.
ONE OF MY FIELD AND TITAN FALL
ONCE IS NERDS FOR NATURE, AND IS
ACTUALLY A CITIZENS SCIENCE
PROJECT CALLED NERDS FOR
NATURE.
ANOTHER WAY OF SAYING THAT,
HOWEVER WOULD BE SCIENCE, BY,
FOR AND WITH THE PEOPLE THAT YOU
MAY NOTICE COMES FROM THE
GETTIESBERG ADDRESS, AND LINCOLN
IS A GREAT PRESENCE IN THE
LIBRARY OF CONFIDENCE.
WE HAVE CREATED 4 PROGRAMS.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A LARGE
NUMBER OF VIDEO CLIPS.
CROWD AND CLOUD.ORG IS WHERE YOU
CAN FIND ALL THE PROGRAMS
STREAMING IN REAL TIME IF WHAT
WE SHOW YOU IS OF INTERESTING.
OUR PREMISES IS TO TRY TO TURN
VIEWERS INTO DUEERS.
NOT JUST TO HAVE A GOOD TIME
WATCHATION TV SHOW, BUT BE
ENCOURAGED TO BECOME PART OF THE
STATUS SCIENCE MOVEMENT.
AND IT WOULDN'T BE POSSIBLE
WITHOUT COLLABORATION OF A
NUMBER OF AGENCIES.
THIS IS HOW WE BEGIN THE SERIES
AND THIS PRESENTATION.
>> VIDEO: THE CROWD AND THE
CLOUD IS MADE POSSIBLE BY MSF --
NSF.
THE NATIONAL SCIENCE FOUNDATION,
WHERE DISCOVERIES
BEGIN.PEOPLE PURSUING THEIR
PASSIONS,
AND GENERATING DATA THAT IS
USEFUL FOR RESEARCH.
>> I LOVE SCIENCE.
I CAN GO SUFFERING FOR SCIENCE.
>> TECHNOLOGY SAY WAY TO REALLY
GET PEOPLE OUTSIDE AND LOOK MORE
CAREFULLY AT THE NATURAL WORLD.
>> DOLLAR NOW MORE MOBILE PHONES
ON EARTH THAN PEOPLE ON OUR
PLANET.
AND NEW TECHNOLOGIES CAN HELP
SOLVE MAJOR CHALLENGES.
>> EVERY SINGLEDATE DATA THATTA
POINT HAS A STORY.
NOW, COMMUNITIES CAN USE SCANS
TO TACKLE LOCAL PROBLEMS.
>> THE STATE DOESN'T COME OUT
AND SAY, YOU'VE GOT TO CLEAN
THIS UP.
>> THEY'RE LINKING SENSORS AND
CITIZENS  TO FIND SOLUTIONS.
>> I'M LEARNING ABOUT TOXINS.I'M
LEARNING HOW TO TEACH OTHER
PEOPLE TO DO WHAT I DO SO THEY
CAN DO IT FOR
THEMSELVES.
COLLABORATING VEE AT CLOUD, THE
CROWD CAN SAVE TIME, SAVE MONEY
AND SAVE LIVES.
WE'RE SURELY SMARTER TOGETHER.
I'M WALEED
ABDULADI.
I'VE STUDIED EARTH ICE SHEETS
FROM AIRCRAFT, AND I WAS NASA
CHIEF WHEN CURIOSITY LANDED ON
MARS.
SO I KNOW BIG DATA AND BIG
SCIENCE.
BUT I'M CONCERNED THAT NO LONGER
IS SCIENCE SOMETHING DONE ONLY
BY PROPOSALS  IN A LAB.
NO MORE IS DATA JUST THE
PROPERTY OF CORPORATIONS AND
GOVERNMENT.
>> FOR YEARS, YOU'VE WATCHED
SCIENCE ON PUBLIC TELEVISION.
NOW, YOU'RE INVITED TO DO
SCIENCE.
>> I HOPE YOU CAN SEE, WE HAVE
GOT A WIDE VARIETY OF PROBLEMSES
WE FEATURED IN THE SERIES AND A
WIDE VARIETY OF FOLKS WHO WERE
INVOLVED.
CITIZEN SCIENCE HAS A LONG
HISTORY, THE BACKGROUND HERE IS
THOMAS JEFFERSON'S WEATHER
RECORDS, DATING BACK TO THE
1770'S AND TODAY, CITIZEN
SCIENTISTS LOOKING AT WHETHER
20,000 OBSERVERS ARE RECORDING
DAILY PRECIPITATION
MEASUREMENTS, ON THE LEFT HAND
SIDE, IN MICHELLE OBAMA'S
VEGETABLE GARDEN.
THESE ARE CONTRIBUTING DATA THAT
THE NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE
USES  TO UPDATE FLASH FLOOD
WARNINGS.
HISTORY OF THE CHRISTMAS BIRD
COUNT GOES BACK TO THE
19HUNDREDS.
ONE OF THE LONGEST RUNNING
PROJECT IN THE UNITED STATES.BUT
CONTEMPORARY CITIZEN SCIENCE
INCLUDES MILLENNIALS.
PEOPLE THAT ARE A PART OF THE
PUBLIC LAB.
IT MAKES ME THINK OF ARCADE FIRE
ON TOUR.
BUT THESE ARE CITIZEN SCIENTISTS
FLYING.
BALLOONS UNDERNEATH KITES  TO
DOCUMENT THE B.P. OIL SPILL OFF
THE DEEP WATER HORIZON.
CONTEMPORARY CITIZEN SCIENTIST
INCLUDES PUTTING
SENSORS,
MICROSCOPIC FENCE TO LOOK AT SEA
TEMPERATURE.
LIKE I SAID, A GREAT VARIETY.
TRYING TO TIE MY PRESENTATION TO
THE THEMES OF THIS CONFERENCE,
I'M GOING TO TALK ABOUT THREE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF DATA
COLLECTION AND SHARING IN SOME
CASES, IT'S A QUESTION OF
PUTTING DATA ON THE MAP AND
HELPING TO SOLVE PROBLEMS.
THE WEST OAKLAND ENVIRONMENTAL
INDICATOR'S PROJECT.
IT WAS FOUNDED TO LOOK AT TRUCK
ROUTES GOING THROUGH WEST
OAKLAND AND HOW TRUCK ROOTS WERE
CORE RESPONDING  TO ASTHMA
ATTACKS IN SENIOR CITIZEN CARE
CENTERS AND DAYCARE CENTERS.
THEY'D GO OUT AND COUNT TRUCKS
AND GOING TO CITY GOVERNMENT TO
GET THEM TO MOVE THE TRUCK
ROUTES AWAY FROM THE HOST
HEAVILY POPULATED AREAS.
THEY HAVE CONTINUED THEIR WORK
REACHING OUT TO KISSED,
IATRIAING  TO GET KIDS EXCITED
ABOUT THE NEW GENERATION AND
THIS NEXTY CLIP IS HOW THE
TEAMS, HOW EXCITED THE TEAMS
GET.
WHEN DOING THEIR RESEARCH.
THEY WERE USINGS THEIR
ENVIRONMENT, THEIR COMMUNITY AS
THE SOURCE OF
DATA.
>> WHEN THE STUDENT HAS BEEN
ABLE TO GO OUT AND WALK AROUND
THE COMMUNITY.
AND COLLECT DATA AND THEN
OBSERVE THINGS, THEY UNDERSTAND
THE CORRELATION BETWEEN THE DATA
AND THE SOURCES, AND THE
SOLUTION THEY'RE INTERESTED IN.
>> THIS IS CALLED THE DUST
TRACK.
IT MALICIOUS HOW MUCH DUST IS IN
THE AIR.
PARTICULAR MATTER IS THE LITTLE
DUST PARTICLE THAT IS WE CAN'T
SEE.THE AIR FILTER IN THERE IS A
CARTRIDGE.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT METAL.
THIS IS MET
AMP BECAUSE OF THE
LOW COST SENSORS AVAILABLE ^,
AND THE SMART PHONES, ARE THE
DEVICES.
STUDENTS CAN COLLECT DATA AND
IMMEDIATELY BEGIN INTERPRETING
THEM.
IN DECEMBER 2015, SOME OF THE
STUDENTS PRESENTLIED THEIR
FINDINGS AT THE AMERICAN
GEOPHYSICAL UNIT, ONE OF THE
LARGEST AND BIZZEST GATHERINGS
OF PROPOSAL EARTH SCIENCES.
>> THAT'S AMAZING.
I DIDN'T REALIZE HOW BIG A
DEAL.
ONCE I STARTED LOOKING INTO T WE
HAVE SOMETHING TO BRING TO THE
TABLE TO.
PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR WHAT WE HAVE
TO SAY.
IT'S KIND OF
EXCITING.
WE MIGHT CHANGE SOMETHING.
>> WE SOMETIMES RIGHTEN THE
STATISTICIANSES BECAUSE THEY
WOULD PREFER TO HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF PERFECTLY PRESS TEEN,
ABSOLUTELY, YOU KNOW, 100% DATA
FROM A MILLION DOLLAR MACHINE
AND WE'RE SAYING NO, NO, LET'S
TAKE THIS 200-DOLLAR MACHINE AND
START MAKING DECISIONS, BASED ON
IT.
BUT THE NOTION IS, IF YOU HAD
1 MILLION-DOLLAR ON MACHINES,
CAN YOU DO SO MUCH.
BUT IF YOU HAD A
MILLION
100-MACHINES, THEN WE'D START TO
ADJUST BEHAVIOR IMMEDIATELY.
>> SO THE SECOND CATEGORY OF
CITIZEN SCIENCE I'M GOING TO
TALK ABOUT WHERE THIS IS NO DATA
THERE ARE NO AGENCIES IN
GATHERING THE DATA AND SHARING
THAT.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE FROM THE
SECOND PROGRAM, WHICH IS CALLED
CITIZENS PLUS SCIENTISTS OF
WHERE A CONCERNED CITIZEN, DEB,
YOU'LL SEE HER IN THE PIECE.
BUT BECAUSE IT'S AN EDITED
SEGMENT, THAT'S YET NAMES ARE
HERE AT THE BEGINNING, WAS
CONCERN ABOUT AIR POLLUTION IN
HER AREA.
CONCERNING GAS AND OIL
DEVELOPMENT.
SHE WENT TO THE NGO, AND YOU'LL
SEE HOW DATA IS CAPTURED, AND
SHARED THAT THROUGHOUT PEER
REVIEW PROCESS, WITH A BIG
RESULT IN TERMS OF STATE
POLICY.
SO IT GOES ALL WAIT FROM DATA
COLLECTION, TO SOCIAL GOOD,
SOCIALLY BENEFICIAL
RESULTS.
>> IT TOOK OUT RIGHT OUT OF A
HUNDRED SEMI LOADS.
YOU KNOW, THE TRAFFIC WENT FROM
MAYBE THREE, FOUR CARDS A WEEK
TO 50 A DAY.
TONS OF DUST ON THIS COUNTY
ROAD.
THEY'D LIGHT THE FLAIR ^, AND
THE WHOLE BOTTOM WOULD SHAKE.SO
OUR HOUSE WOULD JUST SHAKE.
LOTS OF
NOISE.
THERE WERE SPILLS, AND LEAKS,
NOBODY CLEANS TUP.
NOBODY SAYS GOING.
THERE'S NO OVERSIGHT.  THE STATE
DOESN'T COME OUT AND SAY, YOU'VE
GOT TO CLEAN THIS UP.
THE FIRST THING THAT HAPPENS IS
THE SITES ARE SELECTED.
THE CITIZEN SCIENTISTS ARE
TRAINED ONSITE BY OURSELVES.
THEY HAVE GOT A SET NUMBER OF
SAMPLES THEY CAN TAKE.
SO THE SAMPLES ARE TAKEN.
LITERALLY, TAKING A PLASTIC
BUCKET AND PUT SOMETHING
STAINLESS STEEL ON IT, THAT WILL
HOLD THE SAMPLE BAG.
THE BUCKET IS THE BODY.
THE BAG IS THE LUNG, AND THERE'S
A PUMP THAT SERVICE AS YOUR
DIAPHRAM THAT PUMPS THE AIR OUT,
CREATING NEGATIVE PRESSURE.
OPENING THE BAG, AND BRINGING IN
AIR SO IT CAN BE SEALED AND SENT
TO THE LAB FOR TESTING.
THEY PROCESS IT IMMEDIATELY.
>> BUCKET BRIGADE TECHNIQUES
HAVE BEEN REVIEWED BY THE EPA
AND ARE FOUND USEFUL WHERE ANY
OF THE SENSORS ARE LACKING.
>> I DIDN'T THINK I'D FIND
MUCH.
AND WE FOUND CREATING DATA
MISSIONS OFF THE FREAKIN'
CHART.
>> WE FOUND, MANY OF THE SAMPLES
EXCEEDED THOSE STANDARDS.
SOME WERE SOMETHING LIKE 10,000
TIMES ABOVE THE STANDARD.
MANY OF THE TOXIC CHEMICALS THAT
ARE KNOWN TO CAUSE CANCER WHICH
WE FOUND IN THIS REPORT.
IN ONE CASE, 22 MILLION TIMES
OVER THE EPA CANCER RISK.
>> THESE WERE ENORMOUS
RELEASES.
MANY OF THESE COMPOUNDS ARE
NEURAL TOXINS.
HIGH CONCENTRATION THAT IS CAN
ACTUALLY CAUSE COMB A. BUT AT
LOWER CONCENTRATIONS, THEY TEND
TO REDUCE BRAIN FUNCTION.
THE LONG-TERM EFFECTS, BIGGEST
ONE IS CANCER.
SEVERAL OF THESE ARE KNOWN HUMAN
CASEINOGENS.
>> SO WHEN WE STARTED DOING THE
BRIAN WAS GATE, 5, 6-STATE
BUCKET BRIAN WAS GATE.
WE DIDN'T INTEND ON DOING THE
PEER REVIEWED ARM.
WE WERE JUST GOING TO DO THE
REPORT.
>> I BECAME INVOLVED IN THE
TRACKING STUDY WHEN THE GROUPS
THAT HAD COORDINATED THE
COMMUNITY BASED ACTIVITIES
APPROACHED ME FOR ASSISTANCE
DOING THE STATISTICAL ANALYSIS
OF THE DATA ABOUT A WRITING UP
THE PUBLICATION AND GET TOGETHER
PUBLISHED  IN A PEER REVIEW
JOURNAL.
WHENEVER THERE IS THIS KIND OF
STUDY, HAVING A PEER REVIEW PUN
OCCASIONS SORT OF THE GOOD
HOUSEKEEPING SEAL OF LEGITIMACY
FOR A STUDY.
>> WHAT HAPPENS IS EVERYTHING
DISSES IT.
SO THE PEER REVIEWED ARTICLE WAS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
GAVE VALIDITY TO CITIZEN
SCIENCE.
>> I THINK THAT'S WHY WE GOT
TAKEN SO SERIOUSLY.
THAT A JOURNAL ARTICLE HAD BEEN
PUBLISHED AND THIS IS WHAT
ACADEMICS, SCIENTISTS  AND
DOCTORS WERE SAYING ABOUT THE
EXTREME HAZARD AND THERE WAS
WIDESPREAD COVERAGE ACROSS THE
U.S. AND TILE, GLOBALLY, OF BOTH
THE PEER REVIEWED STUDY, AND THE
REPORT AND IT HAD A MAJOR
IMPACT.
>> I THINK THE GREATEST
INFLUENCE FROM THE WARNING SIGNS
REPORT WAS FOR THE
[INDISCERNIBLE] IN NEW YORK.
>> OUR TRACKING STUDY WAS WAIVED
BITE COMMISSIONER, WHEN ME MADE
THE ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK WAS BANNING
TRACKING.
[END OF VIDEO]
SO THE LAST GENRE IS REALLY LIKE
CROWD SOURCING WANT SO MUCH DATA
OR LACK OF DATA IN THE CASE OF
TRACKING, AND THE DEEP WATER
HORIZON, THERE'S SO MUCH DATA
COMING OUT OF RESEARCH LAB, YOU
COULD CROWD SOURCE IT MUCH
FASTER THAN THE WORK CAN BE DONE
BY RESEARCHERS THEMSELVES.
SO THIS STORY IS ABOUT FOLKS UP
AT CORNELL WHO WERE LOOKING  TO
SEE IF THEY CAN FIGURE OUT THE
CAUSES OF ALZYMEERS.
THEY EXPERIMENT ON MICE, THEY
TAKE VIDEOS OF MOUSE BRAINS AND
TASTE PROBLEM THAT TAKES THEM A
WEEK TO CAPTURE THE DATA BUT A
YEAR TO ANALYZE T. THEY BORROWED
FROM, EXAMPLES  FROM SUCCESSFUL
GAME FEED CITIZENS PROJECTS,
INCLUDING THE NASA STAR DUST
MISSION, WHERE 30,000 PEOPLE
PLAYING GAME WERE ESSENTIALLY
ABLE TO FIND TRACES OF
INTERSTELLAR PARTICLES AND
I-WIRE, LOOKING AT NEURONS IN
THE BRAIN.
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER, THEY WERE
ABLE TO BORROW FROM ALL OF THE
LESSONS OF WEB GAMES, IN TERMS
OF OF LEADER BOARDS,
COMPETITIONS, FIGHTING TO HAVE
YOUR NAME UP THERE AT THE TOP OF
THE LEADER BOARD AND THIS IS HOW
A CITIZENS PROJECT WAS DEMOED
IN A RETIREMENT COMMUNITY IN
FLORIDA, PLAYING THE STORE
CATCHER'S GAME.
CAN YOU SEAT EXCITEMENT THE
SENIOR CITIZENS GOT, FROM TRYING
TO SPEEDUP ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
>> VIDEO:
[INDISCERNIBLE] RELEASED ITS
STAR CATCHER'S GAME.
BASED ON THE STAR DUST INNER
FACE.
THE CROWD WAS INVITED TO HELP
CROWD SOURCE THE ANALYSIS FOR
BLOCKED BLOOD VESSELS.
SOME OF THE FIRST PLAYERS WERE
IN CENTRAL FLORIDA.
THEY WERE RETIREES WHO HAS
CHOSEN A WARM CLIENT IN A
COMMUNITY WITH PLENTY TO DO.
>> HOW MANY OF YOU HAVE FAMILY
FRIENDS, SOMEBODY CLOSE TO YOU,
THAT HAD OR DID HAVE ALZHEIMER'S
OR YOU HAVE IT?
JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING.
IF ONLY THE SCIENTISTS WORKED ON
IT, IT MIGHT TAKE AS MUCH AS 30
YEARS AND FOR MOST IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE A BIG BENEFIT.
THIS IS WHAT THE GAME LOOKS
LIKE.
AND YOU CAN GET IT ON YOUR
PHONE, YOUR TABLET, YOUR LAP
TOP.
>> DOES THE GAME CHANGE EVERY
DAY.
>> YES.
YES.
HOW MANY THINK THAT IT'S
SLOWING?
HOW MANY THINK IT'S
SOLVED?
SHOULD WE FIND OUT?
TRY AND SOLVE THEN.
I'VE GOT 402 POINTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[LAUGHTER]HERE WE
GO.
EVERY TIME WE FIND A SOLVE ONE
--
>>
[END OF VIDEO PRACTICAL.
>> WE CAN HELP MY GENERATION.I'M
64.
WHILE THIS IS GOING TO HELP MY
MOM, THIS IS GOING TO HELP KIDS
MY AGE.
>> EYES ON OWLS WILL KEEP
REFINING, IT'S GAME INTERFACE B.
GREATEST IMPACT WILL COME FROM
THE LIMITLESS POWER OF THE
CROWD.
ONE OF THE COMMON QUESTIONS
ABOUT CITIZEN SCIENCE, IS, IS
THE DATA QUALITY RELIABLE
ENOUGH.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FIND
THAT RELATIVE TO THE LABORATORY
GRADE RESEARCH, THE CROWD IS
DOING VERY WELL.
ORIGINALLY, THEY THOUGHT THEY
WERE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE
DEVELOPMENT MEMBERS OF THE CROWD
TO VALIDATE EACH RESULT.
THEY HAVE GONE DOWN TO SEVEN,
EIGHT PEOPLE, LOOKING AT EACH
PIECE OF DATA TO GET QUALITY
RESULTS WANT SO DATA QUALITY IS
OFTEN RAISED ABOUT CITIZEN
SCIENCE.
THE QUALITY OF MANY CITIZEN
SCIENCE PROJECT HAS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED  IN STATISTICS.
I THINK ANY OF YOU WOULD FIND
CONVINCING.
OUR SERIES WAS ON THE AIR BACK
IN APRIL AND MAY.  AND PBS
STATIONS WILL BE RUNNING IT ON
TO THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
JUST LAST WEEKEND, WE DID A
GLOBAL
CATCH-A-31, MOBILE ON THE
STREET MAP, MAP-A-TONS, AND GIVE
THEM PIZZA.
TO DO MAPPING OF STREETS.
THIS TIME, EYES ON ALZ, 22 TOO
MANY TEAMS, SIX DIFFERENT
CONTINENTS, PLAYING A GAME,
WITHIN AN HOUR TO SEE WHO COULD
ACTUALLY CODE THE LARGEST NUMBER
OF STALLS AND YOU CAN SEE SOME
OF THE PEOPLE THERE.
GO GUATEMALA.
EL SALVADOR, CHILE, CHAIN AMP
PEOPLE WERE ON LINE, PLAYING
GAME WHEN, WE DID A LIVE ZOOM
HANG OUT.
THE WINNERS WERE ACTUALLY DOWN
IN CHILE.
YOU CAN SEE THAT THEY ANNOTATED
1955 EXAMPLES OF BRAIN SCIENCE
AND THEN THEY CELEBRATED AND
EVERYBODY GOOD GOT TO SHARE IN
THAT.
ASK THE SCIENCE HAS BECOME A
GLOBAL PHENOMENON WITH CITIZEN
SCIENCE IN AUSTRALIA, AND EUROPE
BEING STRONG.
SOME OF THE APPS DEVELOPED  IN
SPAIN ARE BEING USED HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES AS WELL.
THIS IS CALLED MOSQUITO ALERT
WITH THE CONCERN BAZOOKA.
GOING THAT CITIZENS CAN DO TO
REPORT THE AREAS IN WHICH THERE
IS A BREEDING SITE FOR MOSQUITO
SYSTEM VERY IMPORTANT.
THIS VIDEO SHOWS YOU THESE ARE
THE SITES OF TRADITIONAL
LOCATIONS OF LIVE TRAPS.
BUT THEY'RE FAIRLY LIMITED.
THIS IS THE NUMBER OF CITIZEN
SCIENTIST REPORT THAT IS CAME
IN, IN SPAIN.
SO MY TIME IS UP.
COFFEE BREAK IS LOOMING.  I'M
GOING TO JUST ZIP OVER THE NEXT
FEW THINGS, JUST TO SAY THAT
THERE IS AN NSF PROJECT USING $6
MICROSCOPES  TO ATTACH TO THE
SMART PHONES THAT ARE ALSO PART
OF TODAY'S CITIZEN SCIENCE
REVOLUTION AND THAT I'LL END IT
HERE BY SAYING IT'S A REVOLUTION
THAT IS HAPPENING, POWERED BY
PEOPLE.
IT IS REALLY ANSWERING
OCCURRENCE THE COMMUNITIES  AND
CITIZENS HAVE BUT IT'S USING THE
TOOLS OF SCIENCE.
IT'S GENERATING DATA FROM THE
ENVIRONMENT, ANALYZING T
COLLABORATE WITHING SCIENTISTS
AND DELIVERING BACK SOLUTION
THAT IS WORTH SO CITIZENS PLUS
SENSORS, WORKING FOR SOLUTIONS.
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD SUMMARY OF
WHAT TODAY CITIZEN SCIENCE S.
AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO TALK TO
ANYBODY OVER THE BREAK.
THANKS SO MUCH, LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FOR PUTTING ON.
DELIGHTED TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU WANT.
[APPLAUSE].
>> THANK YOU, JEFF.
WE ARE GOING TO BREAK FOR 15
MINUTES AND WE ARE GOING TO
START AT 3:51.
TAKE?
MOMENTS TO GET SOME COUGH AND HE
TEA.
FEEL FREE TO ENGAGE WITH THE AS
DATA THOSE TUNING INTO THE LIVE
STREAM, WE WILL BE BACK AT ABOUT
3:51 EASTERN TIME.
[BREAK TAKEN]
WELCOME BACK, EVERYONE.
WHILE WHILE WE'RE GETTING SOME
TECH STARTED, WE'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR JOINING YOU TODAY A LOT
OF TIME FEW WEEKS AGO WHOA MADE
A PUBLIC CALL FOR
RELATIONSHIPERS, LIBRARIANS AND
TECHNOLOGY GISTS TO SHARE HOW
THEY ARE PLAYING MR. CONCEPTS.
EACH OF THESE SPEAKERS WILL HAVE
5 MONTHS TALK ABOUT THEIR
PROJECTS.
WE WILL HERE FROM ESTABLISH
WEINBERGER, CHELSEA -- ED
SUMMERS, PAUL FARBER, JARED
NEILSON AND WILLIAM FERSER.
WE REREMIND YOU TO JOIN IN WITH
THE HASHTAG DATA WE'D LOVE TO
KNOW WHERE YOU ARE PHYSICALLY
AND THERE MIGHT BE A PRIZE FOR
WHOEVER IS THE FURTHERREST FROM
WASHINGTON D.
C.
>> I'M STEVEN WEINBERGER, THE
DIRECTOR OF LINGUISTICS AT
GEORGE MASON DRIVE UNIVERSITY.
I'M A FEIGNOLOGIST BY TRAINING.
WE PUT TOGETHER A LITTLE
SPEECHAC CENT DATABASE AT GEORGE
MASON UNIVERSITY.
SO HOW DOES THIS BEGIN IN THIS
1999, I GAVE AN ASSIGNMENT TO MY
PHONETICS CLASS AND THEY WERE
INTERESTED IN TEACHING
ESL SO
THEY WENT OUT AND RECORDED
NONNATIVE SPEAKERS AND WE
SYSTEMATIZE TIES TODAY AND PUT
IT ON THE WEB AND IT'S BEEN ON
THE WEB SINCE 1992.
IT HAS BEEN PICKED UP, AND WE
WANT TO THANK THEM FOR KEEP
TONGUE.
WHAT'S THE PURPOSE-ARCHIVE?
TO DEMYSTIFY AND SCIENTIFICALLY
STUDY ENGLISH ACCENTS, BY THE
WAY, AND THE DATABASE CONTINUES
TO EXPAND.
THE PURPOSE HAS CURRENTLY,
TODAY, IT
HAS 2399 SAMPLES, 3310
NATIVE BACKGROUNDS FROM ASL TO
ZULU.
175 COUNTRIES ARE REPRESENTED.
THERE'S 165,400 60 WORDS AT THE
MOMENT MUCH THAT'S USED BY A
VARIETY OF VISITORS LIKE
LINGUISTS, ESL TEACHERS, SPEECH
PATHOLOGISTS, ACTORS, AND MOST
OF THE TIME, PEOPLE DOING
DRINKING GAMES.
THESE ARE ALL THE LANGUAGES THAT
ARE REPRESENTED, LANGUAGE
BACKGROUNDS.
EVERYONE IS READING THE SAME
ENGLISH PARAGRAPH.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THE ARCHIVE A
BIT CURE RATER MEEK.
THE ARCHITECTURE INCLUDES
ILLICIT PARAGRAPH, AUDIO SAMPLE,
SOME DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION
ABOUT EACH SPEAKER, MAPS OF
LOCATIONS, PHONETIC
TRANSCRIPTIONS, WHICH I'LL SHOW
YOU A SAMPLE OF IN A MOMENT.
WHAT MAKES A GERMAN SPEAKER
DIFFERENT FROM A ZULUSPEAKER OF
ENGLISH.
SEGMENT INVENTORIES OF ENGLISH
LANGUAGE AND IT HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR REMOTE RESEARCH
TORSE SEND IN ACCENTS  FROM ALL
OVER THE WORD.
69 WORDS IN THE PARAGRAPH, THE
SAME AS THE PLEASE CALL STELLA
PARAGRAPH.
THAT'S THE WHOLE PARAGRAPH.
EVERYONE READS T. WE HAVE A
STRICTING PROTOCOL.  AND WE
REDUCE IT TO MP3, 28 BITS.
ANDLET SEE IF THIS WILL WORK FOR
YOU.
TELL ME IF YOU THINK THIS IS A
NONNATIVE.
(INAUDIBLE).
>> CAN WE TURN IT UP A LITTLE
BIT.
I'LL DO IT
AGAIN.
>> (INAUDIBLE).
>> CAN YOU HEAR ALL THAT?
>> PLEASE CALL STILL A.
>> ANYWAY, THOSE ARE THREE
NONNATIVES.
CAN YOU GUESS THE LANGUAGES?
NO.
THE FIST ONE IS EMPARIC.
SECOND ONE IS MANDARIN CHINESE
AND THE THIRD ONE IS RUSSIAN.
THE SPEAKER DEMOGRAPHICS COME
LIKE THIS.
WE ASK THEM THEIR NATIVE
LANGUAGE.
THERE ARE 310 OF THEM AT THE
HOME.
IT'S LINKED TO AN ETHNOLOG
CODE.
WE ASK WHAT OTHER LANGUAGES THEY
KNOW.
LENGTH OF ENGLISH LANGUAGE THE
GENDER AND AGE OF THE
INDIVIDUAL.
THE ENGLISH ON SET AGE AND THE
LEARNING STYLE.
EVERYONE'S ASKED THE SAME 7
QUESTIONS.
SO THIS IS ALL SEARCHABLE
INFORMATION AND THERE'S SOME
ROOM FOR SOME NOTES.
HERE'S THE PARAGRAPH.
TRAN SCRIBED WITH?
FUNNY PARAGRAPHS THAT LIPPING
WORLD IN THEATERS FRIEDS USE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO HEAR THIS.
>> BREEZE CALL STELLA.
ASK HER TO BRING THESE THINGS
WITH HER FROM THE STORE.
5 BIG BLOCKS OF BLUE CHEESE AND
MAYBE A SNACK FOR HER BROTHER,
BOB WE ALSO NEED A SMALL
PLASTIC.
>> I'M SURE YOU WERE ABLE TO
FOLLOW ALONG WITH THE PHONETICS
WE WROTE THERE FOR YOU.
THE PHONETIC INVENTORIES,
INCLUDED IN THE ARCHIVE FOR EACH
OF THE LANGUAGES, AT LEAST 210
OF THEM ARE GIVEN IN SOME FORM
LIKE THIS.
THEY'RE ALL UNIFORM AND YOU CAN
COMPARE VIETNAMESE TO ENGLISH
AND FIND OUT WHY A VIETNAMESE
SPEAKER IS DOING WHAT SHE'S
DOING WHEN SHE SPEAKS ENGLISH OR
WHY A SHERMAN SPEAKER DOES WHAT
SHE DOES WHEN SHE SPEAKS
ENGLISH.
AND THE SEARCH FACILITY LOOKS
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
CAN YOU DO POINTED SEARCHES ON
ALL THE DATA ON THE ARCHIVES.SO
FOR RESEARCH, THE DATA IS
REALLY AVAILABLE, AS A
UNIFORM,
IT'S UNIFORM SO THAT YOU CAN USE
IT TO COMPARE ONE ACCENT TO
ANOTHER.
BECAUSE EVERYONE'S READING THE
SAME THING.
IT'S TURNING INTO A MASSIVE
DATABASE.
SO A LOT SPEECH ENGINEERS ARE
ASKING FOR IT TO USE TO TRAIN
THEIR MACHINES TO UNDERSTAND
SPEECH.
AND WE ARE NOW UNDERSTANDING
WITH THE ARCHIVES, A LITTLE
BETTER WHAT, IT MEANS TO HAVE AN
ACCENT, WHAT IT MEANS TO
SCIENTIFICALLY STUDY AN ACCENT.
AND WHAT AFFECTS AN ACCENT.
SOME OF THE MOST CRUCIAL FACTORS
INVOLVED IN ACCENT.
ARE LIST RIGHT THERE.  WHAT YOUR
NATIVE LANGUAGE S WHEN YOU BEGAN
TO LEARN OR STUDY ENGLISH.
YOUR LENGTH OF RESIDENCE AND
WHERE AND YOUR LEARNING STYLE.
THANK YOU, I THINK I MADE IT
WITHIN 5 MINUTES.
[APPLAUSE]
.
>> HI, MY NAME IS CHELSEA SEVERE
AND I'M GOING TO BE TALKING TO
YOU TODAY ABOUT THE CARE BEAN
PERIODICAL.
IN MY OTHER LIFE, I AM A
PROFESSOR AT CATHOLIC UNIVERSITY
OF AMERICA, ASSISTANT PROFESSOR
IN FRENCH STUDIES.
I'M GOING TO BE TALKING TO YOU
ABOUT PERIODICALS, AND THE
CATALOG, MORE SPECIFICALLY,
ABOUT A PROJECT I'M DEVELOPING
HERE, ON A SPECIFIC HAITIAN
PERIODICAL.
THE JOURNAL OF THE HAITIAN
SOCIETY OF HISTORY,
GEOGRAPHYY
IT WAS FOUNDED IN 1923.
IT'S ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS OF
SCHOLARSHIP.
OVER 250 ISSUES, IT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT REPOSITORY OF LOCALLY
PRODUCED KNOWLEDGE.
IN ITS ACADEMIC AND SOCIAL
SCIENCE RESEARCH COMING OUT OF
HAITI.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
U.S. AND REALLY NORTH AMERICAN
AND NORTH ATLANTIC ACADEMICS
DON'T CITE IT.
THEY DON'T USE T. IT'S REALLY
RARELY USED AND READ, AND NOT
PART OF OUR ACADEMIC DISCOURSE.
SO THE QUESTION IS WHY.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF REASONS
WHY, THAT I CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE
THE TIME TO GET INTO HERE AND
THAT WOULD TAKE US HOURS  AND
HOURS  TO DISCUSS.
BUT THERE IS ONE REALLY
INTERESTING REASON WHY AND IT'S
SOMETHING I DISCOVERED WHILE
DOING MY RESEARCH HERE AT THE
LIBRARY.
AND THAT IS SPECIFICALLY, HOW
PERIODICALS EXIST IN THE LIBRARY
SPACE.
AND IN THE LIBRARY CATALOG.
PERIODICALS COME INTO THE UPON
LIBRARY, THEY ARE CATALOGS
BUFFET NOT INDECKED.
SO HERE, I HAVE A REPRODUCTION
OF THE CATALOG ENTRY FOR THE
SOCIAL SCIENCE JOURNAL AND HERE,
WE HAVE A REPRESENTATION OF A
HUNDRED YEARS OF
SCHOLARSHIP,
LOCAL, CARE BEAN UPON PRODUCTION
THAT IS IN THE CATALOG.
WE HAVE OUR SUBJECTS HEADING,
HAITI PERIODICALS AND THE TITLE
ITSELF IS QUITE EXPLANATORY.
BEYOND THAT, WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S INSIDE.
AND THIS IS AN INDICTMENT OF THE
LIBRARY CATALOG.
THIS IS PRECISELY HOW THE
CATALOG IS SUPPOSED TWO THE
PROBLEM S WE DON'T GET TON WHAT
IS INSIDE BECAUSE IT'S ON
INDEX.
THIS IS WHERE KNOWLEDGE
PRODUCTION IS HAPPEN NEGLIGENT
21ST CENTURY.
IT'S THE PRIVILEDGED MEDIUM FOR
CARIBBEAN ACADEMIC RESEARCH, AND
LOCAL SCHOLARSHIP.
WITH THIS CONTENT BEING ELISE
EISENBERG. -- LEGIBLE, IT'S NO
WONDER PEOPLE AREN'T USING IT OR
CITE T. WITH THAT IN MIND, WE
DECIDED TO COME WAY PROJECT TO
SOLVE THAT.
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
EBBING PANELED ACCESS TO THIS
JOURNAL.
AND THE IMPACT OF THIS
SCHOLARSHIP THAT THE LIBRARY
HOLDS THE LIBRARY IS ONE THE FEW
THAT HAS A NEARLY FULL
RUN-JOURNAL.WE FINISHED PHASE
ONE WHICH WAS
TO CREATE A DATABASE.
WE INDEXED EVERY ISSUE OF THE
JOURNAL, SUBJECT HEADS  AND SO
ON AND SO NOW, WE HAVE OUR
DATABASE.
AND THE FIXTURE STEP IS TO
DEVELOP A COLLABORATIVE SPACE,
AND ENGAGE WITH THE
SCHOLARSHIP.
AND HERE, I WANTED TO SHOUT OUT
SOME SITES OF PEOPLE DOING BEST
CARIBBEAN
PRACTICES HIGHWAY
MIGHT WE ENCOURAGE COLLABORATION
W INCREASE ACCESSIBILITY AND
OTHERWISE, WORK TO MAYOR OAT GAP
BETWEEN CARIBBEAN RESEARCHERS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN THE NORTH
ATLANTIC ACADEMY ^, AND THE
COMMUNITIES WE ARE COMMITTED TO
SERVING?
SOY AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO PHASE
TWO, BUILDING THIS COLLABORATIVE
SPACE, WE WANTED TO TAKE THIS
INSPARATION, WHICH IS GOING TO
TAKE
INSPIRATION.
AND MAKE IT AVAILABLE TO
RESEARCHERS NOT JUST IN THE
NORTH ATLANTIC SPACE BUT ALSO IN
THE CARIBBEAN AS WELL.
SO WE'RE ENVISIONING AN
NOTATIONS, SOMATIC GROUPINGS OF
CONTENT.
CREATING A DYNAMIC SPACE THAT
WILL IMPROVE ACCESS AND IMPACT
TO THIS CARIBBEAN PERIODICAL.
THIS IS IN THE WORKS THE STILL
IN DEVELOPMENT NOW.
SO I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM
YOU.
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS, IDEAS,
ADVICE, THOUGHTS, THIS
CONFERENCE HAS BEEN SO
ILLUMINATING FOR THAT REASON FOR
ME.
SO PLEASE, I'LL BE HERE AFTER
THE CONFERENCE B. ALSO FOR THOSE
VIRTUALLY, WHO ARE TUNING INTO
THE LIVE STREAM.
PLEASE TWEET WITH ME AND BE IN
TOUCH.
THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
.
MY NAME IS KEVIN SLOTMAN.
THE DIGITAL [INDISCERNIBLE]
MANAGER AT THE NEW YORK
PHILHARMONIC.
TODAY I'M GOING TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY, THE PHILHARMONIC
SUBSCRIBERS PROJECT.
A PRONG WE DID IN CONJUNCTION
WITH A GROUP OF SOCIOLOGISTS,
WHOSE NAMES AND A FILLATIONS YOU
SEE UP HERE.
YOU CAN TWEET US AT MESO
ARCHIVE.
BEFORE I GO INTO THE PROJECT
WANT I WANT TO BRIEFLY TALK
ABOUT THE MASS DIGITIZATION TAWE
ARE DOING.
SINCE 2008, WE'VE BEEN BEEN
SUPPORTED BY THE LEAFY
FOUNDATION TO THE TUNE OF
$5 MILLION TO, DIGITIZE EVERY
LAST SCRAP OF PAPER IN OUR
ARCHIVES.
OUR ARCHIVES GO BACK TO 1842,
AND
DOCUMENT [INDISCERNIBLE]
NORTH AMERICA.
WE HAVE FORMATS, INCLUDING
MUSIC, WE NOT ONLY HAVE SCORES
AND PARTS THAT ARE INTERESTING
IN THEIR OWN RIGHTS BUT THEY ARE
MARKED BY THE CONDUCTORS LED BY
THE NEW YORK PHILHARMONICS, AND
THOSE WHO HAVE PLAYED FOR THE
LAST 75 YEARS.
WE HAVE A COMPLETE SET OF
PROGRAMS GOING BACK TO 1842.
FROM WHICH WE HAVE ALSO
EXTRACTED DATA ABOUT A WHICH
I'LL TALK ABOUT MORE IN A
MOMENT.
PHOTOS, 10,000 FOLDERS OF
BUSINESS RECORDS  AND ARCHIVES,
RANGING  FROM MINUTES, POSTERS,
CORE RESPONDENTS.
DOWN TO RECEIPTS  AND THAT SORT
THING.
AS WELL.
70,000THOUSAND PAGE PAGES OF
PRESS
CLIPPINGS.SO THE SUBSCRIBERS
PROJECT WANT
WE HAVE INFORMATION RELATING TO
OUR SUBSCRIBERS.
PEOPLE WHO BOUGHT MORE THAN ONE
TICKET OR TICKET TO A SERIES,
DATING BACK TO 1842.
WE KNOW THEIR FAMES, THEIR
ADDRESSES, WE KNOW WHAT SEATS
THEY BOUGHT AND FOR HOW LONG
THEY WERE GENERALLED WITH THE
ORCHESTRA.
A COUPLE OF YEARS AFTER WE
LAUNCHED THE DIGITAL ARCHIVES, A
GROUP OF THE SOCIOLOGISTS
APPROACHED US AND ASKED, CAN WE
DO SOMETHING WITH THIS
DESCRIBEER DATA IT HAS BEEN
DYNEL TIESED AND IT WAS
RELATIVELY EASY, UNDERSCORING A
POINT, THERE'S A LOT HUMAN LABOR
THAT GOES TO EXTRACTING DATA
FROM THESE THINGS B. IT WAS
RELATIVELY EASY TO TAKE THESE
15TH CENTURY BOOKS AND TURN IT
INTO A NICE ADJACENT DATA SET.
THEY WERE ORIGINALLY TRYING
TO
--
[PLEASE STAND BY] WHEN THEY WERE
DONE, THEY GAVE THE DATA TO US
AND WE HAVE THIS NICE WEB
WIDGETS FOR PEOPLE WITH SELECT A
PORTION OF THE DATA AND ALSO THE
DESIRE SUBSCRIBER DATA S. IS A
DOWNLOAD, POST 1951 TO PROTECT
THE MOST RECENT FOLKS BUT ALL
THE DATA IS THERE FOR ANYBODY
WHO WANTS  TO USE IT SO WHAT DID
THE SOCIOLOGIST FIND IF WELL
WHEN, THEY GOT INTO THE DATA
THEY GAVE US A NUANCED
UNDERSTANDING OF 19TH CENTURY
SOCIAL STATUS.
I THINK THIS IS REALLY
INTERESTING TO MOST THEY USED
THE DATA TO, YOU KNOW, WE KNOW
KIND OF THE BIG PICTURE OF
GUILDEDER A SOCIAL
CONSOLIDATION, BUT THEY USED THE
DATA TO FIND SOMETHING THEY
CALLED SEGREGATED INCLUSION.
WHICH I'M GOING TO READ IT.
A FORM OF INCLUSION THAT
PRESERVES THE PURITY.
BY NOT ONLY -- IN A LIMITED WAY,
THAT REA IF ID THE HIGH CLASS
STAT STATUS OF THE ORCHESTRA.
SO THAT'S A REALLY NICE NUANCE
TWIST UNDERSTANDING, OF HOW 19TH
CENTURY SOCIAL CONGLOMERATION
WORKED IN NEW
YORK.
ALL THAT HAVE DATA IS AVAILABLE,
BOTH ON OUR WEBSITE, AT THE
PERFORMS HISTORY, AS WELL AS A
DOWNLOADABLE DATA.
AND XML DATA ON GET GET HUB SO
CAN YOU LOOK UP OUR ENTIRE
PERFORMANCE REPERTOIRE, PRETTY
MUCH UP TO DATE WHENEVER YOU
WANT.
ALL OF OUR ARCHIVES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR FREE, AT
ARCHIVES.PHILHARMONIC.ORG.
THANK YOU TO THE SOCIOLOGIST FOR
APPROACHING US AND DOING THIS
WORK.
THANKS FOR L.C. FOR HOSTING US
OUT HERE TODAY.
THANKS  TO MY
COLLEAGUES ^, AND
THE
ARCHIVES AND TO THE WILLIAM
LEAFY FOUNDATION, WHO HAVE BEEN
KIND ENOUGH TO FUND US FOR ALL
OF THIS DYNEL TEASATION.  THANK
YOU.
>> I AM GLAD TO BE HERE.
I RECORD HUNDREDS -- BETWEEN
JUNE
1952 AND 1953.
THE MATERIAL THIS JOURNEY
INCLUDES MUSIC OR MAGNETIC
TAPE.
BUT PREMIERE OF FIGHTS,
NOTEBOOKS, INVOICES, LETTERS AND
THE AMERICAN LICENSE OF THE
LOCKE.
MY RESEARCH IS TO ALLOW THE
DOCUMENTS, IN ORDER TO ESTABLISH
COLLECTIONS BETWEEN THE SONGS,
RECORDED BY [INDISCERNIBLE] AND
OTHER COLLECTIONS OF THE SPANISH
TRADITIONAL MUSIC.
SUCH AS THAT, RECEIVE AND THE
SPANISH NATIONAL RESEARCH
COUNCIL IN BARCELONA ALTHOUGH IT
INCLUDES SOME
MUSIC
-- MOST OF
THEN, THROUGH
THE
USING THE SAME
PERFORMANCE, IT IS CLEAR THAT
THE COLLECTIONS COMPLEMENT ONE
ANOTHER.
BUT TO WHAT EXTENT IS UNKNOWN.
THE BARCELONA COLLECTION HAS
BEEN DYNEL TIESED  IN A COT LOG
IN A DATABASE IN WHICH THEY HAVE
INCORPORATED [INDISCERNIBLE].
CATALOG INFORMATION ON ALL THE
SIGNS ON PASSENGER RECORDED,
INCLUDING HIS PHOTOGRAPHS  AND
LINKS.
I HAVE ALSO CATALOG AND TRIBED
DOCUMENTS SUCH AS NOTEBOOKS, AND
DIARIES, CONNECTED THEN, TO THE
MUSIC, PEOPLE AND LOCATIONS TO
WHICH THEY REFER AND INCLUDING
LINKS TO THE CORE RESPONDING
DIGITIZATION OF THE LOCKE
WEBSITE.
THE STATE HAS A COLLECTION FOR
ARC UNTIL SIS AND COMPARISON AND
IT IS POSSIBLE TO IDENTIFY
CONCURONS TO THE LOCKE, AND THAT
IN BARCELONA, LOCATIONS, MUSICAL
GENRES AND SONGS.
THE BARCELONA COLLECTION,
INCLUDES SONG BE PERFORMED BY
THIS WOMAN, FROM A SMALL VILLAIN
IN THE FORM OF TRAN SCRIPTIONS
MADE
[SINGING]
A RESEARCH TOOL
FOR INTERPRETING DATA ABOUT A
AND PREPARING ON THE MEANING OF
THESE CONCURRENCIES, AND IN
ORDER TO ASSESS, HOW THIS
NETWORK DETERMINES
[INDISCERNIBLE] AND THE MUSE AND
I CAN PEOPLE HE CHOSE TO
RECORD.
THIS DIGITAL TOOL ALSO MAKES
DATA ACCESSIBLE TO OTHER
REACHERS.
AT THE SAME TIME, THROUGH THE
DATABASE AND THE SOCIAL NETWORKS
THAT WE DISCONNECTED.
CONTRIBUTION TO SPANISH
TRADITIONAL MUSIC BECAME KNOWN,
AND APPRECIATED BY A GENERAL
AUDIENCE.
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THE
DIFFERENT APPROACH BOTH TO THE
DATABASE AND TO THE SPANISH
COLLECTION, I AM CREATING A
STORY MAP -- CONNECTING THE TOWN
TO AN EXAMPLE OF THE MUSIC
RECORDED THERE, BELONGING TO THE
MAX CONNECTION, AND A LINK TO
THE COMPLETE INFORMATION,
CONCERNING  THAT LOCATION ON THE
DATABASE.
THE MAIN PURPOSE OF THIS
APPLICATION IS TO MAKE DATA MORE
VISUAL, NOT ONLY TO RESEARCHERS,
BUT ALSO TO OTHER AUDIENCE
OUTSIDE THE CABINET CONTEXT.
AS EARACHEER, I HAVE BENEFITED
FROM MAKING THE COLLECTION
AVAILABLE AS DATA.
I AM ABLE TO ANALYZE, COMPARE
AND INTERPRET INFORMATION IN
ORDER TO PRODUCE ACADEMIC
PUBLICATIONS.
AT THE SAME TIME.
THE ACCESSIBILITY OF THE
COLLECTION AND VISUAL IS
RESEARCHABLE AND INTERACTIVE
WAYS THROUGH THE DISABILITIES
ADVISORY BOARD, AND THE MAP
APPLICATION ALLOWS THE
PERFORMANCE AND THE COMMUNITY IN
GENERAL TO USE AND ENJOY THESE
MAGNIFICENT COLLECTIONS,
INCREASING SOCIOLOGICAL IMPACT.
THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
.
>> THIS IS A PICTURE OF A BUNCH
OF NUMBERS.
, I GUESS IT'S A JOKE.
BUT IMAGINE THIS IS A FILE,
RIGHT AND WHAT I'M HOPING  TO DO
IN THE NEXT 5 MINUTES IS
CONVINCE YOU THAT THIS IS A
COLLECTION OF DATA AND NOT ONLY
THAT, IT IS A USEFUL COLLECTION
OF DATA SO I WORK ON A PROJECT
CALLED DOCUMENTING THE NOW,
WHICH IS A MELON FUNDED PROJECT
TO HELP BUILD SOCIAL MEDIA
ARCHIVING TOOLS AND PRACTICES.
AND WITH A PARTICULAR FOCUS ON
TWITTER, WHICH IS KIND OF A
THIRD RAIL KIND OF TOPIC
HERE.MY COLLABORATOR, I WORK
WITH
BURGESS JEWELS AND MAYBE SOME OF
YOU REMEMBER HIS TALK.
THIS IS ONE SLIDE THAT HE
HAD.
THAT HE SHOWED AND BURGESS, WHEN
HE WAS HERE, WAS REALLY TRYING
TO IMPRESS ON EVERYONE, THE
IMPORTANCE OF DOING SOCIAL MEDIA
ARCHIVING IN THE CONTEXT OF
LARGE STATE AND CORPORATE ACTORS
THAT ARE ALSO DOING SOCIAL MEDIA
ARCHIVING FOR THE PURPOSES OF
SURVEILLANCE AND CONTROL.
AND SO OUR PROJECT IS INTERESTED
IN MEMORY, RIGHT.
REMEMBERING SOCIAL MEDIA FOR THE
PURPOSES OF CULTURAL MEMORY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE HAVE
ACTORS LIKE GEO FEED YEAH, WHO
ARE SORT OF BUILDING SOCIAL
MEDIA COLLECTIONS THAT THEY ARE
THEN ADVERTISING
TO INCISE DISIN
CALIFORNIA.
THEY CAN UPON HAD THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT MANAGE THE FERGUSON
SITUATION, RIGHT?
SO THE COURT AND JURY THAT WE
WERE WORKING ON IS HOW DO WE DO
SOCIAL MEDIA ARCHIVING WHILE
THIS IS GOING ON.
HOW DO WE DO IT IN AN ETHICAL
WAY THAT SORT OF RESPECTS THE
VOICES AND THE CONTENTED OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE CREATING THE
CONTENT.
THAT'S KIND OF THE CHALLENGE WE
HAVE
HAD.
S  TO NO REAL TECHNICAL SOLUTION
THAT'S REALLY GOING TO DO IT FOR
US.
BUT WE FOUND THAT ONE SILVER
LINING WE FOUND WAS IN TWEETER'S
TERMS OF SERVICE ITSELF.
THEY ACTUALLY DON'T ALLOW
PEOPLE.
SO HAVE YOU TO AGREE TO THE
TERMS OF SERVICE TO GET DATA
FROM TWITTER AND ONE OF THE
RULES THAT THEY HAVE IS THAT YOU
CAN'T DOWNLOAD DATA AND JUST
SORT OF PUT IT ON WEB, RIGHT?
YOU CAN'T DOWNLOAD MILLIONS OF
TWEETS  AND PUT THEM IN INTERNET
ARCHIVES BECAUSE I MEAN, FOR
THEM, IT'S SORT OF A BUSINESS
DECISION.
THEY HAVE REASONS THAT THEY
DON'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN.
ONE OF THE INTERESTING THINGS
THEY DO LET YOU DO IS TAKE A
FILE OF TWEET I.D'S.
EACH TWEET HAS A NUMERIC
IDENTIFIER, AND THEY DO ALLOW
YOU TO DISTRIBUTE THOSE AND YOU
KNOW, WHAT YOU CAN DO WITH A
TWEET IDENTIFIER IS GO BACK TO
TWITTER'S API AND GET THE DATA
FOR THAT TWEET AND THE
INTERESTING THING TAHAPPENS
THERE IS IF THE TWEET HAS BEEN
DELETED OR IF THE USER HAS
DECIDED TO PROTECT THIS ACCOUNT
OR DELETE THEIR ACCOUNT.
YOU CAN NO LONGER GET THAT
TWEET.
SO IT KIND OF EMPOWERS THE
USER.
GIVES THEM SOME LEVER OF CONTROL
OVER HOW THEIR CONTENT IS USED
ELSEWHERE ON THE
WEB.
THIS IS THE FIRST APPLICATION
THAT I WAS GOING TO MENTION,
CALLED THE COT LOG AND REALLY
ALL THE CATALOG S IT'S REALLY
JUST A WEB PAGE THAT LISTS DATA
SETS, WITH TWEET I.D.'S, THAT
DITCH RESEARCHERS HAVE CREATED
FOR DIFFERENT RESEARCHERS.
I PUT THEM IN ONE PLACE SO THAT
OTHER RESEARCHERS CAN FIND TEMSO
THEY HAVE A DESCRIPTION OF THE
DATA SET.
WHO CREATE IT WHAT DATE
RANGE
WHY THEY CREATE IT.
AND A REPOSITORY, SO THIS IS
JUST A CLEARING HOUSE FOR THE
DATA SET THAT IS LIVE ELSEWHERE
AND THEY CAN DOWNLOAD IT.
SO ONCE YOU DOWNLOAD IT.
YOU END UP WITH SOMETHING LIKE
THIS, A FILE WITH A BUNCH OF
CONTINUES IN IT.
AND SO THE APPLYING, I THOUGHT
I'D MENING REALLY QUICK, THE
HYDRATOR APPLICATION, WHICH
BASICALLY, IT'S A DESKTOP
APPLICATION.
YOU DOWNLOAD AND RUN ON YOUR OWN
WORK STATION.
IT WILL READ A DATA SET FILE.A
DATA SET OF TWEET ID'S, AND
HYDRATE THEM WANT SO TURN THEM
BACK INTO THE DATA THAT IS
USEFUL FOR RESEARCH.
AND ONE OF THE, THINGS IT WILL
DO IS CONVERT THE TWITTER.
IT'S LIKE A FORMAT IS USED FOR
ALL KINDS OF ANALYSIS.
THAT'S REALLY THE MAJORITY OF
WHAT I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT.THANKS FOR
YOUR
TIME.
[APPLAUSE].
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, I'M PAUL
FARBER, I'M THE ARTISTIC
DIRECTOR OF MONUMENT LAB, A
PUBLIC ART AND HISTORY PROJECT
BASED IN PHILADELPHIA.
THANK YOU TO LOCKE FOR HOSTING
US ALL TODAY.
IN MY DAY JOB, I'M A HISTORIAN
AND CURE RATER AND I REPRESENT
AND LEAD A COLLECTIVE OF
SCHOLARS, CURATORS, ARTISTS AND
TUNES AROUND THIS PROJECT SINCE
2014.
AND WE'RE INTERESTED IN BUILDING
TEMPORARY MONUMENTS IN PUBLIC
SPACES.
AND DATA SETS TAEPIDURAL IN
LIBRARIES AND ON LINE.
AS OPEN DATA WE'RE GEARING UP
FOR A BIG FALL 2017 CITY WIDE
EXHIBITION IN PHILADELPHIA WITH
THE MURAL ARTS
PROGRAM.WHAT
IS AN APPROPRIATE MONUMENT
FOR THE CITY OF PHILADELPHIA.
WE HAVE A CITY FULL OF PUBLIC
ART, AND STATUES, MURAL.
BUT SOMETIMES -- THANK YOU.
WE NEED ASSISTANCE TO FILL IN
WHAT IS THERE.
SO THIS PROJECT IS ONE WHERE WE
USE THIS QUESTION TO INVITE
PEOPLE IN.
WE ASK ARTISTS TO BUILD
TEMPORARY MONUMENTS AND WE ASK
THIS TO THE PUBLIC AS A WAY TO
MEASURE BOTH THE EXPECTED OR THE
MUNICIPAL AND ALSO UNDERSTAND
THE POSSIBLE, THE DREAMED, THE
SPECULATIVE, THE HAUNTS OF THE
CITY, TO HAVE A MORE COMPLETE
VISION OF OUR HISTORICAL
LANDSCAPE.
WE'RE WORKING WITH 20 ARTISTS
FROM AROUND THE WORLD AND AROUND
PHILADELPHIA, WHO ARE GOING TO
BE BUILDING NEED MONUMENTS IN
PUBLIC SPACES.
SOME WILL USE THE KIND OF
TRADITIONAL
FORMAT BRONZE,
GRANITE.
BUT OTHERS ARE GOING TO BUILD
THEIR MONUMENTS WITH SOUND,
LIGHTS, PERFORMS,
INTERACTIVITY.
MANY OF THESE ARTISTS, TAKE ON
ISSUES OF SOCIAL JUSTICE,
ESPECIALLY AROUND RACE, GENDER,
SEXUALITY, CLASS, NATIONAL
BELONGING, TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
MONUMENTAL LANDSCAPE REPRESENTS
A CITY FOUNDED ON FREEDOM,
JUSTICE AND TOLERATION.
THEIR WORKS WILL BE CITED AROUND
THE CITY OF PHILADELPHIA AND
THERE ARE FIVE CENTRAL SQUARE
THAT IS GO BACK TO THE 1680'S
AND FIVE NEIGHBORHOOD PARKS.
AT EACH OF THESE SIGHTS, THERE'S
AT -- AT EACH OF THESE CITES
THERE'S AT LEAST ONE TEMPORARY
MONUMENT AND A RESEARCH LAB
WHERE WE USE THIS FORM.
ON THIS FORM, WE THE PUBLIC TO
NAME THEIR MONUMENTS.
PLACE IT SOMEWHERE IN THE CITY
AND ADDRESS AN INTERSECTION, A
NEIGHBORHOOD, THOUGH THAT OFTEN
IS BROKEN.
YOU'LL SEE IN A MOMENT.
WE ALSO ASK THEM IN A BIG OPEN
SPACE TO DESCRIBE OR SKETCH.
IN ADDITION, IF PEOPLE WANT TO
LEAVE THEIR HOME ZIP CODE, THEIR
AGE, THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA HANDLE,
THEY CAN ADD THAT ON AS WELL.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME WE
HAVE DONE THIS.
BACK IF 2015, IN THE COURTYARD
OF CITY HALL, WE HAD OUR
DISCOVERY PHASE, THANK TO THE
ARTS  AND HERITAGE.
HERE, OUR TEMPORARY MONUMENT
BITE LATE TERRY ATKINS WAS AN
EMPTY CLASSROOM TO COMMENT ON
EDUCATIONAL PRIDE THAT WE HAVE
IN THE CITY, AND ALSO FACT OF
BUDGET CUTS AND SCHOOL CLOSURES
THAT MARKED OUR CURRENT
SCIENTIFIC LANDSCAPE.
IN ADDITION TO THIS CLASSROOM,
WE HAD THE DIFFER KIND OF
CLASSROOM.
THE LEARNING LAB WHERE TEAMS
MOSTLY OF YOUTH
RESEARCHERS
WOULD GATHER PUBLIC PROPOSALS.
IN THE 3-1/2 WEEKS THAT WE WERE
IN THE CITY COURTYARD, WE
HAD 4
FIGHT PEOPLE, LEAVE MONUMENT
PROPOSALS.
AND OVER 30,000 PEOPLE VISIT THE
MONUMENT.
O ONE ON ONE HAND, EACH PIECE
MATTER IT IS AND THE DATA SET AS
A
WHOLE.SOME SNAPSHOTS HERE
DANCING WITH
LOVE IN YOUR STEP.
RIGHT IN THE HEART OF THE CITY.
DOOR-TO-DOOR, AN ENGINE TIVE
PORTAL BETWEEN NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND THE CITY OF BROTHERLY LOVE,
I DON'T LOVE YOU, BUT I ...
[LAUGHTER]
OF COURSE, THERE'S POINT IANT
AND OTHER IMPORTANT FORMS OF
TRUTH TELLING.
SOMEBODY WHO'S WARY OF THE
MURDER CRISIS IN OUR CITY,
CALLED ATTENTION TO THE SHRINES
AROUND THE CITY AND SITES OF
VIOLENCE.
OTHERS WERE MORE POETIC.
BLURRING THE BOUNDARY BETWEEN A
VISION OF A STATUE OR JUST AN
EXCHANGE BETWEEN PHILADELPHIANS
AND THEN OF COURSE, THE
COMPLEX.
LIKE CLAUS OLDERBERG SAID,
COMPOSING MONUMENT SYSTEM LIKE
COMPOSING WITH A CITY.
IN ADDITION TO THE INDIVIDUALS,
CAN YOU SEE THE DATA SET.
YOU CAN SEE IT ON A MAP, ACROSS
THE CITY.
WE HAVE ALSO TRANSCRIBED AND
ANALYZED A LEVEL OF
CLASSIFICATION, ON OPEN DATE.THE
PORTAL FOR CIVIC DATA IF THE
CITY.
WE WRITE THE HISTORY OF OUR CITY
TOGETHER AND WE TAKE UP THE CALL
FOR CULTURAL HER TABLE ORGANIZES
TO FIND NEW WAYS TO BRING IN
VOICES, PEOPLE AND DATA, NOT
JUST TO BE POWERED BY
IMAGINATION BUT ALSO TO
CO-AUTHOR THE NEXT CHAPTERS OF
OUR CITY'S HISTORY.
THANK
YOU.
[APPLAUSE].
>> CAN WE SWITCH TO THE MAC.
THANK YOU.
HI, MY NAME IS JARED NEILSON.I'M
AN ARTIST AND INSTRUCTOR AT
GEORGE WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY,
WHERE I TEACH FULL STACK WEB
DEVELOPMENT.
I RECENTLY DISCOVERED THE
DIGITAL COLLECTIONS AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC ON LC'S, WEBSITE.
IF YOU HAVEN'T DISCOVERED IT
YOURSELF.
I HIGHLY RECOMMEND BROWSING THIS
YOU'LL LOSE HOURS OF YOUR DAY.
IT'S A FANTASTIC COLLECTION.
THERE'S ONE COLLECTION IN
PARTICULAR THAT CAUGHT MY EYE
WANT THIS PICTORIAL ST. LOUIS.
IT'S A SERIES OF PLATES
PUBLISHED AS AN ATLAS IN 1975
BITE ARTIST, CAMILLE DRY.
THIS WAS CREATED AT THIS AT THE
SAME TIME AS AN ACTIVE
BOOSTERISM BITE CITY WHEN THEY
WERE MAKING A BID TO BECOME THE
NATION'S CAPITAL.
THEY THOUGHT THEIR POSITION ON
THE MISSISSIPPI, BEING A MASSIVE
TRADE ECONOMIC ROUTE WAS MORE
SUITABLE FOR OUR NATION'S FUTURE
THAN THIS CURRENT
SWAMP.
SO THESE PLATES ARE INCREDIBLY
DETAILED AND BEAUTIFUL.
WHAT WAS REALLY INTERESTING WHEN
I FOUND THESE IS THAT THERE'S NO
TECHNOLOGY USED IN THEIR
CREATION.
THERE'S NO AIRPLANE, THERE'S NO
HOT HAIR BALLOON.
THIS WAS ALL CAMILL DRY, AND HIS
TEAM, BEATING THE PAVEMENT,
MAKING THESE RECORDS AND THEN
TRANSPOSING THEIR 2D DATA INTO A
3D AERIAL PERSPECTIVE
REPRESENTATION.
HERE'S A LITTLE MORE OF THE
DETAIL
HERE.
SO THE ATLAS WAS PUBLISHED WITH
A KEY THAT SHOWS YOU WHICH PLATE
WHERE THEY LINE UP WITH THEIR
GEOGRAPHIC POSITION IN
RELATIONSHIP TO ST.
LOUIS.
MANY OF THE PLATES
HERE, LET ME
JUST CORRECT
THIS SO.
BECAUSE THESE WERE ALL HAND
DRAWN, SOME OF THE PLATES HAVE
THESE INTERESTING FEATURES WHERE
A LANDMARK IS BREAKING THE
FRAME.
AND I WANTED TO KEEP THIS WHEN I
L FIRST WHEN, I DISCOVERED THIS,
I WANTED TO DO SOMETHING WITH
THIS I WANTED TO SEE ALL THE
PLATES STITCHED TOGETHER AS ONE
LARGE
MAP WHEN STITCHING THESE
TOGETHER, THERE ARE A LOT OF
THESE BREAKS WITH THE FRAME.
SO I CLEANED UP ALL OF THESE,
BUT I LEFT THESE LANDMARK
DETAILS AND INSERTED SOME SPACE
INTO MAP AND I HAD TO CONVERT IT
TO GRAY SCALE BECAUSE THIS
BECAME SUCH A MASSIVE IMAGE
FILE, THAT THE ONLY WAY FOR ME
TO PULL THIS OFF IS TO STRIP OUT
ALL THE COLOR OF DATA AND GO
GRAY SCALE WANT SO THIS IS THE
SMALL VERSION MCNEALLY, WHICH IF
ANYONE HERE WORKS WITH DIGITAL
IMAGES, 64,000 BY 26,000 PIXELS
WAS A MONSTER.
THE SIZE ROUGHLY WAS
900-MEGABYTES.
IT WAS
HUGE.
I HAVE A WHACK ROUND, IN
EXHIBITS I TRIED RUNNING THIS
THROUGH THOSE PROGRAMS AND IT
WAS JUST KILLING
THEM MY GOAL IS
TO KEEP THIS INTERACTIVE IN A
WAY WHERE THE DETAIL WOULDN'T BE
LOST BUT WE COULD ALSO HAVE THIS
PULLED OUT GLOBAL
SCOPE.
IT'S AN OPEN SOURCE JAVA SCRIPT
LIBRARY, THAT HAS REALLY GREAT
ROBUST TUTORIALS, AND VERY, VERY
EASY
AND SIMPLE TO IMPLEMENT.
AND I FOUND THESE FANTASTIC
REPOWS  ON GITA HUB THAT HELPED
ME PIECE TOGETHER THESE -- THE
LEAFLET IS INTENDED SPECIFICALLY
FOR GEOGRAPHIC MAPS FOR
GEOSPATIAL DATA ABSTRACTION
LAYERS.
SO I FOUND THIS ONE HERE, RAFTER
CORD, THAT WAS
KEY.
THIS IS THE LEAST DYNAMIC
SLIDE.
THIS IS MY PHYLA TREE.
I NEEDED TO SUPPLIES THAT BIG
IMAGINE UP INTO SMALLER TILES.
HERE CAN YOU SEE HOW THE TILES
ARE NESTED.
THIS IS LIKE, THE LEVELS, AND
THESE ARE ALL THE THUMB NAILS.WE
HAVE ALL HAD THIS EXPERIENCE
WHEN WE'RE ON A SLOW DATA
CONNECTION AND WE'RE USING
GOOGLE MAPS  AND WE SEAT LITTLE
SQUARES, POP UP AND THEN THEY
SLOW AND THEY COME INTO FOCUS.
THAT'S MAP TILING IN ACTION.
THIS IS WHAT MAP TILING LOOKS
LIKE ON A
SERVER.
THIS IS 0, 0 IN OUR
ACCORDNANTS.
WE'RE GOING TO ZOOM IN ON
0, 0
SO MY MAP HAD 8 LAYERS AND WE
ZOOMED THROUGH 8 LAYERS.
MY TIME IS UP.
JAVA SCRIPT IS AWESOME.
THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY
YOU CAN IMPLEMENT THE MAP
YOURSELF.
I NEEDED HELPY SO I ASKED THE
LIBRARIAN FOR SOME BACKGROUND
INFORMATION IF YOU HAVEN'T USED
ASK A
LIBRARIAN, I RECOMMEND T.
IN LESS THAN A WEEK, I RECEIVED
THE PERTINENT INFORMATION I
NEEDED.
THIS IS THE FINAL END
RESULT IF
YOU WANT TO SEE IT IN ACTION.CAN
YOU DO SO AS THIS URL.
I WROTE A TUTORIAL ON MEDIUM
THAT YOU CAN FIND HERE.
THANK
YOU.
>> BILL FIRSTER, I'M WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF VIRGINIA AT, IT'S
THE 16S HUMANITIES, ARTS AND
HUMANITIES TECHNOLOGY
INITIATIVE.
IT'S KIND
OF SO ANYWAY, I'VE
COME HERE TO SHOW YOU A TOOL
CALLED VISUALIZE.
IT'S A DESIGNED BY US FOR USE IF
TWO DIFFERENT AREAS.
ONE WAS FOR TEACHING CLASSES,
INTERACTIVELY, IN A PROJECT
BASED SETTING.
PRETTY MUCH LIKE WHAT YOU SAW,
THE PEOPLE DOING THE STUDENTS
EARLIER AND ALSO, WE USE IT FOR
MAKING SCHOLARLY ARGUMENTS,
USING PRIMARY SOURCES SO WE
CONNECTED A TIME
LINE A STORY
PANEL AND A SLIPPY MAP,
ALTOGETHER AND PUT IT
IN AND CAN
YOU OVERLAY THINGS ON TOP OF
IT.
SO CAN YOU HAVE, YOU KNOW, DOTS
OR THINGS ON TOP OF IT.
YOU CAN HAVE INTERACTIVE
GRAPHICS.
KML
FILES, OR SORT MAPS AND THAT
BECOMES QUITE USEFUL.
SO ALSO, WE HAVE GOT A VARIETY
OF OTHER KINDS OF TOOLS TO MAKE
YOUR PRESENT EGGS.
SO THIS IS A DRAWING TOOL BUILT
IN SO CAN YOU DRAW THINGS ON IT
AND CAN YOU KIND OF PAN AND ZOOM
MAPS.
THIS TOOL, BASICALLY, IT'S ALL
WEB-BASED, AND IT'S VERY EASY TO
USE AND THE IDEA IS, INSTEAD OF
THINGS LIKE ARC GIS, WHICH ARE
VERY ROBUST TOOLS FOR DOING
GEOGRAPHIC INFORMATION TYPE
WORK.
THESE ARE EASILY USED BY
HUMANITY SCHOLARS OR BY
STUDENTS.
THE KEY, WE HAVE SET IT UP.
AND TRIED TO USE A VERY
DISTRIBUTED PROCESS.
THE UVA WE HAD A -- WE JUST USED
ALL DATABASES BACK THEN AND
THESE VERY COMPLEXES,
DATABASES.
AND WHAT REALLY CAME DOWN,
TYPICALLY, HAVE A BIG TABLE FOR
THE MOST PART AND IT'S AN X
NUMBER OF FIELDS AND A WHOLE
BUNCH OF EVENTS.
WHAT WE DID, WE DON'T NEED ALL
THAT COMPLICATED DATABASE.
LET'S TRY AND USE A
SPREADSHEET.
NOW, THE ADVANTAGE OF USING A
SPREADSHEET, GOOGLE HAS BUILT IN
ALL THESE INCREDIBLE SHARING
TECHNIQUES, WITHIN THE
SPREADSHEET AND THE SPREADSHEET
IS CONNECTED LIVE TO THE
VISUALIZATION.
THEY TOLD ME, ACTUALLY, I
COULDN'T USE THE INTERNET SO I
WOULD HAVE SHOWN IT LIVE OUT
HERE.
BUT THE IDEA IS YOU CHANGE ONE
THING ON THE SPREADSHEET, AND IT
CHANGES ON THE VISUAL IATION AND
PEOPLE HAVE MORE, YOU KNOW,
AUTONOMY WITH THEIR DATA AND FOR
CLASS ROOM USE, IT WORKS OUT
QUITE
WELL ACTIVITY FUNDED BY
NEH, WHICH FUNDED US IN A